US TODAY IT'S AN HONOR TO HOLD
THIS JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WITH MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
WHOSE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. HAVING
OUR COMMITTEES HOLD THIS
DISCUSSION TOGETHER IS A
TESTAMENT TO THE WIDESPREAD
REACH AND THE IMPACTS OF
HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH. AND
EQUALLY WIDESPREAD
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE TO SIX
SOLUTIONS TO THIS CRISIS. AND
IT IS A CRISIS. YOU WILL HEAR
THAT FROM MANY OF OUR SPEAKERS
TODAY. LAST MONTH GOVERNOR NEW
SOME SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TO CREATE A NEW FUND AIMED AT
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS BY
FOCUSING ON PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION. PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES IN CREATING
NEW TEMPORARY HOUSING. IT'S
VITAL THAT WE INCLUDE YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS. IN RECENT
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. THESE EFFORTS
HAVE INCLUDED A REQUIREMENT
THAT CERTAIN PERCENTAGES OF
RECENTLY ALLOCATED FUNDS WE SET
ASIDE TO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. BUT DESPITE
THESE RECENT EFFORTS WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS STILL
MORE WORK TO BE DONE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION RECEIVES
ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THAT ARE TAILORED TO THEIR
UNIQUE NEEDS. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HEAR FROM PROVIDERS DECISION
MAKERS FROM THE YOUTH WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
FIRSTHAND TO SET THE FOUNDATION
OF DEFINING AND IDENTIFYING
HOMELESS YOUTH. WE WILL LEARN
ABOUT THE WORK BEING DONE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AMONG OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE HOW RECENT
INVESTMENTS TRANSLATE INTO
ADEQUATE OR PERHAPS INADEQUATE
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR THIS
POPULATION. AND REVIEW PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO OUR
YOUTH TO ASSESS THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS. WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT WHAT
GAPS EXIST IN THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THE HIGH RATES OF
YOUTH LIVING ON THE STREETS.
ADD TO A DOUBLE THE NEXT STEPS
FOR CALIFORNIA TO FURTHER
SUPPORT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
FINALLY WE WILL LOOK TOWARDS
THE FUTURE AND DISCUSS IDEAS
NEEDS AND PROGRAMS. WE'LL LOOK
AT PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY TO BETTER SERVE OUR
HOMELESS ON HOUSE AND COUCH
SURFING YOUTH. I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING TODAY-
WE HAVE SOME WONDERFUL
PANELISTS THAT ARE GOING TO-
PROVIDE THEIR INSIGHT IN ALL
THE AREAS THAT WE'VE JUST
TALKED ABOUT AND I WANT TO
THANK THEM. AS THEY SAY IN
SPANISH THEN THE MONO
BEFOREHAND FOR COMING TO SPEND
SOME TIME HERE WITH US ON SUCH
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC. AND NOW I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE CHAIR OF. THE
OTHER PART OF THIS JOINT- EVER-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND- FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST-
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF- THIS IS-
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT HAS BEEN
LONG IN COMING- I THINK BOTH
FROM ISRAEL'S MYSELF AND MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES WE
UNDERSTAND- THE INTERSECTION
ALLEY OF SO MANY POLICY. AS YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT SAYS. THE LACK
OF HOUSING. AND YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
SOCIAL SAFETY NET. AND THE
APPROPRIATE HUMAN SERVICES TO
ADDRESS IT. WOULD CERTAINLY- IS
THE CHAIR IT LAID OUT A NUMBER
OF THINGS I WAS GOING TO SAY
SO. I'M NOT GONNA REPEAT IT
EXCEPT FOR THE ONE POINT THAT.
THE HOMELESSNESS IS THE MORAL
DILEMMA OF OUR DAY I AND- IS
NOT ONLY THE TOP PRIORITY FOR
MANY OF US IN THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK IT IS A TOP. ISSUE FOR
OUR CONSTITUENTS I AND- WE'VE
ALL BEEN HORRIFIED AT THE
EPIDEMIC OF HOMELESSNESS SAY WE
ARE TEAM ON OUR STREETS. AND IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND NOT JUST.
IN GENERAL BUT IN PARTICULAR
THE MOST TRAGIC FACE OF
HOMELESSNESS WITCHES OUR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE- WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS. FOR YOUNG PERCENT
CREATES LONG TERM TRAUMA THAT
THAT IN THE BILL WILL CARE. FOR
THE REST. ARE WE WITH THAT IS
YOU HOMELESS. PERSON THAT SICK.
AND YOUR LIFE OF THE HOMELESS
AS AN ADULT. AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY-
HOMELESS YOUTH BECOME HOMELESS-
WHETHER THEY ARE TRANSITIONING
OUT OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM-
WE HAVE TOO MANY LGBTQ YOUTH.
WHO ARE LEAVING- DIFFICULT-
FAMILY SITUATIONS- WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY HOMELESS YOUTH
WHO ARE FLEEING ABUSE VIOLENCE
IN THEIR HOMES. AND WE KNOW.
THATHOMELESS YOUTH. LIVING
WITH ALMOST FAMILIES ARE OFTEN
TIMES- THE VICTIM OF POVERTY
AND INCOME INEQUALITY THESE ARE
ALL OF A VARIETY OF IN A
SPECTRUM OF REASONS WHY. YOUNG
PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS- AND
THAT IS REALLY THE PURPOSE OF
THIS HEARING TO FIGURE OUT- HOW
IS IT THAT WE ADDRESS THE-
AREAS NEEDS. OF FOR POPULATION
WITH PREVENTION WITH EARLY
INTERVENTION. FORTY PANEL AND
REST ASSURE A COLLEAGUES ONLY
FOR THE CHAIRMAN OF SERVICE.
WILL BE CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER THIS YEAR BEYOND
INITIAL YES BUT THAT TURNED
BACK BETTER. MISTER CHAIR. AND
YOU ARE CON CALL LIKE TO
PROVIDE YES STONE THANK YOU TOO
BYE OF OUR CHURCH THIS IS THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT IN AS THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE PAST YEARS.
AS WELL ACTUALLY ASSEMBLY GOES
BACK EVEN FURTHER THAN THAT
BECAUSE THE SOMEBODY'S MADE
HOUSING A PRIORITY. BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS WE HAVEN'T SEPARATED
IS THAT ISSUE AROUND HOMELESS
YOU AND- TRYING TO FIND DEAL
WITH HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST. A MATTER OF PUTTING A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS BUT IT'S
ULTIMATELY LOOKING AT THE ROOT
CAUSES A LOT OF WHICH GOES BACK
TO TRAUMA. AND VERY DIFFICULT
FAMILY SITUATIONS SO THAT YOUTH
AND UPBEAT ON THE TILE WELFARE
SYSTEM IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THEY END UP HOMELESS.
FOR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
REASONS AND- IF WE ARE GOING TO
BREAK THOSE CYCLES WE HAVE TO
HELP THE FAMILIES WE HAVE TO
HELP THE CHILDREN. AND THEN
THAT. REDUCES THE AMOUNT WHO
WILL. TEND TO FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS. FUTURE SO FOR
THIS POPULATION. PROPER LEVEL
SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
IS COMMON. THERE IN REAL. TO IT.
IN WHAT'S YOUTH AND SPECIAL. TO
FOR YOU WHICH WHICH WE REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN AND EVEN FROM THE
LATEST PROPOSALS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. AS WE VAST TO
PUT A TO ADDRESS HOMELESS YOUTH
IN THE BUDGET THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HASN'T HAPPENED. SO
UNLESS WE'RE WILLING TO RAISE
THE QUESTIONS AS WE ARE HERE
WHICH I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
AND LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO OUR HOMELESS YOUTH
POPULATIONS THAT I'M AFRAID
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
OVERLOOKED. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR DOING THIS LET'S KEEP
OUR YOUTH. FOREMOST AS WE THINK
LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS. THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS A COLLECTION WE CAN.
THIS IS A POPULATION WE CAN
HELP BUT WE HAVE TO BE
DEDICATED TO DO THAT AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS COMMITTEE HEARING IS
ABOUT AND I'M- VERY HAPPY TO BE
A PART OF IT THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU ALSO FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THE CONTENT
CARE- LEGISLATION OVER THE
YEARS. THIS IS BEEN AN AREA
THAT YOU'VE BEEN VERY CONCERNED
WITH AND YOU'VE TAKEN THE STEPS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS IT
TO. YOU FOR THAT. ANY OTHER UP.
MISTER GIBSON. OKAY VERY MADAM
CHAIRMAN THANK BY YOURSELF AND
ALSO MISTER TO APPLICABLE ONE
CONVENE THIS INFORMATION
HEARING ON THIS IS CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE THAT I- VERY MUCH A PART
OF AND VERY CONCERNED WITH-
WHEN I WAS ELECTED I DID
HOMELESS YOUTH WHO- GO TO A
FOUR YEAR COLLEGE AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE PUT OUT WHEN
THEY GET HOUSING DURING THE
RECESS BREAK IT SO NOW WE
MANDATES- OF ALL UNIVERSITIES
TO PROVIDE RIGHT. I'M SHELTER
FOR STUDENTS WHO ATTEND
STUDENTS WHOSE ATTENDING SCHOOL
THERE WHICH IS AGAIN ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT I SPENT AND I WOULD
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS EVERY
YEAR. IT'S ALWAYS THIRDS INTO
MY WE DO I DO THIS BECAUSE IT'S
A- THAT I HAVE A STEP IN TERMS
OF PEOPLE ARE. WITH ARE GOING
THROUGH. AND SO IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- THE FIRST OF MARCH IS
THE COLDEST MONTH OF RECORD AND
SO WE DO THIS- MANY YOU KNOW MY
STORY MIKE MY GOT SON IS
HOMELESS- DUE TO A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT- TRAUMAS THAT GO IT
WENT ON TREAT IT- NOW OF
CRYSTAL. METH AND ALSO HOMELESS
AND SO. SHE WAS VERY. AND SO
I'M IN THIS SPACE BUT- THE
FIGHT IS THIS. AND SO MY
COMMITMENT IS TO ONE LEARNING
TO HEAR FROM THE PANEL. OF
EXPERTS TO GIVE US A GREATER
INSIDE TERMS WHAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING THAT WE MAY NOT BE DOING.
TO TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT THIS
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONVENING. THIS VERY IMPORTANT
PADDLE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND THE SERIAL SO.
SPECIAL WITH OUR FOSTER YOUTH.
WESLEY MONTH THANK YOU AGAIN
YOU KNOW ALSO THINKING ABOUT
BEING A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
IS LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT COMMUNITY AFTER
COMMUNITY WHERE WE SEE THAT THE
NUMBER OF YOUTH WHO ARE WE
WE'RE IDENTIFYING AS HOMELESS.
I'M IS INCREASING AND SO REALLY
I THINK THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES ARE
LOOKING THE STATE TO PROVIDE
DIRECT BECAUSE WE TALK TO FOLKS
WE WANT TO. REALLY PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE BOOK YOU ALSO
KNOW THAT IT'S- AN ISSUE THAT
IS RISING- AND SO I'M ABLE TO
EACH OTHER IF YOU AS CHAIR IS A
FOR. CONVERT AND RICHARD WHAT
IS OUT OF THIS. THANK YOU. OPEN
STATEMENTS MUST QUIRK SILVA
AGAIN JUST REPEAT THAT THE
HAPPY TO BE HERE TO LEARN SOME
OF THE INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
PRESENTED BUT AGAIN AS A FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER I THINK THE
TRAINING AND INFORMATION GETS
DIRECTLY NOT ONLY TO THE
TEACHERS BUT THE- LIAISONS THAT
ARE WORKING WITHIN THE SCHOOLS
SO THAT THEY CAN HELP IDENTIFY.
A STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS ESSENTIAL THIS
ISN'T THE TOPIC THAT- IT IS-
TALKED ABOUT AND FOR STUDENTS
WHETHER OR IN ELEMENTARY HIGH
SCHOOL THEY DO SOME ASSISTANCE
PROCESSING RENAMED TELL THEIR
STORIES TO GET THE HELP. THANK
YOU MISTER OVER DOCTOR CHOI.
RIGHT IF YOU INVITE ME TO HIDE
MY DAY CHOI LIKE TO GIVE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE HOMELESS AND SO
ISSUE IS A VERY CRITICAL ABOUT
THE IN PARTICULAR ARE YOU WITH
THE HOMELESS IN A C. SO IT IS
TO USE A CHART WITH YOUR AGES-
I AS MY DESIRE IS THAT THE Y.
YEAR TO EASIER WE INCREASE. OUR
TAX. FOR AFFORDABLE HOW AND THE
AND THIS ERA SITUATION ABOUT
THE STILL OUR HOME IN A
SITUATION. A CRUEL SO IS- SO WE
HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS SO THAT THE
3% DROP A OF A YOUTHFUL HOME
THIS BEFORE- IN. CALIFORNIA
MAYBE- SOMEBODY PRESENT TO
SECOND TYLER'S SO WHAT THE HAS
SO A TRIBUTE TO THE DROP OF
WITH NO YOUTH OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA MAYBE WE
CAN IDENTIFY THAT- REASON AND
THEN. WE CAN- ON FOSTER OF THAT
THE PROGRAM IF FOR A CERTAIN
PROGRAM IS TO HELPING. THE
REDUCTION OF THE YOUTH THE
HOMELESSNESS. SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA SO I'M MORE THAN
WILLING TO FIND SOLUTIONS-
THROUGH OUR HEARINGS TODAY. AND
COME UP WITH A- OF ENFORCEABLE
OF POLICY ISSUES THANK. THANK
YOU DOCTOR CHOI. A BEFORE THE I
DO WANT TO. REMIND YOU THAT YOU
ALL RECEIVED THE BACKGROUND
PAPER THERE'S SO MUCH
INFORMATION THERE I INVITE YOU
TO REALLY TAKE TIME TO READ
THROUGH THAT I ALSO WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY THANK OUR FROM
DOCTOR TO. FROM THE- THE
CHAIRMAN CHOOSE OFFICE- HIS
CONSULTANT LEASE ANGLE THANK
YOU OR IT FOR HELPING TO
PROVIDE OF PUT THIS TOGETHER
AND I MOST ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK- THE CONSULTANTS FOR THE
HUMAN SERVICES. COMMITTEE MY
CUT MY YEAH CHIEF CONSULTANT
DOCTOR DEBORAH COOPER AND ALSO-
CONSULTANT FOR HUMAN SERVICES
OF SO MANY YEARS KELSEY CASTIEL
AND WITHOUT I'D LIKE TO INVITES
THE FIRST PANELISTS. SHERA
HYATT. ELLIE SUDDEN AND
SUPERVISOR HILDA SO LEASE TO
COME UP. SURE A HIGH IT IS THE
PROJECT DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMELESS YOUTH PROJECT WELCOME-
ELLIE SUDDEN DEPUTY SECRETARY
FOR HOMELESSNESS BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY AND OF COURSE OUR VERY
OWN. OF FORMER SECRETARY OF
LABOR UNDER DENTAL BHAMA-
FORMER SENATOR- FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN-
BUT MOST. MOST IMPORTANTLY
SHE'S HOURS SHE'S FROM
CALIFORNIA OUR SUPERVISOR HILDA
SO LEASE SO- IF WE IF YOU'D
LIKE WE CAN BEGIN WITH HER HIGH
IT IN THE ORDER LISTED. GREAT
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TO HEAR HIGH AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMELESS YOUTH PROJECT- AND I
MANY BE GIVING A LITTLE BIT OF
KIND OF BACKGROUND WHAT'S
HAPPENING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO WE KNOW
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS ABOUT ONE THIRD OF THE
NATION'S HOMELESS YOUTH
POPULATION. EVEN THOUGH WE ONLY
HAVE ABOUT 12% OF THE NATION'S
POPULATION SO WE'RE REALLY OVER
REPRESENTS THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE X. THING HOMELESS. IN
CAP YEAH UNDER STANDARD. A
HOMELESSNESS ARE YOU ALMOST. WE
TEND TO USE THINK OF IS ANYBODY
WHO'S LACK A FOR REGULAR AND
NIGHT TIME BY BACK IN AND COUCH
SURFING LIVING DOUBLED OR
TRIPLED UP OUT OF ECONOMIC
NECESSITY STAYING IN HOTELS OR
MOTELS- EMERGENCY SHELTER
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING STAYING
AND CARS ARE ABANDONED
BUILDINGS- ALL OF THOSE BECAUSE
WE TEND TO THINK OF AS MOST
INCLUSIVE EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS THAT'S MOST
RAPPERS OF WHAT WE SEE. I'M IT
NEARLY ALL THOUSAND ON A COME.
MY AND TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
AGES EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
WERE COUNTED LIVING OUTSIDE ON
A SINGLE NIGHT IN JANUARY IN
TWENTY NINETEEN- IN ADDITION TO
THAT TWO THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY. PARENTING YOUTH AND
THEIR CHILDREN WERE ALSO
COUNTED LIVING OUTSIDE
CALIFORNIA- HAS OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNTIL THIRD THAN ALMOST ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY. I'M
LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DATA. A TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS OUR
IDENTIFIED IN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS- AS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AT SOME POINT IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SCHOOL YAR. AND WE KNOW BOTH
HUD'S POINT IN TIME COUNT
NUMBERS AND THE DEPARTMENT THE
CASE NUMBER IS TO BE AN
UNDERCOUNT. WE LOOK AT OUR HIGH
PATIENT THE STUMP I HEARING CAL.
ONE IN TWENTY YOU SEE STUDENTS
ONE IN TEN CSU STUDENTS AND ONE
IN FIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS EXPERIENCES HOMELESS
AT SOME POINT DURING THE COURSE
OF THE YEAR. SO WHAT'S UNIQUE
YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS RIGHT
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES ARE NEEDED
FOR THIS POPULATION. I'M THEY
MAY OR MAY NOT USE ADULTS
SERVICES- OR IF THEY DO THEY
MIGHT NOT BE CERTAIN
DEVELOPMENTS THE APPROPRIATE
WAYS FORWARD WHERE THEY'RE AT
IN LIFE. THEY'RE OFTEN LACKING
RENTAL AND EMPLOYMENT HISTORY
AS WELL AS INDEPENDENT LIFE
SKILLS AND UNABLE TO AFFORD
MARKET RATE RENTS. I OFTEN
ATTACHED TO FAMILIES ALSO.
HOMELESSNESS OR IN MANY CASES
ARE UNACCOMPANIED MEANING THAT
THEY'RE NOT IN THE CARE OF A
PARENT OR GUARDIAN. SO WHO
EXPERIENCES HOMELESSNESS WE
HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS-
SO LGBTQ YOUTH AND YOUTH OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH
ARE OVER REPRESENTED- IN LARGE
PART DUE TO SYSTEM
DISCRIMINATION. PREGNANT AND
PARENTING YOUTH ARE ALSO REALLY
OVER REPRESENTED IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND ARE UNDER SERVED
IN COMMONLY OVERLOOKED BY A LOT
OF OUR HOMELESSNESS SYSTEMS. A
YOUTH EXIT BUT WELFARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS OFTEN
EXIT INTO HOMELESSNESS OR HAVE
EXPERIENCES OF HOMELESSNESS. SO
HOW DO THESE YOUNG FOLKS
SURVIVE ON THE STREETS. WELL
SOME MAY NEED TO TURN TO
SURVIVAL SEX FOR A PLACE TO
STAY OR IN EXCHANGE FOR OTHER
BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD MONEY OR
CLOTHING. LACKING A PERMIT
ADDED MAY BE EXCLUDED. FROM
TRADITIONAL FORMS OF EMPLOYMENT
AND THAT'S THE CASE WE NEED TO
TURN THE LENS BACK ON OURSELVES
AND ASK WHAT THE LATTER'S
OPPORTUNITY ARE THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. YOUNG PEOPLE RATHER
THAN VILIFY OR CRIMINALIZE THEM
FOR PARTICIPATING IN ACTS OF
SURVIVAL. ONE THING WE KNOW IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT 50% OF
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ADULTS
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS BEFORE
THE AGE OF TWENTY FOUR SO IS
REALLY KEY TO MENTION THIS GAME
I THINK OF PREVENTION. NO THE
HOMELESS DOES DURING
ADOLESCENCE DISRUPT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF INDEPENDENT
LIVING SKILLS AND CREATES
LIFELONG REPERCUSSIONS NOT ONLY
EMPLOYABILITY AN EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT BUT ALSO THE GREAT
HEALTH AND WELLNESS- WHICH
INCREASES RISKS OF SUICIDE AND
SUBSTANCE OVERDOSE WHICH WE
KNOW TO BE KIND OF THE TWO
HIGHEST BECAUSE THE MORTALITY
FOR THIS COMMUNITY. SO IT WORKS
FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND I
WILL HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS A BIT
IN HE FUTURE PANELS BUT LONG
TERM TRANSITIONAL HOUSING-
RAPID RE HOUSING. OTHER TYPES
OF NON TIME LIMIT OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
HAVE GREATER NEEDS DEDICATED
STATE FUNDING AS WE'VE SEEN IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
THROUGH HE'D BEEN HAP- WE'VE
HEARD TO THERE'S MORE NEED TO
CONSULT WITH PROVIDERS ARE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THIS
COMMUNITY. AND THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THOSE FUNDING FRAMES. OF
YOUTH CARVE OUTS HAVE BEEN
HUGELY SUCCESSFUL WITH SOME
COMMUTING TO OPT INTO. OR THAN
THE MEN AND APES ON YOUTH SNUS
IN WRECKED. STORE KIND OF LACK
OF FUNDING TO ADDRESS YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IN PARTICULAR.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN TINY HOMES AND
HOST HOMES IT'S KIND OF
INNOVATIVE TRAGEDIES HAPPENING
A DIFFERENT COMMITTEES ACROSS
THE STATE. SOME OF THE BARRIERS
ARE WHAT'S MISSING OF WHAT WE
HEAR A LOT THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING ARTS AND WELLNESS
PROGRAMS. THERE'S A NEED FOR
MORE SHELTER AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING FOR MINORS IN
PARTICULAR- THERE'S VERY VERY
FEW AND FAR BETWEEN SERVICES
FOR MINORS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
A THINGS LIKE THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE IN THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF HOMELESSNESS
LARGELY UNDERMINE OUR EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
ACCESSING EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION
AND HOUSING. THERE IS A NEED
FOR HARM REDUCTION EFFORTS
MOVING SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH
OTHER LONG TERM STRATEGIES TO
GET PEOPLE HOUSE. OF THE
CURRENT CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
IS MANY DECADES IN THE MAKING
AND WILL TAKE A LONG TIME TO
UNDO WHAT IS WHAT IS NEED TO
CONSIDER HARM REDUCTION FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY LIVING
AND SHELTERED. WE NEED STRONGER
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION EFFORTS ASWELL. A
LOCAL PROGRAMMATIC DATA SHOWS
THIS TO BE SUCCESSFUL COST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY BUT IT'S
UNDER RESOURCE. AND LASTLY WE
NEED TO LISTEN TO YOUNG PEOPLE
OF LIVED EXPERIENCE THE
HOMELESSNESS IN ALL OF OUR
SYSTEMIC EFFORTS AND DESIGN
PROGRAMS THAT MEET THEIR NEEDS.
THE ONLY WAY WE KNOW. WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS HELPFUL IS IF WE
WORK WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
MOST CLOSELY IMPACTED BY THIS
ISSUE. OTHER WILL HELP US LOOK
AT POLICIES OF THE LENS OF
THESE YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
AND CREATE MORE INTEREST
SEXUALITY ACROSS MOVEMENTS FOR
JUVENILE JUSTICE CHILD WELFARE.
UNDOCUMENTED DISABLED AND OTHER
MARGINALIZED YOUTH POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. THANKS SO MUCH
AND I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS. ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE- ME
THESE QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
EACH PANEL. I'M SUCH A HERA AND
THE BACK ON PAPER DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB OF SORT OF
LAYING OUT SOME OF THE TRENDS
WE FENCING- SO GOOD AS TO THAT
THE FOLKS UP WITH THAT
TOGETHER- I DO JUST WANT TO
WANT TO SAY TO THE POINT OF THE
3% THREE COULD DECREASE YOU
KNOW WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
POINT IN TIME COUNTS AND
EFFECTIVENESS AND NOT
EFFECTIVENESS. REGARDLESS OF
SORT OF MINOR CHANGES AND
TRAJECTORIES I THINK WE CAN ALL
SORT OF AGREE THAT HAVING AT
ANY GIVEN POINT ALMOST THOUSAND
YOUTH AND STATE- EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS WAY TOO MUCH SO
OUT WE AT THE STATE KNOW THAT
WE CLEARLY NEEDS MORE HEAD YOU
BETTER- SO IN THAT CONTEXT I'D
WANT TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
HOPING IT AT THE STATE LEVEL.
I'M SUCH A GIN THAT HE PROGRAM
WITH REGENCY AID PROGRAM THOSE
OF YOU WHO DON'T LOVE ACRONYMS-
IT WAS IT WAS A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR TO FIFTY
FOUR JURISDICTIONS SO ARE FORTY
THREE ZERO SEASON AND ELEVEN
CITIES 5% OF THAT AT MINIMUM
PER JURISDICTION WITH THAT WAS
TO BE SPENT NEW THERMOSTAT
COMING. THE JOB REPORT IS
MENTIONED IN. BIRDS NOTE THAT
WERE SEEN. I GREATER IN. THE
THAT 5% THEY SORT OF QUOTED A-
TEMP. 3% COMMITMENT BELIEVE
HE'S PROGRAMMING I WOULD JUST
SORT OF NOTE THAT THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE CONTINUING TO
COME BACK TO US WITH REQUESTS
FOR ALTERATIONS AND HOW THEY'RE
SPENDING THESE FINDINGS. IF
THEY'RE SEEING SORT OF A
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
THAT FELL THROUGH WHERE THEY
WANT TO TWEAK SOMETHING THAT'S
WORKING BETTER. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM TO SEE HOW
THAT HOW THAT PLAYS OUT AND SO.
WE WILL PROBABLY HAVE A GREAT
SENSE OF HOW MUCH OF THAT
FUNDING IS ACTUALLY BEEN PUT
TOWARDS HOME USE HOMELESS.
RENTAL UNTIL THE END OF THAT.
OF THE FUNDING I PERIOD NEXT
JUNE. BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID
WE HAVE SEEN SOME REALLY.
ENCOURAGING SIGNAL FROM MY FULL
OF CAN YOU. IS I JUST A LOT OF.
IN NUMBER HAS DOUBLED THERE WAS.
ASIDE WITH ORIGINALLY REQUESTED.
YAGO FAR. MONTEREY A HANDFUL OF
THE UC'S HAVE ALREADY SORT OF
INCREASE FROM WHAT THEY
ORIGINALLY PROJECTED THEY WOULD
SPEND. I AND YOU THOMAS AND
PROGRAM WHICH I THINK IS A
REALLY GOOD SIGNAL THAT THEY'RE
SEEING SOME THINGS THAT.
WORKING OR ARE THAT A GREATER
NEED THAN THEY EXPECTED AS THEY
STARTED TO START. THE YOUNG AND
SO PERHAPS THE ASSET FOR THOSE
OF YOU THAT DON'T KNOW AT PART
OF THE HEAT STATURE. WERE IS
THAT THEY SUBMIT OVERLY. TO OUR
BUT WE RECEIVE THOSE AS OF
JANUARY FIRST AND HAVE BEEN
DOING SOME EARLY ANALYSIS OF
WHAT. IS IN THOSE REPORTS AND
WHAT WE'RE SEEING. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- THUS FAR WE'VE
SEEN A MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING-
BEING TARGETED ON YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AROUND EMERGENCY
SHELTER NAVIGATION CENTERS ARE
DAY CENTERS I THINK THAT'S NOT
A- SURPRISE GIVEN HOW THE
FUNDING WASN'T WAS SORT OF
INTENDED AND FRAMED- WE'VE
ALSO. HEARD CONSISTENTLY THAT
THERE AREN'T SAFE PLACES FOR
USED TO GO THAT ARE IN CRISIS
AND SO. A STRONG INVESTMENT IN.
OUR PRIMARY INVESTMENT THAT
ISN'T IN IT ISN'T AS HUGE
SURPRISE AND IT'S SOMETHING WE
WERE WERE SUPPORTIVE OF- BUT
CLOSELY BEHIND THAT WE'VE SEEN
SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN RAPID RE
HOUSING. OUTREACH STRATEGIES
PREVENTION AND DIVERSION. AND A
LITTLE BIT BEHIND THAT
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THE MINIMAL
PROGRAMMING. AROUND HOST HOMES-
WENT TO HER MENTION A LITTLE
BIT SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT REUNIFICATION
ACTIVITIES. SO THAT SORT OF AN
INITIAL SENSE OF WHERE WE'RE
SEEING SOME OF THE FUNDING FROM
KEEP GOING. BUT I THINK OVERALL
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN
MOST. ISN'T ONLY I WOULD THINK
RISE BY WHICH IS PLEASED TO SEE
IN THOSE ANNUAL REPORTS. IF YOU
THAT ARE RE THINKING CRITICALLY
ABOUT HOW TO DRESS THAT CRISIS
WITH. IS JENNIFER IT'S OFTEN
FIRST TIME MANY. COMMITTEE HAVE
HAD FIVE. TARGETING YOUTH AND-
THINGS SOME STRONG AND- IS IN
THE EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS. FOR
COME. AT THIS. HAVE FOLK I
PLACES FOR YOU TO GO THAT OUR
PRICES. FOCUSING ON HOW THE
BROADER HOMELESS A SYSTEM CAN
BETTER ADDRESS THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF USES AROUND COURTED ENTRY
SYSTEMS- SOME OF WHERE THE
TRADITIONAL. AND. A LITTLE BIT
MORE. WE PROVIDING CONSISTENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS WE
START TO SEE SOME OF THE ANNUAL
REPORTS WERE FOLKS ABOUT HAVING
CHALLENGES OR THINGS LIKE THAT.
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES ON ON ON
HIGHLIGHTING THINGS THAT ARE
WORKING WELL AND WORKING
THROUGH THINGS THAT ARE. A BIT
CHALLENGING IN THAT IN THAT
SAID IF HE FUNDING. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE- EVER IN THE MIDST OF A AB
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS THAT
WERE JUST DUE FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH FOR THAT. HAPPENED
PROGRAM- THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THAT WAS
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR TWO HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN JURISDICTION SO
WE'RE- DOING OUR VERY BEST AND
ARE IN THE THROES OF REVIEWING
A HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
APPLICATIONS. THE STATE TUNED-
BUT THE FUNDING FOR THAT I'M
HAD AN INCREASE- FOR THAT THE
MINIMUM AMOUNT TO BE SPENT ON
YOUTH FOR HALF FUNDING IS EIGHT
PERCENT. SO EAGER TO SEE- YOU
KNOW WHAT COMMUNITIES LEARN
FROM FROM THE HEAT FUNDING AND
SORT OF WHERE THEY'RE CHOOSING
TO TARGET THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT. ARE OUT. WELL WE
ARE IN THE MIDST OF REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS TO SEE WHAT WHAT
IS IN THERE AND GETTING THAT
THAT FUNDING OUT- I WOULD SAY
THAT WE ARE- YOU KNOW THINKING
THROUGH SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THE PARTS WE CAN BE
PROVIDING FOR BOTH GROUPS.
FUNDING WERE MET STEP OF
PLANNED OUT SORT OF A SUMMER
FALL USE WEB IN OUR SERIES THAT
WOULD BRING IN COMMUNITIES IT
OF IT. REALLY GOOD WITH THE
FUNDING. BUT ALSO OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN IN GREAT BURKE A
FEDERAL PARTNERS THAT HAVE
BEEN. GOOD WORK REALLY TRYING
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PETER SHARING FOR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT. THIS IS SORT
OF THE- TIME MANY OF THEM HAVE
HAD. INDIRECTLY TARGET FOR YOU.
OVER EAT. SOME AND TECHNIQUE.
SINCE OURS. THAT'S THIS ROUTE
PROVIDING TA. COUPLES ARE
SPECIFIC AREAS THAT RIPPING
THROUGH ONE OR BILL AT HOME
WITH THE THAT WORKS FOR
PARTICULARLY AROUND I CAN'T
RECALL I THINK FEW OF YOU
MENTIONED THE REAL NEED FOR
HEARING FROM YOU FIFTH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WE COULDN'T AGREE
MORE. AND SO REALLY
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THE WORK
THE COMMUNITIES OF AN USE IT OR
ARE YOUTH ACTION I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE I WOULD SAY
BOTH AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT I
THINK WE'RE ALSO INTERESTED IN
THAT THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL
I'M THINKING ABOUT HOW CORD
THREE FOR. CAN BE BACK. DID
ALSO THINKING ABOUT SUCCESSES
THOSE IN RIGHT SO WHAT WHAT IS
WERE AROUND OF HOUSE WHAT IS
WORKING AROUND ST OUT OF REACH
WHAT IS WORKING AROUND RAPIDLY
HOUSING SORT OF GOING THROUGH
EACH OF THOSE INTERVENTIONS AND
TRY HIGHLIGHTS SOME THE BEST
PRACTICES A COMMUNITY AND TAKE
AWAY SOME THAT SORT OF STAY
TUNED THAT'S WHERE WE'RE HEADED
IN THE ISLAND YEAR I FIT. IN
STRINGS WE ALSO THE IS CREATING
FINANCE CZARIST OR THE POLICIES
ACTIVE IN CONCERT A HAND OF
THINGS THERE THAT I JUST WANNA
SORT OF- NOTE THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF WORKING ON AND I
THINK WE'LL SEE SOME GOOD PARTS
SONGS I COUNT. HERE MANY. A
MATE. EIGHT WIDE WHERE HOW
WOULD ALLOW US TO HAVE A
STATEWIDE DATA BUT THAT WOULD
GET A LOT OF THE PIECES THAT
ARE IN THE HOMELESS YOUTH ACT-
SO REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
AND GATHER THE DATA WE NEED TO
WE KNOW THAT AGE MY **** IS NOT
A HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEM IS NOT
EVERYTHING BUT IT WOULD AS A
LEVEL OF THAT WE HAVE YOU HAVE
NEVER HAD AT THE STATE WELL I'M
REALLY BE THE UNDERSTAND AND
UNDERSTAND. WHERE WORST AND SO
WE'RE. TAKING THAT. BACK WHERE
HOW. CAN GET. I COLOR YOU KNOW.
IDEALLY THIS CALENDAR YEAR IN
THE MIDST WORKING UPPER PROCESS
IS THE STATE AND BUT THAT
REALLY ALLOW US TO GET SOME OF
THE DAY THAT IS FROM THAT FROM
THE ACT AND START TO UNDER KIND
OF MEASURABLE OUTCOMES ANGLES
WE'D BE PUTTING IN PLACE AROUND
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS- WE ARE ARE
ARE IN THE MIDST OF IN AND
THINKING THE REST OF. AN OKAY
AT THIS STAGE IT IS AN SORT OF
UP. SOME OF. HOW DO WE ARE
HOMELESSNESS HAD WE ADDRESS
SOME OF BROAD BUT USE THAT THEY
SORT OF GOALS WITH AN ACT I
THINK WOULD BE DEEPLY EMBEDDED
IN THAT STRATEGIC PLAN- AND
THEN THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IT IS ACTUALLY CALLED OUT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE- AND WE'RE-
EAGER AND- WILLING TO. OTHER
WEIGHT WRITING OP A PURE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT AND THEN
BRINGING IN EXPERTS THAT THAT
HAVE. HAVE NOTHING THAT
COMMITTEES COLORED SOFT UP
THERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- HONORABLE
CHAIR WOMAN CARE PERSON- CHIU
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU AND
OBVIOUSLY ELOISE REYES IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU WHEN ALL
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO HAVE READ THE
GROUND REPORT THAT THE
COMMITTEE TOGETHER I THINK IT'S
GREAT INCLUDES. AT I'M GLAD SIT
TO- OUR GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES IN OUR
STAKEHOLDERS HERE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT- WHERE WE'RE GOING
ON THIS ISSUE REALLY NICKEL AND
HOMELESSNESS. THE TOP OF MY
HEAD EVEN THE TO TELL YOU AND
UNABLE SAN WE HAVE MILLION
PEOPLE. DON GIVEN AS YOU HAVE
HEARD NINTH OR MORE PEOPLE
REMAIN HOMELESS AND A GOOD
PORTION OF THAT OBVIOUSLY ARE
ARE YOU. OF THE LARGEST NOT. IN
THE LIST. NOT PROUD TO. BUT
NONE THE THIS IS BEEN PROBLEM.
ONGOING FOR NO OF YEAR AND I
IT'S I DON'T THINK THERE'S ONE
BULLET TO ADDRESS. REGARDING
HOMELESSNESS AND WHEN YOU DEAL
WITH YOUNG YOUNG PEOPLE AND
YOUNG ADULTS I THINK IT'S EVEN
MORE CHALLENGING FOR US BECAUSE
MISS UNDER MISUNDERSTAND OUR
MISTAKE THAT ALL ONE SIZE FITS
ALL AND HERE WE REALLY HAVE TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE I DID SOME. BALL HAVE RATE.
COMING FROM A FAMILY BEEN
TOWARD ART. ASSIST THE CHILD IS
BEEN IN FOSTER CARE OR BEEN IN
A PROBATION CAP OR A CHILD THAT
HAS LIVED IN A- IN A FAMILY
THAT HAS. OF UNDERGONE TRAUMA.
THOSE ARE SCARS. ARE YOUNG
CHILDREN AND- I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- IN LA COUNTY ALONE RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND. A YOUNG RESERVE. WE
KNOW. OF WORK IS HOME THIS.
MORNING TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN.
YOUTH HOMELESS COUNT AND THAT'S
A LOT SIGNIFICANT NUMBER WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. UP TO CAL
YEAH. SO TWENTY TWO PER. IN
TIME TO THE TEAM AND THAT
NUMBER AND THEN THIS LAST YEAR
IN TERMS OF OUR YOUTH HOMELESS
COUNT WE ALSO SAW. CREE PROPER
OVER IN IN HOME AND THAT THAT
IS. BECAUSE FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THAT WE PUT IN I BELIEVE- YOU
ALMOST NEED TO HAVE. MAYBE TWO
OR THREE MORE DOLLARS AND NOT
JUST THE STATE BUT ALSO FROM I
SAY THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
OUR OUR ACCOUNTING I THINK IT'S
BEEN VERY INNOVATIVE WE PASSED
A MEASURE. SEVERAL YEARS AGO A
YOU WILL BE HEARD ABOUT IT
MEASURE H. WHERE WE ACTUALLY
TAXED OURSELVES AND WE SAID WE
ARE GOING TO STAND UP AND IN
TEN YEARS AT LEAST PROVIDE A
STREAM OF FUNDING. AND WHILE IT
ISN'T A CURE ALL FOR EVERYTHING
I THINK IT'S LET US IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO BE ABLE TO.
TO THE AS THEY SAY PEEL THE
ONION BACK AND START TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE GOT HERE
BECAUSE IT ISN'T JUST SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. THIS IS SOMETHING WE
FIND PEOPLE YOU EVEN YOUNG
PEOPLE OTHER THAN OUT STREET
FOR MANY YEARS. IN. BECAUSE
THEIR PARENTS CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD THE RENT FOR WE HAVE
MOTHERS SINGLE HEAD OF
HOUSEHOLD MOTHERS COMING IN AND
TESTIFYING. TO OUR COMMITTEES
AT THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
TELL US THAT. OF RENTS WENT UP.
MAYBE EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR. A
MOTHER THAT'S WORKING MINIMUM
WAGE JOBS AND HAS FOUR
CHILDREN. CAN HARDLY BEAR THE
BRUNT AND SO WE'RE FACED ALSO
WITH COMING UP WITH OTHER TOOLS
TO TRY TO. ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
BUT I KNOW TODAY'S SUBJECT
MATTER IS ABOUT THE U. AND FOR
ME. HEARTBREAKING IS TO SEE
YOUNG PEOPLE JUST THIS LAST
JANUARY WE OPENED UP. TWENTY
FOUR HOUR WINTER SHELTER. AND
WITH THAT WE DECIDED WE WOULD.
HOUSE UP ABOUT A HUNDRED.
HUNDRED WILL JUST OF FOR. FOUR
MONTH PERIOD AND- FILTERS ARE.
BUT I WOULD YOU IT WILL BE
ADDITION MONEY TO ADDRESS SOME
TEMPORARY SERVICES THAT NEED TO
BE MADE AVAILABLE NOW THAT WILL
HELP US THEN IDENTIFY. MORE
CHRONICALLY OF YOUNGSTERS THAT
REALLY NEED TO RECEIVE HELP AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT AGE GROUP
IT'S AROUND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO TWENTY FOUR. THOSE
YOUNGSTERS HAVE FAILED IN
SCHOOL MANY EMIGRATE AUSTER
JOBS HAVE A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND.
THE WHOLE SLEW OF SERVICES SO
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING FOR ADULTS OW HELPING
THEM IS. A SCOUT RESIDENTS.
GETTING THERE. GETTING THEM
BACK IN SCHOOL AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A SYSTEM OF CARE
AVAILABLE CASE MANAGEMENT IS.
ONE OF THE COSTLIEST TO HIDE
AND I SAY MY OPINION THAT'S
WITH REALLY INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO
FACTUALLY- AND DO IT THROUGH A
SYSTEM OF CARE WHERE YOU CAN
INTEGRATE. THIS ONE'S RECORD
YOU CAN INTEGRATE THEIR
HEALTHCARE THE CLIENTS.
INVOLVEMENT THEY'VE HAD WITH
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM SO YOU A
FULL BODY EVIDENCE OF WHAT THAT
YOUNG CHILD A PERSON IS GONE
THROUGH. AND BEGIN TO
UNDERSTAND. YOU KNOW MORE
IMPORTANTLY WITH THE ARE AND BE
ABLE TO. WHAT THAT THE THAT
YOUNGSTERS FACING AND HOW WE
CAN HELP TRY TO RECTIFY THAT AT
THAT POINT IN SOME WAYS IT'S A
LITTLE LATE BUT I WOULD SAY WE
HAVEN'T DONE IT I DON'T KNOW
ANY SYSTEM THAT HAS REALLY BEEN
ABLE TO. TO TACKLE ALL THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT NOW IN
OUR PROBATION DEPARTMENT BUT
THAT'S JUST ONE DEPARTMENT WHAT
ABOUT OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
INTEGRATING THEM BEING ABLE TO
TALK TO. OUR JUSTICES ARE
JUSTICE INVOLVED DEPARTMENTS
AND WHAT HAVE YOU TO TRY TO
CREATE A- NEW ONE OF
INFORMATION THAT'S RELATIVE AND
THAT CAN BE UPDATED EASILY AND
ACCESSIBLE GIVEN GIVEN
CONFIDENTIALITY. BUT NONE THE
LESS IT HAS TO HAPPEN AND THAT
COSTS MONEY THE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES- I WILL TELL YOU DOUBT
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PUT ALL THAT DATA. ANY A COP. A
MANNER. IN SOMETHING STAY. TO
OF. AND BE PUT ON THE TO THAT
BECAUSE WE TALK SETTING SYSTEM
OF CARE. EVERYWHERE BUT IF YOU
HAVE AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM AND
WHEN WE STOP THE REPEAT REPEAT
THE GOAL. MAY CONTINUE TO SPEND
A LOT OF MONEY AND THAT'S
WHAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE JUST
LEARNED IN THE LAST. REALLY
FIVE YEARS OF ON THE SUPERB. TO
SEE. ATTAR TOOLS FOR SOME
REASON IS NOT WORKING FOR THEM
AND WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO FIX.
I THINK THAT THERE ISN'T ENOUGH
UP SHELTERS PROVIDED- OFFER YOU
STIRS. I. THE LADY IN EAST LOS
ANGELES AND INCORPORATED AREA
THAT ACTUALLY HAD TRANSITIONAL
AGE. OF ASSISTED LIVING FOR
YOUNGSTERS AT IT WAS COSTLY.
BUT IT WAS IT WAS VERY TIMELY.
AND IT WAS VERY NECESSARY SINCE
THAT TIME I CAN'T REALLY TELL
YOU TAT ANY OF THE- NEW
FACILITY HAS BEEN BUILT.
BECAUSE IT COSTS MONEY CAPITAL
BUT ALSO BEING ABLE TO
ESTABLISH THE SYSTEMS OF CARE
THE CASE MANAGEMENT THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND THEN
MAKING SURE. THAT THAT THOSE
CHILDREN ARE OUT YOUNGSTERS ARE
ABLE THEN TO GO TO SCHOOL.
NUMBER ONE BUT ALSO OBTAIN SOME
JOB TRAINING AND COUNSELING
SKILLS. JOB TRAINING I THINK IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL BECAUSE IT
OUTLINED IN YOUR REPORT. YOU
MENTIONED. HOW MANY OF THESE
YOUNGSTERS- DON'T DON'T HAVE A
HOW CAN I SAY. CONFIDENCE OF
THE ABILITY TO EVEN. EVEN A
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN HOUSEHOLD
LET ALONE. BEING ABLE TO FIGURE
OT THAT ACCOUNT. OF WHO HAD
AND NAVIGATE SYSTEM. THAT THE
PARENTS WERE NOT EVEN ABLE TO
THEM. REAL HELLO YOUR SETTING
UP THESE YOU. FOR FAILURE
UNLESS YOU PER THEM WITH THE
ATTIC ADEQUATE A TREATMENT AND
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND IT'S
GOING TO COST AND I WOULD JUST
SAY TO YOU THAT THOSE ARE.
REALLY I THINK A SIMPLE A
SIMPLE THING WE NEED TO PROVIDE
MY STAFF WROTE VERY LET THE ARM.
PROPOSAL HERE. NOT PROPOSAL BUT
OUTLINED IN I WILL SHARE IT
WITH YOU WITH YOU BUT I'M
REALLY JUST SPEAKING OFF THE
CUFF BECAUSE I THINK IT'S MORE.
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAT YOU
GET A CANDID VIEW OF WHAT- ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT REPRESENTS AND
I ONLY REPRESENT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE BUT I REPRESENT ONE OF
THE POOREST. AND TO THE
CHILDREN ARE CLASSIFIED AS-
UNDER UNDER THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESS HAPPEN TO BE BLACK
BROWN CHILDREN. AND THOSE OF
THE CHILDREN THAT WERE FAILING
RIGHT NOW AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO DO A LOT MORE WE HAVE
TO INSIST. THAT OUR SCHOOLS
RECEIVE AT A- COUNCIL AND
SERVICE MENTAL HEALTH. AND SPUR
IT IT IT CAN'T HAVE OR TWO.
HEALTH INDIVIDUALS HELP
IDENTIFY BUT MORE. HELP THEM
NOW. SPECIALLY FOR DOC I DID. A
LOT. TO PROVIDE ABOUT. BUT THAT
INCREASE INCREASE POPULATION
THAT ALSO SEEN. AN AND GIVEN
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT A JUST
FROM COMMUTER. UNDOCUMENTED
REPRESENT ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THEY- ARE TIMID. THEY ARE
ALL POLL FEEL FEET FEAR FOR
HARASSMENT- BUT IN ASKING ANY
KIND OF THIS SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I VERY. FOR OUR
SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THESE YOU. WHO THEY ARE- BUT TO
BE ABLE TO HELP THEM AND THAT
GOES FOR ALSO COMMUNITY
STUDENTS. I THINK THAT WE OUGHT
TO. FORCING FORCING. THE MAYBE
I'LL IN THEM TO MUCH COLLEGE
CAN. BECAUSE THEIR SUCCESS AND
BY IS REALLY GOOD TO DEPEND ON
ON- WHAT OUR OUTLOOK IN IN
MOVING AHEAD BEING ABLE TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE ON EDUCATING AND
KEEP YOUNGSTERS IN THE AGE OF
GIVING THEM OFF IT IS TO ATTEND
COLLEGE BUT ALSO NOT HAVE TO
FOR AND AN MOVE ON. INST ON UP.
THERE IT'S LIKE ON THAT CAMP WE
OUGHT TO BE PER MORE SYSTEM WE
OUGHT TO BE ALLOWING FOR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING TO BE MADE
AVAILABLE. TO OUR JOINING
CAMPUSES WERE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN EAST LOS
ANGELES RIGHT NOW NEXT TO CAL
STATE LA. AND EAST COLLEGE SO
WE AS A COUNTY OR- DO THIS LOOK
AT PROPERTIES THAT WE HAVE OUR
OWN ASSETS AND TO BUILD ON THAT
AND IN FACT I WANT TO JUST
MENTION ONE THING TO YOU I
DON'T KNOW IF SOME OF YOU.
HEARD BACK WAS THE- SAND. AND
HALL. OF AT THE TIME IN CARE.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO CARE FOR
FOSTER CHILDREN THAT WERE A
TRAUMATIZED OR PHYSICALLY
ABUSED- INCIDENTS HAPPEN THERE
THEY CLOSED DOWN THE- LADY. SO
MANY IS IN MY DISTRICT. IT
STILL REMAINS HALF OPEN I WANT
TO REPURPOSE IT SO THAT WE CAN
CREATE HOUSING FOR TRANSIT WELL
AGE YOU. ALSO PUT IT HOUSING
FOR ADULTS AND ALSO FOR A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS ALONG
WITH THAT AT. LEAST AND
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUAL THAT
STILL REQUIRE THAT AND A LOT
FOR AB. ON PROPERTY ALL OF
THOSE THINGS I. IN IN MY
OPINION. A WELLNESS COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY THAT CAN HEAL AND IF
WE START TO LOOK AT KEEPING OUR
COULD OUR YOUNGSTERS IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY GROW UP.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
BETTER OFF RIGHT NOW ALL IF A
CHILD IN MY DISTRICT AND SAY EL
MONTE THE CITY OF THE MONEY HAS
TO TRAVEL TO GET LGBT Q. A
USER. BECAUSE THEY'RE HOMELESS
THEY WILL PROBABLY I'M IN A
PLACE MILEY WITH WHICH IS
ABOUT. SEVEN THIRTY MILES AWAY
HOT THAT CHILD HOW DOES A
PERSON GET THERE. HOW DOES THAT
PERSON HAVE A GATE THAT SYSTEM
AND WHO'S GOING TO BE AT THE
OTHER END OF THAT OF THAT.
APPROACH I'M THERE TO HELP THEM
TO SHOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
THE RIGHT TREATMENT AND CARE.
SO IS IT. PROVIDING FOR OUR
YOUNG AN OPPORTUNITY AT THE
TABLE IS WELL AS THE SAN AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
COUNTY IS DOING AND I LOVE IT
THE GOVERNOR HAS CHALLENGED US
TO DO MORE IN THIS AREA AND WE
AT THE COUNTY ARE PREPARED TO
DO THAT I THINK WE'VE CEDED THE
PERCENTAGE AP. NO WE HAVE THE
WORD WE WANT PARTNER WITH YOU
WE WANT TO WORK ALONGSIDE WITH
YOU AND SEE HOW WE CAN GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO THE PUBLIC
BECAUSE I THINK THAT OTHERS A
LOT OF MISSED. WITH RESPECT TO
HOMELESSNESS AND SPECIAL THE
YOUNG PEOPLE SO YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SUPERVISORS
POLICE. I'D LIKE TO- SEE IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS
OF THIS PANEL. YES MATHIS. ON
ONE SIDE OF SUPERVISORS LEASE I
THINK YOU'VE TOUCHED ON A LOT
OF REALLY SOLID POINTS- THEY
DIDN'T PAUL I DO POLICY PAUSE
EVERY YEAR AND A LOT OF WHAT
YOU MENTION OF WHAT YOU. WAS
THE SAME THING THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING AND ONE OF THE MOST
RURAL AREAS- I REPRESENT TULARE
COUNTY. AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THE HIGHEST PER CAPITA HOMELESS
IN THE STATE- YOU DON'T. PUT
YOU TALK ABOUT THESE THINGS.
YOU KNOW THE JOB TRAINING THE
EDUCATION BECOME KEY IN THE
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES AND I
FEEL LIKE ESPECIALLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE CAN I GET- INTO
THIS HOUSING FOR MENTALITY AND
WE FORGET IT ABOUT THE
TREATMENT AND THE TRANSITION
ASPECTS. AND YOU KNOW THE FACT
IS THAT. WHEN ESPECIALLY WITH
OUR YOUTH A LOT OF TIMES THEY
GO UNNOTICED SADLY AND TELL THE
GET ARRESTED OR THEY END UP IN
ANY ARE WHICH IS WHERE THE
TREATMENT AT THIS HOW BEEN IN
TO RAISE YOUR SPOT ON THE CITY
THE CASE MANAGEMENT ASPECT IS
THE CONVERSATION WE HAD WITH
OUR HUMAN SERVICES DIRECTOR
INTO LARRY COUNTY WITH OUR
SHARE WITH OUR D. A. WITH
PROBATION WITH THEIR SUPER
EVERYBODY WAS SAYING. THIS IS
ANNE ALONG FOR AN ISSUE. THIS
IS A HUMAN SERVICES CRISIS AND
WE NEED MORE CASE MANAGERS
THERE BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOMEWHERE FOR THEM%
TO COME IN. AND KIND OF DO THAT
TREE OPTION IN. LIKE YOU SAID
THE FOR PICTURES. WHAT IS THEIR
EDUCATION WHAT IS IT DOTHEY
HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD TO THE
WHAT HEALTH CONCERNS MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS IN BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT THAT HOLISTICALLY. TO
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON WITH THIS
PERSON AND WHAT KIND OF
TREATMENT DO THEY NEED TO GET
SO WE CAN GET THEM CLEANED UP
GET THEM TRANSITIONED. IN THEN
GET THEM BACK TO IN A VITAL
PART OF SOCIETY. AND I THINK
UNTIL WE FIGURE THAT ASPECT
OUT. ST OUR SCHOOL COUNSELORS
HAVE. REQUIREMENTS EVERY
EVERYBODY ALONG THE WAY HAS
THESE DIFFERENT HAVE A
REQUIREMENTS. THE WITHOUT THE
MILLION OVER TO COMMUNICATE
DIRECTLY WITH EACH OTHER. TO
REALLY GET THAT FULL WRAPAROUND
SERVICES AROUND SOMEBODY.
EVERYBODY'S WORKING IN A
DIFFERENT SILO. AND WE HAVE TO
BREAK DOWN THOSE SILOS TO
ENSURE THAT WHOLE LISTICLE
PERSON CARE THAT WE WE'VE ALL
BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT FOR
DECADES. BUT THE SILOS ARE
STILL THERE. AND I THINK THAT'S
IN ON THE COMMITTEE SIDE-
MANAGER WE NEED TO LOOK. FORD
IS HOW DO WE MAKE THE SILOS
DOWN TO A WOUND THAT OPEN FLOW
COMMUNICATION. BECAUSE ONCE WE
GET THESE INDIVIDUALS IN. A AND
IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE IN THE
BACK OF A COP CAR IN NEEDS TO
BE THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT.
THE ON SET OF TAKING INVOKING
THEM DOWNTOWN. TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT THEY NEED TO GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. IN TALK TO THE
HUMAN SERVICES CASE MANAGER.
AND GO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
WHERE YOU AT IN THE END WITH
THE FOLLOW UP WAS CASE MANAGERS
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP IN
AND HOW THE POWER IN THE
ABILITY. SMALL CASE WOODS TO
FOLLOW DID YOU GO TO YOUR
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT DO YOU GO
TO YOUR BACK APPOINT. HOW COME
OUT. FROM YOUR ACCOUNTS THAT
YOU'RE DISHING. WITHOUT THAT
FOLLOW OF ASPECT. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T NEED TO BE THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OR PROBATION BECAUSE
THESE WE DONATED CRIMINALIZING
THESE KIDS FOR SLIPPING THROUGH
THE CRACKS WE NEED TO STEP UP
OUR GAME. AND IT DOESN'T NEED
TO BE ON. THE SIDE IT DOESN'T
NEED TO BE ON THE BACK OF
PROBATION. WE NEED TO BE PART
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT. AND
MAKE SURE THAT THESE CASE
MANAGERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
MORE WHILE. WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO DO IT. WE JUST
NEED TO STOP TALKING ABOUT IT
AND- GET THE SYSTEM WHERE THEY
CAN GO OUT AND ACTUALLY DO IT.
WITH THAT HUMAN SERVICE CASE
MANAGER CAN SHOW WHILE. CAN
FOLLOW UP AND TALK TO THEIR
BOSS OF YOU KNOW WHAT SIR
TRANSITION AND THEY'RE WORKING
IN MAKE SURE. YOU DON'T COUCH
SURFING I'M I'M A VETERAN I
KNOW ALL ABOUT COUCHSURFING
BEEN THERE DONE THAT I'VE GOT
BODIES IN. IT OUT IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS YOU FORGET ABOUT
BECAUSE YOU DON'T THINK ABOUT
IT. BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG
KEYS. THAT I SEE ACROSS THE
BOARD REGARDLESS OF RURAL OR
URBAN. THE THERE ISN'T A DIVIDE
ON THIS IT'S THE SIMPLE FACT
IS. WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT. ON
THE POLICY SIDE TO ALLOW THAT
OPEN FLOW OF COMMUNICATION AND
WE NEED TO PUT IT IN OUR BUDGET
THIS YEAR TWO SURE THAT THAT
FIGHT IS GOING TO INCREASE CASE
MANAGEMENT ENSURE THOSE
WORKLOADS ARE SMALL. A I'M VERY
PROUD OF HOW YOU HAD THAT-
QUESTION FOR MY SENIOR ISSUE
HERE. SO I'M ON THE EDGE CARE A
SUPERBOWL HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
YOU TALKING FROM YOUR POINT OF
VIEW YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE- IN MY
POLICY PARTY KIND OF CALLED IT
THE TRIAGE TREATMENT TRANSITION
THE THREE TV'S. BUT FROM THE
YOUTH PERSPECTIVE. WHERE DO YOU
SEE THE S. POINT OF BRINGING IN
THAT CASE MANAGER AND HOW SOON
I MEAN IS IT WHEN THEY GET
ARRESTED AND INSTEAD OF TAKING
THEM AND BOOKING THEM TAKING
THEM SOMEWHERE LIKE THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I HEAR FROM
FROM THE PROFESSIONALS IN AND
BACK HOME. BUT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE IS DOES THAT MAKE
SENSE WELL I THINK LIKE YOU
SAID YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE THE FIRST POINT OF
INTERVENTION AND I THINK
INHERENTLY WHEN THAT HAPPENS
THEN YOU KNOW THEY'RE SORT OF
THIS LIKE. A DIFFERENTIAL AND
IT CAN BE REALLY DIFFICULT I A
CAN LIKE BUILT THAT CONFIDENCE
REPORT WITH THAT YOUNG PERSON
SPECIAL IF THEY'RE LIKES LET.
I'M TO THEN EVEN. THE PATH OF
ON FOR PROP. TAKING AND SO.
YEAH I. OF YOU KNOW I KNOW
YOU'RE INTO. THEIR WAKING THE-
AND OTHER PER. THAT RUN A
PREVENTION IN. AT A PROGRAM
BEEN REALLY SUCCESSFUL WE DO
TRY TO INTERVENE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE I MEAN I THINK
SOMETIMES IT COMES DOWN TO
SUPPORT EDUCATION WHICH- AS-
THE RISERS LEAST TALKED ABOUT-
SO IDENTIFYING THAT YOUNG
PERSON. FOR THAT YOU KNOW EVEN
GETTING FAT AND LIKE I. I'LL
JUSTICE AT PENSION SO. YOU KNOW
CHILD WELFARE THINK NEEDS TO
RESPOND REALLY THOUGHT FULLY
TO. YOU FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS YOU KNOW IT WE
KNOW THAT IT'S NOT A REASON IN
OF ITSELF REPORT- AND WE DON'T
THINK THE CHILDREN TO BE
REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
WHEN IT'S NOT. YOU KNOW ABOUT
SAFETY BUT- I THINK KIND OF
STARTS BEFORE THAT IDEALLY- I
THINK THAT. YEAH HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS RESPONDING
TO ALMOST AS OBVIOUS IT'S A
HUGE THING THAT THEY'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW BUT- I THINK ALSO
NEED TO BE A LOT MORE COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AROUND. NINE ONE IS
NOT THE RIGHT NUMBER WHEN YOU
SEE SOMEBODY WHO'S POOR YOU
KNOW WHAT HE MEANS LIKE. THAT
IS NOT BAD WHAT THE RESOURCES
ARE FOR AND IT DEFINITELY MEANS
AT LATIMES. POLICE HAVE TO THAN
ACTIVE SOCIAL WORKERS WHICH IS
NOT WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
YEAH I THINK THE WE CAN CUT. A
LOT OF OUR- YEAH G. INTO. THOSE
WRITTEN QUE MANAGER AWAY FROM
CA JUSTICE FOR. IT REALLY JUST
MUCH BETTER OUT IN ON THIS YEAH
THE SECOND PART OF THAT. ALSO
IS ONCE. A LOT OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND UP ON THE
STREETS YOU END UP WITH THE
DRUGS COMING INTO PLACE IN THE
QUEUE TIED IN THE HOLD OPIOID
EPIDEMIC TOTALLY HE- CRAZY
AMOUNTS OF METHAMPHETAMINES
THAT ARE COMING. IN FROM THE
CARTELS INTO OUR STATE. AND
FROM THE YOUTH PERSPECTIVE HOW
DO YOU SEE WHICH IS A HERE ALL
THE TIME. IF THESE PEOPLE ARE
ON DRUGS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
WANT TO GET THE HELP BUTTON
BECAUSE YOU YOU'VE GOT A BREAK
THROUGH AND YOU'VE GOT A BILL
THAT REPORT YOU READY TO ALL
THOSE OTHER THINGS WE LEARNED
ON THE CASE MANAGEMENT CITING
CAPTAIN IN A- LOS. BY IF
SOMEBODY'S. NOT OF THAT MENTAL.
CAPACITY BECAUSE- THEY'RE LIKE.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE I'D RATHER GO GET HIGH.
HOW DO. AT WHAT POINT DO YOU
CAN AGO OKAY DUDE. YOU'RE GONNA
GET HELP I THINK A LOT OF TIMES
IT COMES DOWN TO- BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE INTERVENTION WHEN
THE YOUNG PERSON IS READY SO
WHAT I SEE A LOT OF TIMES IS
I'M YOU KNOW AB. OUT A DROP IN
CENTER FOR LEE AND THE IT I
THOUGHT CASES THIS IN PERSON
LIKE HEY CAN LIKE YOU READY TO
GET CLEANINGS LIKE DO YOU HAVE
A PLACE FOR ME TO LIVE AND THEY
WERE AT AN IMPASSE RIGHT I
THINK THAT GOES BACK TO YOU.
AND HOW FIRST I THINK YOU'RE
REALLY. FIRST THING FOR TO MAKE
FORGETTING ALL THE OTHER THINGS
ARE NEEDED. TO A YET. PERSON
SUCCESS ON HOUSING SO I THINK
THE- HOUSING FOR SHOULDN'T.
MUTUALLY EXCUSE EXCLUSIVE OF
THESE OTHER KIND. LIKE RICH
CASE MANAGEMENT EMPLOYMENT
EDUCATION TYPES OF
INTERVENTIONS. I THINK THAT
THOSE ALSO HAVE TO BE ROBUSTLY
FUNDED AND SUPPORTED LOCALLY. I
THINK THAT. BECAUSE ON THE-
LONG WAIT LIST. FOR SO MANY OF
OUR- YOU KNOW MEAGER KIND OF
OFFERINGS AROUND HELPING WITH
ABOUT THE EMERGENCY SHUT. FOR
TRANSITIONAL. LONGER TERM
SOLUTIONS. OF LOT OF TIMES YOU
CAN REALLY I A PER SIDE THAT
SERVICE WE THE YOUNG. IS READY
AND LOOK LIKE OKAY IF YOU'RE
READY TO. GET CLEAN BUT YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET TO TRANSITION
HELPING FOR SIX TO NINE MONTHS
IT'S JUST GONNA BE SUCH A YOU
KNOW A MORE SEVERE PROBLEM AT
THAT POINT SAID HE THINKS THE
BIGGEST POINT OF. MISTER MATHIS
THE TRANSITIONAL SORRY MADAM
CHAIR AND HOLD ON JUST ONE
SECOND I DO WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE HAVE TIME FOR ALL OF
OUR PANELS- AND- YOU WERE TO
GIVE AN OPENING STATEMENT. I'M
GONNA TAKE THAT IS YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT. BUT MADAM SHIP VERY
GOOD. I AM THE VICE CHAIR SO I
LIKE TO ASK DO YOU SOMEONE THAT
YOU'RE- THE BIG POINT. OF THE
OF THE LACKING IS THAT WITH THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. YEAH SO
DO YOU KNOW NATIONALLY WE KIND
OF SHIFTED AWAY FROM
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OPTIONS
THERE WAS SORT OF. I THINK- IT
REALLY FELL OUT OF FAVOR IN
TERMS OF HOUSING AND I THINK
THAT THE PROBLEM WITHOUT WAS
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT YOUTH
AND ADULTS IN PARTICULAR. AND
THERE IS A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
FOR USING AN ADULT IT IS AN
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY VERTICALLY
BECAUSE IT TENDS TO BE A LONGER
TERM. TO I MEAN IF THINK ABOUT
IT. THERE'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. A LOT OF TIMES
THEY WON'T BE SUPPORTED WELL IN
LIKE A THIRTY DAY OR- YOU KNOW
THREE MONTHS SIX MONTHS TYPE OF
INTERVENTION. BECAUSE THEY
WON'T HAVE DEVELOPED THEIR- YOU
KNOW EITHER LIKE EDUCATION OR
EMPLOYMENT PEOPLE TO AFFORD
REGULATE RENT AFTER. A SMALL
INTERVENTION LIKE THAT SO. YEAH
I DO THINK THAT THAT'S- YEAH
SICKENING. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS. AS VICE CHAIR I REALLY%
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTIONS
AND YOU'VE BEEN WORKING LONG
AND HARD ON THE SUBJECTS I
APPRECIATE THAT THE QUESTIONS
I'M IS LIMóN THANK YOU AT THIS
SO THANK YOU FOR A TEACHER
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW- OF WHAT
THIS FEELS LIKE IN LOOKS LIKE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I THINK
TO SOME OF THE POINTS WERE MADE
ON ABOUT TO UP ENFORCEMENT
HAVING TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
AND IS SERVING IT THANK OF.
WAVE IN THE CASE JUST WHAT ARE
NOT FEELING EVERY RIGHT ALONG
THAT IT WHETHER IT'S WITH CAO
FAIR FOR OUR CITY POLICE WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME I'M TALKING
TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS
BECAUSE THAT'S THE CALLS THAT
COME. AND ARE AGENCIES CAN'T IN
SOME SOME M. KEPT IN SOME
INSTANCES THEY ACTUALLY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SHARE INFORMATION
AND IN OTHERS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO COURTNEY
INFORMATION GOING THROUGH- AND
WE HAVE SEEN THAT AND I
REPRESENT INSURANCE SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES- AND TO THINK
THAT THERE'S THIS INVISIBLE
LINE WHERE YOU WHO ARE HOMELESS
OR ONE WHO IS KIND IT STAYS
WITHIN SENATE BILL ONE. IT
HAPPENED TIMES WERE I KNOW WE
WANT TO SAY GOSH DID THEY HAVE
SIR ELSEWHERE OUR THERE THINGS
THAT WE DO TO THIS HAPPENED
THIS IS NOT. I'M SO I SHE BACK
COM DO YOU THINK AFTER MORE ON
THAT FOR A I AM WORKING A BILL
ASSEMBLY BUILT SEVENTY TO PAY
AND HOW WE CAN THIS. UP THE.
AND WE WANT. JUST WITH ANY FROM
QUE COUNT. I DO APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS A NAME THANK
THAT ALSO OF YOUR TO KIND FROM
US WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE. THE.
WHAT WAS THAT THE NUMBER OF.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. THE MALL
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S THESE
RECORDED AFRICA'S WE KNOW WHAT
THE RIGHT HAND IS DOING AND WE
DON'T DUPLICATE SERVICES SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THAT PARTICULAR GO I HAVE A
QUESTION- DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
TO SUPPORT THE ARMORY OF THE
RAPID RE HOUSING- AFFECTED FOR
BLACK TINO- YOU. SIR ATTITUDES.
BUT I'VE I KNOW THERE OTHER
FOLKS ARE ON FUTURE PANELS
THAT- HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE OF
RAPID RE HOUSING IN PARTICULAR
SO MAYBE IF ANYBODY ON THE
PANEL THAT'S LISTENING THAT CAN
ANSWER YEAH THAT COULD. ON IT
I'M SO YEAH I HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
DATA YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THE
STATE A KIND OF SPOTTY SOMETIME
SO RIGHT IS AND WE'RE ALL YOU
KNOW WORKING TO TRY TO THE
NUMBERS. AND CERTAINLY. ON THE
NIGHT NUMBER YOUTH ON THE
STREET WHO TORIES ARE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENT BUT I
HAVE A WHOLE PARENTS WITH YOU.
AS WELL THAT WE HAVE TO TRY TO
GET OUR ARMS ARE. TRY TO BUY SO.
TO THEM. YOU KNOW ONE WHAT WHEN
I WENT THE SECOND ASK HOW FROM
ME. I WILL. IN ORDER FOR US TO
ADDRESS ISSUE REALLY. AND IS
MONEY. THE REAL SHE ALL. RIGHT
IS IT. TOO WHAT IT WE THOUGHT
FOR SURE IN DOLLARS WILL SOLVE
THIS ISSUE RIGHT- AND I. DIDN'T
KNOW IF MONEY IS THE FACT THE
ISSUE YEAH RIGHT. YOUR IT IS
WITH IT OVER YEAH I DO THINK
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS SOLVABLE
AND I THINK THAT IT IS ABOUT
INVESTING OUR RESOURCES WISELY
THANK IF POSSIBLE. I WOULD ALSO
SAY THOUGH I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING TO IS THAT THERE IS A
STRUCTURAL PIECES OF THIS THAT
WE NEED TO BE TAKING A LOOK
ABSOLUTELY. PRECISE YOU.
CLEARLY SOME SYSTEM. ISSUES
YEAH MS QUIRK SILVA. THANK YOU
ALL OF YOUR PRESENTATIONS-
THERE'S A FEW THOUGHTS THAT I
HAVE AND- I THINK IF YOU THINK
ABOUT OLD SCHOOL IS A NEW
SCHOOL BECAUSE AGAIN I THAT WAS
NOW IMAGERY. PEERS AND YEARS
AGO THE STATE HAD A PROGRAM
CALLED THE HEALTHY START
PROGRAM. AND IT WAS REALLY BIG
AND I KNOW I'M MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GIPSON WILL BE RUNNING A
NEW BILL A RELATED TO THIS
PROGRAM BUT THE HEALTHY START
PROGRAM WAS SET UP. IN SCHOOLS.
TO PARTNER WITH IN THE
COMMUNITY NOT TO BUILD NEW
PROGRAMS BUT TO WORK IN THE
COMMUNITY TO BUILD A COAL.
ORDER TO TAKE- ADVANTAGE AND
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS OF RESOURCE
IS ALREADY IN YOUR COMMUNITY SO
FOR EXAMPLE TWENTY YEARS AGO I
WAS THE HEALTHY START CO
COORDINATOR- WITHIN MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS A TEACHER ON
SPECIAL ASSIGNMENT. SO I WORK
I'M- FOR EXAMPLE WITH OUR
ASSISTANCE LEAGUE TO HELP BRING
MEALS INTO FOR FAMILIES OR FOR
UNIFORMS WE WORK WITH OUR
OPTOMETRY SCHOOL TO BRING AYE
AYE GLASS- EXAMINATIONS FOR
STUDENTS BUT THAT MODEL ALSO
WORKED. DOING THINGS LIKE
MINING FAMILIES UP FOR A TIME.
AT THAT POINT IT WAS CALLED
HEALTHY FAMILIES INSURANCE THE
POINT OF ALL OF THIS WAS THERE
WAS A MODEL ON THE SCHOOL BASE
WHICH IS REALLY BEAT THE
TRUSTED AREA FOR FAMILIES
COMMUNITY BATES OF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE OUT ABOUT. UP FOR
HOME. THE VERB SHOULD BE LESS
IT'S MANY TO BE WITHIN THE
SCHOOLS. BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
FIRST PEOPLE THEY WILL TALK TO
IS MAYBE A TEACHER AT A
CONFERENCE MAYBE- SOMEBODY AT
THE FRONT DESK SCHOOL I AND
THAT IS. THE FIRST THING SO I'M
GONNA DO REALLY FAST MY P.
PROPOSALS TO SOLVE THIS AT THE
PLAY WITH WORDS AS A TEACHER SO
HERE'S MY PROPOSAL THAT'S THE
FIRST WORD MY PROPOSAL NUMBER
ONE. I DID PERFECTION AND FOR
GEN IF WE CAN KEEP THE- BALL TO
AN FAMILIES FROM GETTING INTO
HOMELESSNESS IN THE FIRST.
PLACE THAT'S A HUGE STEP ONCE
THEY BECOME MOST AS WE ADD THAT
MUCH MORE WORK TO IT SO
LEARNING ABOUT THE FAMILIES
THAT ARE AT RISK AND I
GUARANTEE YOU THERE ARE SCHOOLS
OUT THERE UNDER REPORTING AND I
HAVE A BILL. WE GET THIS FROM
CAN TELL WHY. REMARK REPORT
BECAUSE THEN THEY WOULD BE
RESPONSE FOR ANY TO DO
SOMETHING I'M SORRY I'M AN
EDUCATOR I LOVE EDUCATION I'M A
TEACHER MY CELL. WHEN YOU SAY
THEY'RE AMONG THE JEFF THE-
THINGS. SO. TEN TO BE. YES OF
HOMELESS MCKAY AND THE NEXT THE
OVER ANNA THERE'S 20% REAP NOW
WHY WOULD THAT BE SOMEBODY'S
REPORTING SO I JUST GONNA YOU
TO PARTNERSHIP SOME IS HOW
START PROGRAM IS BASED IN A
SCHOOL WHERE YEAH I HAVE YOUR
TRUST PARKER THEIR FROM FREE K.
THE WAY THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
IT'S GOING TO IT YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE. HI THERE'S ALL OVER THIS.
BUT WHERE TO MOST FOR GO FAMILY
CENTER OVER THESE TYPE OF
PLACES ARE WERE FAMILY START TO
TRUST PEOPLE- AND THEN MAKING
SURE THERE SOME TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PARENTS
EARLY ON. SO THAT STUDENTS.
WHEN THEY BECOME TEENAGERS
WHICH ARE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
EVEN THE BEST FAMILIES- THEY
HAVE THAT COMMUNICATION THEY
CAN DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
KEEP THEIR CHILD WITHIN THEIR
FAMILY. SO THAT'S ANOTHER
PEOPLE ART SHIPS PREVENTION
PROTECTION AND PROTECTION FOR
THESE FAMILIES BUT I'M JUST
GOING TO END WITH ONCE YOU GET
THE PARENTS INVOLVED THEN YOU
CAN START CREATING THESE
PATHWAYS WHICH IS ANOTHER P.
WORD. THESE PATHWAYS ARE THE
WASTE SAY OKAY RIGHT NOW YOU
NEED ASSISTANCE BUT HERE ARE
THE WAYS WE CAN MOVE YOU FOR
ONE MONTH TO A NOT NEXT TWENTY
CLASSES ALL THESE THINGS
WHETHER IT BE FOR THE YOUNGER.
FAULT MADE IT GAVE SCHOOL. I'M
SINCE THEN BECAUSE THE FIRST
PLACE WERE KIDS GET A TROUBLE
IN WAY. YOU CAN ANSWER BACK
BECAUSE UNDER THE COOL THANK
BUT IN SCHOOL LOT OF TO ARE NOT
ENGAGING SO WE HAVE TO WORK
WITHIN THE SCHOOL TO CREATE
THESE PATHWAYS UP AND IF WE DO
THAT MY LIPS PEAS WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE FAMILIES AND YOUNG
ADULTS POSSIBILITIES AND THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO CREATE AS
POSSIBILITIES. THAT THEY HAVE A
FUTURE TO BELIEVE ARE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA THERE WAS NO
QUESTION THERE ARE NO. A
CHAIRMAN TO THANK YOU I JUST
WANNA SAID NEXT ST NICK SOME I
HAVE TO PERSUADE PEOPLE
PERFECTLY. I'M GONNA ASK MS
QUIRK SILVA TO FIGURE OUT MY
BRANDING. I HAVE A QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY FOR A SUPERVISORS
POLICE AND IT'S AROUND THE
INTERSECTION AND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND COUNTIES SO WE KNOW THAT
HOMELESSNESS AND THE HOUSING
CHALLENGES ARE OFTEN OF A
BREAKDOWN OF DIFFERENT SILO
WISED POLICY AREAS SO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM FAILS
FOLKS BECOME HOMELESS THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM FAILS. KIDS
BECOME HOMELESS THE HEALTH CARE
SO FAIL. AND WE'VE HOMELESSNESS
OUT. EVEN THE HELLO OF HIS
WRIST. ARE THE COW LEVEL DO YOU
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW THIS CAN
BETTER WE THE COUNTY LEVEL TO.
FOR US TO AND SENT. YOUR COUNTY
AND OTHER COUNTIES TO THINK IN
THOSE STYLIZED AREAS HOW DO WE-
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE FOR
EXAMPLE- WHEN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS ABOUT TO
RELEASE SOMEONE OR SIX A
JUVENILE PROBATION ABOUT TO
RELEASE. ACT AS IT THAT THEIR
INCENTIVE TO THINK. WITH
HOMELESS ADVOCATES AND HOMELESS
PROVIDERS AND OTHER. AGENCIES
DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS HAD WE
PROACTIVELY ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS SOME WONDERING. IN
THE CURRENT JUSTICE CONTACTS
AND HEALTH CARE CONTEXT FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. WHAT'S ON JUST ON
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE I THINK AB
ONE NINE. I OF RETOOL. SAID YOU
KNOW OF THAT MONEY TO THE
THROUGH REALIGNMENT SO PART OF
IT IS WHILE PEOPLE ARE IN OUR
CUSTODY AND THEY COULD BE THAT
EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN YEAR OLD.
IS MAKING SURE THAT THEY GET
SERVICED THERE WHILE THEY'RE IN
OUR CARE. MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATION TRAINING ANY OF THAT
IN ANY IF THERE'S ANY
ADDICTIONS OR WHATEVER MAKING
SURE WHEN THEY LEAVE THOSE
PREMISES WHETHER IT BE IN PROP
A PROBATION CAP. AS ONE EXAMPLE
YOUTH OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
ARE CONNECTING INSIDE A FULLY
AND THEN MAKING SURE THAT
HAPPENS ON THE OUTSIDE AND
THERE'S A LACK OF FUNDING FOR
THAT. BECAUSE EVERYTHING SEEMS
TO BE PUT IN FORMULAS AND BE
DONE WITH. YOUR RESPECTIVE JUST
WHAT. PEOPLE YOUR IN. ENOUGH
REAL HELP INCENTIVE. AND
CREATIVELY LOOK AT OTHER
MECHANISM SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT WE'VE CREATED FUNDING- TO
LOOK AT WHAT WE CALL- DR SO
LOOKING AT OF. RICK LOOKING AT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO INCENTIVIZE
INDIVIDUALS FROM NOT GOING BACK
AND COMMITTING ANOTHER CRIME.
SO MAKING SURE THROUGH
DIVERSION AND RE ENTRY THAT
WERE ALSO EXPANDING THAT FOR
YOUTH AND LOOKING AT IT FOR.
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF OUR IT'S
TO AND TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
THEY TO TREAT. IT LEAVE SAY ME.
UP TWELVE DAY OF BEING IN. UP
AN EXAMPLE MAYBE THERE WAS
INFRACTION OR COULD HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE THEY WERE HOMELESS AND
THEY- THEY WROTE ABOUT CHECKER
THEY TOOK SOMETHING WE TRIED IT.
THEM WITH. COMMUNITY THAT'S
TOUGH. RIGHT THERE. WE HAVE
THAT CA AND THAT WE CAN'T. A
BODY OF INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO HELP PROVIDE A TREATMENT
WHERE IT'S NEEDED THE MOST AND
WE DON'T GET FUNDING
NECESSARILY AT AND I THINK
SOMETIMES THE NINETIES WERE
GIVEN. A YOU KNOW A AND FOR A
THEIR- THAT I'M ON THIS SIDE.
OF UNFUNDED MANDATES SO THERE
IS A WHOLE LIST OF THINGS THAT
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO DO BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS TO DO-
FEEL I FEEL VERY FIRST. TIME
BECAUSE WE ARE WE AGREED
THERE'S A PROBLEM. IN TERMS OF
GET IN THERE IN THE- STATE OF
THAT IN THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING
AND ABILITY TO ME. ITS OVER
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT YET. TO BE
TORIA SO HELL ANSWER THIS IS A
COOL. WITH OUR CHILD WELFARE SO
ARE PER SYSTEM AND ALL OF THAT
WE'RE DOING THAT AT THE COUNTY
OF LOS ANGELES WHERE WE HAVE
OUR THREE AGENCIES NOW IN ONE
INTEGRATED SYSTEM. AND I AND I
BELIEVE THAT YOUR START YOU
KNOW THAT THE STATE STARTING TO
DO THAT AS WELL. BUT THAT MORE
HAS TO BE SAID ABOUT LOCAL FIRM.
BEING OTHER COUNTIES THAT ARE
JUST AS BIG OR CONFRONTING
ISSUE SHE BE LOOKING AT WAYS OF
IN A- THE WAY WE LOOK AT AN
ISSUE SO IT ISN'T. ALL OF. THIS
CHURCH AND SALAS FIVE CENTS FOR
SO NOW IT'S YOUR PROBLEM NO
LET'S GET IT HOLISTICALLY COULD
YOU I'M OF CARE BRENT TRIED TO.
COME UP WITH A WORKS AT. ACE IN
IT'S OUT THERE YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM SOME OF THE OTHER PAY
BUT ON THAT BEEN OF MY
FRUSTRATION BUT I THINK THERE'S
WAYS OF GETTING AROUND IT AND
MAKING SURE THAT IT WHEN WE DO
PUT UP ANY KIND OF- HOUSING
THAT WE INCLUDE IN THERE ALWAYS
PREVENTION TOOLS NO MATTER WHAT
BUT ALSO AGAIN THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE REALLY- MAKE MAKE CASES
SUCCESS FOR THE INVESTORS AND
WE CAN'T JUST THINK ABOUT IT
AND WHAT WORKS FOR TO THE
ADDITIONAL. MAIL BLOCKING A
SIX. WHEN YOU'RE ALL WE'RE
TAUGHT ABOUT THE FOURTEEN
THROUGH YEAR OLD TO MAYBE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX THAT'S
WHAT YOUR REPORT WAS IDENTIFIED
IN THAT'S A DIFFERENT SITUATION
SAID OF SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE FACED
WITH- BUT THEY STILL HAVE
CHALLENGES SOME OF THEM STILL
NEED- ARE ARE STILL NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED IN TERMS OF THEIR
MATURITY- SO YOU CAN'T JUST OUR
SYSTEM SAYS AFTER A CERTAIN
AGE. YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN. MAYBE
WE MADE SOME MISTAKES ABOUT.
LAW MAYBE OUR LAWS HAVE TO BE
CHANGED TO ROUTE TO ROUTE TO
ALLOW FOR FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
THAT YOUNGSTER THAT PERSON.
THEY NEEDED A SUPPORT THAT THEY
DESERVE. BECAUSE THEY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE- COME INTO A
SITUATION WHERE ALL THE SYSTEMS
HAVE HAVE NOT WORK FOR THEM.
AND IT ISN'T NECESSARILY THAT
YOUNGSTERS FALL. I'M CASES SO
I'M JUST I'M JUST SAYING WE
HAVE TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
FLEXIBLE. MY PLEASURE THAT IT.
IS A CLOSING COMMENT AS A
FARMER SO. MYSELF I DEFINITELY
HEAR THAT- THE SITUATION RUN
UNFUNDED MANDATES AND IT IS MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT WHILE WE HAVE
INVESTED A GOOD SHARE OF MONEY
WE I THINK SHOULD BE INVESTING
A SIGNIFICANT MORE AMOUNT OF
MONEY ONE- BUT TO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BOTH
STREAMLINED AND REALIGN.
EVERYONE'S INTEREST SO THAT
WERE CUT ACROSS SILOS AND WE'RE
ALL WORKING TOWARD THE SAME
GOALS. AND THE THREE ONCE WE'VE
DONE THAT ONCE WE PROVIDED
MONEY IN REAL LIFE WE'VE GOT A-ALL. HOLDER CELLS OCCUR AT ALL
LEVELS. THE COUNTY STATES. SHE
DOES COME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISS HIGH I REALLY
APPRECIATE WILL THE COMETS YOU
MADE HARM REDUCTION EFFORTS-
WHAT NOT ONLY ARE OR DO WE SEE
THAT OUR YOUTH ARE HARMING
THEMSELVES BUT WE AS A SOCIETY
ARE ALSO CAUSING HARM TO
APPRECIATE THAT IS AN EMPHASIS
THAT YOU WERE LOOKING AT I
THANK YOU FOR THAT- MISS SUDDEN.
FOR I APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS. THIS GREAT
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WERE DRESSING IT AND NOT JUST
IN WORDS BUT INACTION- IT THAT
THE FACT THAT HIS ENTIRE- STATE
OF THE STATE ADDRESS WAS
CENTERED AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
ASSET VOLUMES ABOUT HIS
COMMITMENT TO ON THIS. I
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENT
REGARDING THE STATE WIDE
WAREHOUSE TO COLLECT DATA I
WILL TELL YOU THAT A THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
AND- IT WAS ARE YOU INTERESTED
IN THAT. AND THEY CAME TO SEE
ME AND ASKED ME TO THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT BECAUSE
WERE FINE. IF WE OWE THAT ARE
FOR YOU ARE OVER IN THE SYSTEM.
WHY IS IT THAT WE CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MANY OF THEM HAVE
BECOME HOMELESS WHY IS IT THAT
WE CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY OF
THEM NEED FOR THEIR SERVICES IT
IF WERE WORKING IN SILOS IT
BECOMES A PROBLEM. JUST
RECENTLY- SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON- HOSTED A THREE DAY
CONFERENCE ARE RISING TIDES SO.
AND I HAD THE PLEASURE OF-
SITTING ON ONE OF THE PANELS
WITH AS CHAIRMAN CHU ON THAT
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE
BREAKING DOWN. I LOW'S AS CHAIR
OF HOUSING HE KNOWS THAT WE
HAVE TO DO THE SILO. WE TELL
DANCE HELLO WHAT WE CAN WORK
INSIDE. THE SAME THING WITH ITS
HOUSING AND HUMAN SERVICES ALSO
THAT THE CHAIR OF HEALTH- WHICH
INCLUDES MENTAL HEALTH THE
THESE WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
A COLLECT THAT DATA. THAT THIS
IS A GREAT ORGANIZATION. THIS
SONG THAT THE NEED FOR AND
SUPERVISORS POLICE I. MANY OF
US TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY A STATE PROPERTIES
TO REPURPOSE THEM AND AS YOU
SAID TO CREATE A WELLNESS
COMMUNITY- AND CLEARLY SINCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR YOUTH.
THEN I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THESE WELLNESS COMMUNITIES FOR
OUR YOUTH I KNOW THAT WE'LL BE
HEARING FROM SOME OF OUR THE
PANELISTS FROM SAMBAR TO DENY
THAT ARE WORKING SPECIFICALLY
ON I'D LIKE. TO THIS IS. AN
TATIAN. OF AND- THANK YOU FOR
STARTING US OFF. ABOUT ONE OF.
I'D LIKE TO WILL CALL UP THE
NEXT PANEL- ENTITLED PROGRAM
SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WE
WILL HAVE THREE PANELISTS ARE
CODY VAN FILLED IN A YOUTH
ADVOCATE FROM THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. DEL EVEY
EXACT OF DIRECTOR OF THE FAMILY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND MARTY
REGAN THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC FUNDING FROM LARKIN
STREET YOUTH SERVICES. AND YOU
HAVE YOUR NAME TAGS BEHIND YOU.
OKAY ONE WHICH MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO SAY THE TIMES JUST
SO PLEASE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE YOUTH ADVOCATE FOR THE
JOHN BURTON- ADVOCATES FOR
YOUTH AS OUR FIRST SPEAKER I
SHE JUST DOES A GREAT JOB AND I
AM LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT AS
I'M SURE THAT YOU ARE I AM IN
SINCE I AND INTO NUMBER NINE
WITH HIS TYPICALLY COLORFUL
LANGUAGE SAID WHAT DO YOU DO
EN. ROUTE HOMELESS YOUTH. THIS
BILL THAT YES GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR ME
THIS OP TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE
WITH YOU- AS YOU KNOW MY NAME
IS CODY BEN FELDMAN I WORK WITH
JOHN BURTON THAT LIKE IT'S
FREE. TWENTY BOTH APART AT THE
SEAMS RIVER COLLEGE ALSO KNOWN
IF YOU SEE I'M SAID THE
GRADUATE THIS SEMESTER AND
HOPEFULLY TRANSFER TO FAX ST
PAUL MY GOAL V. S. S. AND WORK
YOU MIGHT IS FOR MY OWN ONLY AS
THE AND I'M GONNA SHOW SOME OF
THE SIX WITH THIS MORNING OR
THIS AT. FOR AN ADULT YES.
ABOUT TIMES AS- A BABY AGE. I
REMAINED IN MY ADOPTIVE PARENTS
HOME UNTIL I WAS SIXTEEN. A
MONTH PRIOR TO MY SEVENTEENTH
BIRTHDAY I WAS KICKED OUT BY MY
ADOPTIVE PARENTS. CBS GOT
INVOLVED SHORTLY AFTER AND I
WAS PLACED IN A FOSTER
PLACEMENT STILL UNDER THE
PRETENSE OF BEING ADOPT. SO I
DID NOT RECEIVE ANY THIS IS ALL
I CARE. DUE TO S. UPON MY
EIGHTY BIRTHDAY I DON'T QUALIFY
FOR A. B. TWELVE. AND WAS
KICKED OUT OF MY PLACEMENT. AT
THE SAME TIME I JUST BEGUN MY
FOR SEMESTER AT SEA ARE. ANY IN
PROVIDE WAS PRIDE. OF CAN'T
SWITCH I COULD NOT AFFORD. I
HAD REALLY. WITH MY DAD PARENTS.
THE TIME IS NOT. MY BY. FAMILY
WAS. FOR ME TO FACE IT OUT ON
MY OWN. MY FIRST EX WITH HOME
THIS WAS ABOUT FIVE. THANKS FOR
THIS AGAIN SHORTLY THEREAFTER
THE SUMMER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ABOUT FOR TO FOUR.
BEFORE I MOVED IN WITH FAMILY
IN THE TIME THAT I WAS HOME FOR
HOMELESS I ATTEMPTED TO TRY
MANY DIFFERENT RESOURCES I TRY
AB TWELVE BUT DIDN'T QUALIFY
LIKE SO MANY OTHER YOUTH.
COUNCILS THAT MY SCHOOL HAD
TRIED TO CONNECT WITH HOUSING
BUT THAT DIDN'T LEAD ANYWHERE
WHEN I FIRST BECAME HOMELESS MY
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER WENT
WITH ME TO TRY AND LOCATE YOUTH
HOUSING SERVICES. AT THE WAIT
LET WE'RE SO LONG THAT IT WAS
ODDS OF GETTING IN WERE SLIM TO
NONE. LASTLY I TRIED BIRTH AND
CAN ONLY IT WAS NOT A SHELTER
DESIGNED FOR THE COMPANY DO YOU.
WAS TRAUMATIC FOR ME A I WAS ON
IT TO STAY. BEING A PEOPLE MUCH
OLDER THAN ME TO. ME I WAS
UNABLE TO CONNECT WITH ANYONE
AND COMING FROM A DRAMATIC
BACKGROUND I FELT VULNERABLE.
THE YOUNGER WE USE ARE THE MORE
WE ARE PSYCHOLOGICALLY
VULNERABLE TO TOXIC SITUATIONS.
I DID EVERYTHING YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO DO BUT THERE WAS
NOTHING FOR ME. SO I RESORTED
TO CAP CHOPPING WITH PEOPLE I
BARELY KNOW. DURING THE TIME
THAT I WAS HOMELESS I WAS
EXPOSED TO PEOPLE DOING DRUGS.
AT THE TIME THAT I WAS DOING.
AT THE TIME THAT I WAS HOMELESS
I WAS ALSO DOING ONLINE DATING
JUST TO FIND A PLACE TO SLEEP
FOR A NIGHT. WHICH LED TO
UNSAFE SITUATIONS. AFTER FIVE
MONTHS I'VE GOTTEN TO
RELATIONSHIP THAT WAS HIGHLY
ABUSIVE. I WAS EXPERIENCING THE
LOGICAL TIONAL PHYSICAL
FINANCIAL ABUSE. BUT BECAUSE I
HAD NOWHERE ELSE TO GO I WAS
FORCED TO STAY. BE FORCED INTO
THIS RELATIONSHIP DUE TO
HOMELESSNESS LET ME DOWN A
PATH. THAT RESULTED IN THE
ATTEMPT OF MY OWN LIFE. DUE TO
HOMELESSNESS THE SITUATION THAT
RESULTED FROM IT MY ACADEMICS
ALSO BEGAN TO SUFFER. I GOT TO
SEE IS A MY FIRST SEMESTER AND
THE FOLLOWING NEXT SEMESTER I
ADORED SO MUCH ABUSE MIGRAINES
EARNED WEREN'T FC AND A D. AND
A WITHDRAWAL. I WAS PLACED ON
ACADEMIC PROBATION TWICE AND
WAS REMOVED PLACE ON DISMISSAL
BLECKLEY THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN. TO
PUT IN PERSPECTIVE HOW
IMPORTANT HOUSING IS FALL TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN SEMESTER
I WAS TAKING FIVE CLASSES AS A
FULL TIME STUDENT. AND IT JUST
STARTED A JOB AND I PASSED WITH
STRAIGHT EIGHTH. I AM AN
EXCELLENT STUDENT BUT WHEN
HOUSING IS UNRELIABLE AND YOUTH
ARE FACING HOMELESSNESS
EVERYTHING AROUND THEM SUFFERS.
THE YEAR I WAS IN PLACEMENT MY
CATION OF NOT SLIP THROUGH THE
CAR THROUGH THE CRACKS I
EXPERIENCE THE FILLED ADOPTION
DUE TO EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
ABUSE. THE ROLE OF CHILD THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM WAS TO
ENSURE I WAS PLACED BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM AND RECEIVED
ASSISTANCE THROUGHOUT THE TIME
THAT I WAS IN CARE. RECEIVING
SERVICES WHILE I WAS IN CARE
WOULD HAVE MEANT I WAS IN CARE
LEGALLY LEADING TO THE
FULFILLMENT OF ALL AB TWELVE
REQUIREMENTS UNFORTUNATELY THIS
WAS NOT THE CASE WHICH LED TO
MY FIRST EXPERIENCE WITH HOME.
THIS EVENT WILL HELP ME WITH MY
BIOLOGICAL FAMILY ESPECIALLY MY
DAD'S BROTHER. I'VE KNOWN THEM
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS NOW. THEY
FOUND MY SIBLINGS AND I THROUGH
FACEBOOK AND REACHED OUT AND
OFFER THEIR HOME TO ME AFTER MY
RELATIONSHIP ENDED. IF HOUSING
SERVICES WERE AVAILABLE TO ME I
WOULD HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
BE STABLE ON MY OWN. AND NOT
BEEN PUT ABOVE SITUATION OF
SURVIVAL. I WOULD HAVE HAD THE
SAFETY NECESSARY TO ALLOW ME TO
START MY COLLEGE CAREER ON THE
RIGHT TRACK. MANY YOUTH DON'T
HAVE THE SKILLS TO ADAPT TO THE
ADULT WORLD WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN
AND EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS I
SURELY DIDN'T. LEARNING NEW
SKILLS TAKES TIME AND SUPPORT.
I WAS FORTUNATE MY BIOLOGICAL
FAMILY FOUND AND OFFERED HELP
TO ME BUT NOT ALL YOUTH
EXPERIENCE THIS FOR THE YOUTH
WHO DO NOT HAVING A BUDGET AND
SERVICES SET ASIDE FOR
HOMELESSNESS. CAN GIVE THEM
TIME IN A PSYCHOLOGICAL IF
PLACE TO LEARN THE SKILLS
NEEDED FOR THEM IN THE ADULT
WORLD. WHEN I FIRST WENT TO THE
HOMELESS SHELTER I REMEMBER ONE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS WITH THE
SAME TO STAY WAS TO LOOK FOR
EMPLOYMENT OR POOL. AT THE TIME
NO I WAS STRUGGLING SCHOOL AND
COULDN'T EVEN FATHOM WORKING
DUE TO MY MENTAL HEALTH
STRUGGLES. YOUTH NEED SPECIFIED
SERVICE. I NEED TO SPECIFY
PROCESS. AS A YOUTH WE ARE
STARTING OFFER LAP INTO BEING
AN ADULT AND THAT'LL BONE IS
FOR TRANSIT. ADDING STRUGGLE
BEING HOME MAKES IS MUCH DE.
I'M ASKING YOU SUPPORT THE
BUDGET SET ASIDE FOR YOU TO
INVEST IN PROGRAMS. HOUSING AND
SERVICES THAT ARE FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
THEM A SECOND CHANCE. AND FOR
SOME IT COULD PREVENT TOXIC AND
UNSAFE SITUATIONS BEFORE THEY
BEGIN. THANK YOU. OR JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THAT- WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
EXPERTS TODAY BUT YOUR
EXPERTISE IS DRAWN FROM. THE
VERY INTENSELY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR SHARING THAT AND- AND
HELPING IT TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC AND PROVIDING THAT
SERVICE. THANK YOU. MYSTERY BE.
WHEN IS THERE LEAVE IT WAS
FAMILY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. WHEN
I THINK ABOUT HOW WE GOT WHERE
WE ARE IN THIS HOUSING CRISIS
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU THE THING
I REMIND REMIND MYSELF IS TEN
YEARS AGO THERE WERE NO
SERVICES FOR HOMELESS YOUTH IN
SEMINOLE COUNTY FAIRFIELD
COUNTY IS THE LARGEST COUNTY IN
THE NATION WE HAVE A POPULATION
OF OVER TWO MILLION PEOPLE AND
THERE WAS NOT ONE SINGLE
LOCATION FOR HOMELESS YOUTH WE
DIDN'T HAVE SHELTERS WE DIDN'T
HAVE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. WE
DON'T HAVE DROP IN CENTERS
NOTHING AND WITH OUR AGENCY
BECAME INVOLVED WITH THAT
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT THIS IS A
GAP IN SERVICES AND WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS AS WE GOT MORE
INVOLVED WE WERE ABLE TO GET.
FUNDING AND THEN WE WILL. FIND
AN FOR. FIRST SO WE OPERATED ON
SOME FELL FUNDING AND SOME
FOUND. FUND AND- UP UNTIL NOW
BERNADINO COUNTY STILL HAS NOT
SPENT ANY MONEY THAT THEY
WEREN'T ACTUALLY FORCED TO
SPEND. ON HELPING HOME HERE. SO
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT THE HEAT
FUNDING WHEN IT CAME AVAILABLE
THAT 5% SET ASIDE WAS REQUIRED.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DID THEY
SET ASIDE FIVE PERCENT. AND
WITH THAT 5% WE WERE ABLE TO
ADD TRANSIT HOUSING SO OUR
AGENCY CURRENTLY. WE HAVE A
SHELTER FOR HOMELESS. AND WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF OPENING A
SECOND SHELTER FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH. WE HAD IT WE HAD FORTY
BEDS OF TRADITIONAL HOUSING.
AND WITH THE HEAT FUNDING WE
ARE AT THE ABLE TO ADD TWELVE
MORE. WE ALSO HAVE THREE DROP
IN CENTERS THEY WERE IN THE
PROCESS. ADDING TO MORE OF
THOSE WHO WERE AYE PROVIDING A
RANGE OF SERVICES FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE. STARTED RECRUITING.
MORE IT SEATS AND- EIGHT. THAT
ARE. A J. BUT YOU. SAMPLE
LETTER THROUGH OR AGENTS OR-
ORGANS. WHERE THEY PROVIDING.
JOB TRAINING SERVICES OR THEIR
PROVIDING PROBATE CANCER. HELP
THEM EARN AT ALL WITH ARAFAT.
NEED HELP. WELL TO BAN SERVICES
INTO THE AIR. ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE THAT I'VE LOVED ABOUT WHAT
WE DO THE IS TO WORK WITH THE
K. I GET JOY OF GETTING TO TALK
TO PEOPLE LIKE CODY EVERYDAY
AND- THEY ARE. RICH AND THAT'S
US IS OUT TO ME ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LEARNED I'M A
MARINE AND WHEN I WAS IN THE
MARINE CORPS ONE OF THINGS THAT
I LEARNED IF YOU DON'T LEAVE
ANYONE BEHIND AND EVEN IF THERE
EVEN IF YOU'RE BEING SHOT AT
YOU LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND. THESE
KIDS DO THAT THESE PEOPLE WILL
RATHER SLEEP THEIR CAR WITH
THEIR FRIENDS AND GO TO A
PROGRAM WHERE IF THEY DON'T
THINK A FRIEND IS GOING TO BE
SAID. AND REALLY THEY REALLY
HAVE THAT CONCERN THAT CARE
FREE OTHER WHICH I THINK IS.
OOPS REBEL WITH THE SOMETIMES
THEY DON'T MAY MATES I LEARN TO
BE A GOOD ROOM WHEN I WAS NOT
BEING A GOOD ROOMMATE WHILE I
WAS IN THE MARINE CORPS AND MY
PLATOON SERGEANT MADE ME SLEEP
IN A TENT IN THE YARD AND TELL
I COULD LEARN HOW TO GET ALONG
WITH MY ROOMMATES WE ALL NEED
TO LEARN THAT AND WE HELP OUR
KIDS LEARN THAT THAT'S A VERY
NOBLE SKILL BUT THEY DIDN'T
HAVE A HELP GET PAST THE OTHER
ONE IS- EMPLOYEE. GRAY
EMPLOYMENT. THERE THAT TEACH
GET. YOUNG PEOPLE. HOW TO.
APPLY A JOB HOW TO WRITE A
RESUME AND HOW TO DO THAT WHAT
THEY DON'T TEACH THEM IS HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE DEPRESSION OF
REJECTION. I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS
SOMETHING I DON'T THINK I COULD
EVER DO BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
EVERY TWO YEARS I HAD A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE DECIDED. YOU'RE
NOT ANYMORE. I HEAR THAT. LIKE
EGO JUST TO FRACK I DON'T THINK
I COULD DO WHAT YOU GUYS DO
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE THERE ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND EMPLOYMENT
AND THERE AND PART OF THE
REASON THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO
FIND EMPLOYMENT THEY DON'T HAVE
A JOB HISTORY. YOU DON'T HAVE
SECURE HOUSING THE HAVE THE
PROPER. THE THERE'S A LOT OF
THAT GOING ON THERE AND THERE'S
A LOT OF ACTION AND IF ANY OF
YOU EVER BEEN UNEMPLOYED YOU
KNOW THAT YOU GET REJECTED A
LOT AND WE NEED WE DO A LOT OF
CHEERLEADING FOR CATS YOU KNOW
WE HELP THEM UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN THEY GO TO APPLY AND THEY
GET REJECTED THAT'S OKAY THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH YOU WHICH MEANS THAT
WE NEED. GO MORE I MAY IT WAS A
FOR YOU WE DON'T FIND IN WE
WERE TO BEST JOB FOR YOU AT HOW
TO BE OPEN TO THAT PROCESS
THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAD SO WOMAN
THE TALK OUT CASE BEEN
IMPORTANT CASE COMPLY WITH.
BACK IT BATCH. OF THE ACT. IF
YOU CAN AND HOUSING IF YOU
DON'T EMPLOYEE AND YOU CAN'T
AND EMPLOYMENT IF YOU DO HAVE
HOUSE CASE MANAGEMENT IMPORTANT
BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE A FOR THIS
TO LIVE WHILE WE'RE THAT MANAGE
THAN MANAGER ISN'T VERY%
EFFECTIVE SO THE SERVICES THAT
WE HAVE- IT'S NICE TO SEE I
THINK WE'RE AT AN EXCITING TIME
WORKING WITH HOMELESS YOUTH.
AND THE REASON I SEE THAT IS
IT'S ON THE FOREFRONT PEOPLE
ARE TALKING ABOUT IT FINALLY
TEN YEARS AGO I COULDN'T ANYONE
TO TALK TO US ABOUT IT AND
TODAY IT'S RIGHT ON THE FRONT
PAGE PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IT WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS IN
THAT AREA IS EXCITING TO SEE
THAT PROGRESS- I WAS ASKED.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
HEAT FUNDING- WHEN WE RECEIVE
THAT FUNDING WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
GOTTEN FUNDING FROM OUR LOCAL
CONTINUUM OF CARE- ALL OF THE
HEAD FUNDING THAT COMES INTO
OUR COUNTY IN OUR CONTINUUM.
GOES STRAIGHT TO A DAHLE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AND
VETERANS I'M A VETERAN I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT ALSO I
THINK YOUNG PEOPLE NEED A
LITTLE HELP IN THAT AREA. SO IS
EXCITED THAT THE SET ASIDE THIS
ALLOWED US TO ADD THOSE NEW
BEDS. I CAN ALREADY POINT TO-
AT LEAST ONE KID WHO IS. IN
RIGHT NOW. HE ONE OF THE JOY. I
GOT IT HE- UNTIL HE CON TO SOME
HOOPS. AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET
A MENTOR HE HOUSING PROGRAM AND
THEN HELP INTO THAT PROCESS.
AND NOW HE'S A BOOT CAMP AND
NOW HE'S GOT HIS. HIS PACK ON
HIS GOING ON THIS PATH AND HE'S
DOING GREAT STUFF I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. SEVERAL I
COULD GO FOR AN HOUR. ABOUT THE-
THAT WE'VE BEEN A TO MAKE THESE
GREAT PROGRESS WITH. EXCITING
TO SEE THOSE BACK GROWTH. TWO
LAST THINGS THAT WE DID WANT TO
COMMENT ON- THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE IS A BODY AND YOU GUYS ALL
KNOW HOW THAT PROCESS WORKS. HI
DO HAS DONE IT I THINK A REALLY
OUTSTANDING THING AYE AYE IT'S
BEEN TWENTY THIRTY YEARS OR
SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THIS BUT- THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE DECIDES WHAT THE
PRIORITIES. THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY IS. AND THEN
CONTRACTS GOOD. PLEA FROM HUD
TO THE NONPROFIT. I THINK THAT
SYSTEM HAS WORKED REALLY WELL
AND THAT'S WHY WE CONTINUE TO
USE IT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. THIS AN AIDE TO CUT
MAYBE MODEL THAT SAME PROCESS
BECAUSE THAT THIS HEAT FUNDING
AND WITH THE HELP FUNDING THE
MONEY GOES TO THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. AT LEAST OUR CONTINUUM OF
CARE DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO. THERE
AND THEY'RE MAKING. BUT THAT'S
NOT THEIR FORTE THAT THERE
REALLY STRUGGLING IN THAT AREA
SO SOMETHING I'D ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER. AND THE LAST THING IS
WHEN TAX SEASON. AND I'M
ASSUMING YOU'VE ALL PROBABLY OF
EITHER PAGER TAXES ARE WORKING
ON YOUR TAXES. I LOVE TAXIS AND
NOW AND THE REASON I LOVE IT IS
BECAUSE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
WE WORK WITH. I GOT JOBS AND
FREQUENTLY THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IN THEIR LIFE THEY'VE EVER
HAD A JOB. THE FOR AND THEY'VE
HAD TO FILE TAX. THEY HAVE THE
pGIANTS STYLES. FACE AND THEY'RE
SO EXCITED BECAUSE THEY'RE LIKE
I'M A LEGIT HERE. NOW BILL
PERSON I. TAXES AND THEN THEY
GET THE THOUGHT ATTITUDE GOING
LIKE I GET TO TELL PEOPLE WHAT
TO DO BECAUSE I PAID A SALARY.
IT'S A- RELIEF FOR. AIRING WHEN
YOU WERE YOUNG. GETTING TO FILE.
IS NOW WHEN THERE ARE OUR AGE
THAT. WILL BE ON. BE OUT. AND
ABOUT. BUT IT IS. REALLY GREAT
RIGHT TO PASS THE C. PAP.
TICKET FOR THAT. THANK YOU. I
WANT TO APOLOGIZE AT THE OUTSET
I HAVE A LONG SCHEDULE THREE
O'CLOCK APPOINTMENT. BUT BEFORE
I TURN IT BACK OVER TO- MY
FELLOW CULTURE I WANT TO
WELCOME- MS REGAN FROM ONE OF
MY GREAT SAN FRANCISCO
ORGANIZATIONS AND JUST HELP
FALLING. STORY TO OUR
COLLEAGUES. SO ABOUT SIX YEARS
AGO I WAS ASKED TO CARRY
LEGISLATION TO BUILD A
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH. PROJECT
IN- WHAT IS KNOWN AS A VERY
ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL
NEIGHBORHOOD IN MY CITY. AND IT
WAS TREMENDOUS PUSH BACK IDEA
THAT SOMEHOW THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
WAS GOING TO INVOLVE. THOSE
PEOPLE COMING TO THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD- I WAS AMONG ALL
THE ADVOCATES FOR THIS PROGRAM
WE WERE THREATENED WITH MANY
THINGS POLITICALLY OTHERWISE-
MOVED PROJECT FOR. AND THANKS
TO TREAT YOU SERVICES PROJECT.
MALL ARE YOU. CRITICS SUCH AS
THE PERSON BUT I STATE AND I
HAVE NOT A SINGLE COMPONENT
THAT PROJECT IN YEARS SO WITH
THAT INTRODUCTION AS WE CAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME-
I'M ACTUALLY VERY HONORED TO BE
HERE AND I. WANT TO TALK ABOUT
LOGAN STREET YOUTH- IN HONOR OF
CODY AND- ALL OF THEIR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
WE REPRESENT- THERE'S TOO MANY.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT. BUT
NO YOUNG PERSON SHOULD EVER BE
WITHOUT A STEVEN STABLE HOME-
THERE ARE TOO MANY ONE IN TEN-
PEOPLE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWELVE AND TWENTY FIVE BOOKS
TRAINS HOMELESSNESS IN THIS
COUNTRY- IT IS UNACCEPTABLE
IT'S VERY SERIOUS BUT IT'S
SOULFUL. SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR LARA TRADE HAS LEARNED
WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS NEED TO MOVE OFF
THE STREET AND INTO SUCCESSFUL
LIVES. THREE THINGS. A RANGE OF
DIVERSE HOUSING OPTIONS THAT
ARE EASY TO GET INTO AND HARD
TO FALL OUT OF. ROBUST SUPPORT
SERVICES DELIVERED BY WELL
TRAINED STAFF COMMITTED TO
DEEPLY ENGAGING WITH YOUTH TO
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS. AUTHENTIC
AND MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
HAVE A VOICE IN THE DECISIONS
THAT AFFECT THEM. AND AS YOU
ALL KNOW THE STATS CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF YOUTH EXT YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
SAN FRANCISCO ONE IN FIVE OR
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE
AGAIN UNACCEPTABLE. TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED TO THREE THOUSAND YOUTH
ACCESS SERVICES AT THE ORGAN
STREET EVERY YEAR. AND I WANT
TO JUST REVIEW WHAT IT IS THAT
WE DO IS A HOLISTIC APPROACH.
WITHOUT REACHING AGENT SERVICES
AND THIS IS WHERE IT STARTS.
STREET OUTREACH TEAMS MEETING
YOUTH WITH BASIC NEEDS ON THE
STREETS GOING WHERE THEY ARE
THE HARM REDUCTION APPROACH.
MEANING WE MEET YOU WHERE THEY
ARE BUT WE DON'T LEAVE THEM
WHERE THEY'RE AT AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO. UNDERSTAND
WE BRING FOOD CLOTHING HYGIENE
AND WE BUILD TRUST. WE HAVE
DROP IN CENTERS WHICH HAVE
EXTREMELY LOW BARRIERS THEY'RE
ALL WELCOME EVERYONE'S WELCOME
COULD BUILD DEEPER ENGAGEMENT.
IF THEY'RE NOT READY TO ACCESS
SERVICES THAT'S OKAY THE COMBAT.
OR HOUSING OPTIONS MERGES THE
SHELTERS TIME LIMITED AND NON
TIME LIMITED RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS RENTAL SUBSIDIES
VOUCHERS SCATTERED SITE SHARED
HOUSING. ALL OF THESE OPTIONS
ON THE TABLE STEVE SUBSIDIES
CHAU SUBSIDIES IT IT ALL IT'S
ALL NEEDED EVERY ASPECT OF
HOUSING EVERY OPTION- EVERY
CREATIVE- METHOD THAT WE CAN
USE. IT WITH THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GOV ALL WITH
ONSITE INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT HEALTH CARE ONLY
GOOD JUST OTHER SERVICES.
EDUCATION I'M MEANT INTENSIVE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLANS TO ENSURE
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS NOT
REOCCURRING. WE HAVE CO ARE
BASED CURRICULA FOCUSED ON POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND CAREER
TRACK EMPLOYMENT. WITH LIVING
WAGE. WITH LONGSTANDING
RELATIONSHIPS OF LOCAL
EMPLOYERS COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
SAN FRANCISCO AS OF STATE AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS IN
RETAIL FOOD HANDLING AND TECH.
INDIVIDUAL AT COLLEGE AND JOB
COUNSELING TUTORING JOB
PLACEMENT INTERNSHIPS WERE WITH
THEM EVERY SINGLE STEP OF THE
WAY. HEALTH AND WELLNESS
CRITICAL MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS THAT INCLUDE PRIMARY
CARE PREVENTION EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES INCLUDING
MOTIVATIONAL INTERVIEWING TO
ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
USE AND TRAUMA. GROUP AN
INTERVAL INDIVIDUAL SERVICES
THERAPY IN SUPPORT GROUPS. AND
THEN IN TASTE INTENSIVE CASE
MANAGEMENT I HEARD A LOT OF.
RIGHT OF REFERENCES TO CASE
MANAGEMENT. AND IT'S
INDIVIDUALIZED LOW THRESHOLD TO
ACCESS STRENGTH BASED OUTCOMES
FOCUSED AND ALWAYS EXIT
PLANNING FROM THE VERY FIRST
STEP EXIT PLANNING- WE LIKE TO
SAY AT OREGON STREET THAT WE
DON'T TO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO BE. PERMANENTLY ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
ORCHESTRATE YOUR AN EXIT PLAN
YOUR YOUR YOUR HOMELESSNESS IS
BRICK. I'M YOU'RE HERE WITH US
FOR THE DURATION AND AS DEEP AS
YOU NEED US AND THEN WE WANT TO
GET YOU OUT AND- ON YOUR OWN.
ASHLEIGH'S NEEDS INCLUDING HIV
POSITIVE YOUTH FOSTER YOUTH
YOUTH OF MENTAL ILLNESS LGBT Q.
YOUTH ENTRANCE YOU WE HAVE- WE
DO RUN THE ONLY TRANSPACIFIC A
HOUSING SITE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
OUTCOMES AND RESULTS ARE LONG
LONG TERM GOALS FOR EVERY
SINGLE YOU THROUGH COME TO
MARTIN ST. SAVE UNSTABLE
HOUSING PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
WELLNESS SUSTAINABLE CAREER
TRACK EMPLOYMENT AT A LIVING
WAGE AND POST HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION WHATEVER THAT LOOKS
LIKE FOR THAT PERSON. SO OUR
RESULTS SO- AMONG THE YOUTH OR
EXITING LARKIN STREET SO AS OF
LAST YEAR 81% EXITED TO STABLE
HOUSING. 60% A CHIEF PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL WELLNESS 70% WERE
EMPLOYED OR ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
AND THEIR AVERAGE MONTHLY
INCOME WITH SIXTEEN HUNDRED AND
ONE DOLLARS. FROM ZERO. THE
LARGER RESULTS IN THIS IS WHAT
I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH.
BECAUSE OF THE INVESTMENT OF
FUNDS FROM LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL SOURCES WE ARE ACTUALLY
SEEING A DECREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF HOMELESS YOUTH UNDER TWENTY
FIVE IN OUR ANNUAL PICK OUT.
THAT'S HUGE SO FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
WE'RE SEEING A 10% DROP AND-
WHAT I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH
IS PUBLIC INVESTMENT. PUBLIC
DOLLAR INVESTMENT WORKS AND
WE'RE SEEING IT WE HAVE THE
DATA AND THEY WANT TO. LEAVE
YOU WITH PLEASE KEEP DOING IT.
I TO ANSWER THE QUESTION OF THE
PERSON WHO LEFT EARLIER. YES
IT'S ABOUT MONEY IT'S ABOUT
MONEY IT'S ABOUT MONEY IS
RESOURCES IT'S WE NEED MORE
HOUSING BUT UNTIL WE GET LOTS
AND LOTS OF HOUSING. WE AND
FAMILIES THIS PROGRAM IN ALL OF
MY PARTNERS IN THE SPACE. NEED
AS MUCH RESOURCES AS POSSIBLE
TO KEEP. SERVING YOUTH WHEN WE
SOLVE FOR YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WE
SOLD FOR. ALL ADULT
HOMELESSNESS- IT'S A- RISING
TIDE SITUATION OF WERE
PREVENTING THE FUTURE. AND
CAN'T POPULATION. AT THAT'S A
LEVY. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. YES DOCTOR CHORE.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
HARD WORK TO HELP YOU WITH THE
HOMELESS. PEOPLE. I'M GLAD OF
THAT- YOU'LL PROGRAM IS WORKING
AND- DECREASING IN IN THAT THAT
IS- IN A OF GOOD NEWS. I WONDER
IF ANYBODY HAS COLLECTED A IN
THE DATA HE USED HOMELESS
CATEGORIES SO WHAT ARE THE
PROBLEMS OF PROBABLY LARGELY
THREE FOUR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
TO WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE- AT
THE- ON THE STREET AND BECOME
HOME NASA BECAUSE OF THE ERA.
MY GUESTS THE CHOICE OF THEIR
LIFESTYLE. OR BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THEM. HOME SITUATION WITH THE
PARENTS. OR MENTAL ILLNESS. OR
OVER EIGHTEEN. MAYBE A NON WORK
UNEMPLOYMENT DO YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN DATA YES TO ALL OF
PACKED. YES THE TOOL. AND A AND
A WHAT IS THE HIGHEST A
PERCENTAGE CATEGORY WHICH ONE.
UP IN SAN FRANCISCO THE- THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE IT. WE HAVE-
LGBTQ YOUTH AND A YOUTH OF
COLOR- ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
REPRESENTED INOUR HOME WITH
YOU POPULATION SO IT'S AN
INTERSECTION OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND VERY SYSTEMIC- RACIAL
INEQUITY ON BOTH ENDS THAT
SEVERELY IMPACT THESE YOU.
GENERATIONAL POVERTY SO WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF YOUTH WHOS
FAMILIES ARE POOR AND SO
THEY'RE LEAVING THERE'S A HIGH
A HIGH AMOUNT OF STRESS AND
TRAUMA RELATED TO THAT SO
THEY'RE EITHER KICKED OUT OR
THEY'RE LEAVING AND OF COURSE
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. SO IT'S
A IT'S AND THAT'S WHY YES TO
EVERYTHING THEY GET. KICKED OUT
OF THE- PARENTS HOUSE. SAYS
SOME. SOME HAVE THAT THE
BIGGEST ISSUE THAT WE SEE AS- A
LACK OF EMPLOYMENT. THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE JOB
SKILLS AND THEY DON'T HAVE AN
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY THEY HAVE
THEY STRUGGLE FINDING
EMPLOYMENT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
EMPLOYMENT AND YOU CAN'T HAVE
IT HAVE HOUSING. IT WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE HOUSING ITSELF BUT
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
HOUSING. OKAY IF YOU HAVE
IDENTIFIED THAT THAT IS SO-
HIGHS COSTS OF FOR YOUTH ON
EMPLOYMENT. WHAT APPROACH. TO
HAVE YOU STARTED THAT
INTRODUCED US TO. IF DOES UP
UNEMPLOYMENT THE TOP SKIERS.
THE THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
JOB TRAINING PROGRAMS OUT THERE
ALREADY. THE PROBLEM THAT WE'VE
HAD IS THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO ACCESS
THOSE HOUSE OF THOSE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
THEIR LACK OF HOUSING. WHAT WE
AND AS WE SEPTEMBER PROVIDE.
COMPACT OF THAT AND THEN GET
THEM TO SCHOOL OR TO THE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND INTO
THOSE PROGRAMS. MOST OF THE
PROGRAM'S RICK. THAT CLASS. THE
THREE FRIDAY FOR OF A COUPLE
DAYS A WEEK WHATEVER THE IS
IT'S A RECURRING OVER AND OVER
THE NEED TO ATTEND SCHOOL AND
THEY NEED TO STOP THEY NEED FOR
SCHOOL SMELLING NICE AT ALL OF
THOSE ELEMENTS AND YOU DON'T
GET THOSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
PLACE TO LIVE SO WHEN WE
PROVIDE THAT HOUSING. EVERYONE
HOUSING. IN OUR HOUSING PROGRAM-THEY HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN AND
USUALLY WHAT I NEED SEVENTY ONE
JOB WHEN YOU FIND THEM YOU
PROVIDE THE HOUSING BUT AFTER A
CERTAIN PERIOD TO USE ON ON ON
THAT THEM RELY ON YOU AND THE
YOU TO COME OUT. AND YOU CAN
COME OUT THE DO THEY GO TO ST
AGAIN WE DO NOT EVER KICK
ANYONE OUT SO WHEN THEY OWN
THEM IN MISTER MONEY ONE OF ALL
YOU MENTIONED THEY'LL THEY'LL
KICK YOU KNOW AND I WANT TO
SAY- EXISTING JOBS IS ONE ISSUE
BUT THERE ARE MULTIPLE ISSUES
THERE'S OF. ALL OF THE SUPPORT
THERE'S- HOUSING IS A HUGE A
BUT OF DEALING WITH THE TRAUMA.
THE THINGS IF EVERYBODY CAN GO
BACK TO WHEN THEY WERE YOU KNOW
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. THAT AGE SO FROM
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR IS THE
SECOND HIGHEST. A DEVELOPMENTAL
STAGE SECOND ONLY TO ZERO TO
FIVE. AND IT'S THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SECOND MOST
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTAL STAGE
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS GOING ON
THEN YOU LATER ON. FAMILY
TRAUMA- VICTIMIZATION OF
PHYSICAL ABUSE. BLACK OF
HOUSING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DEPRESSION ALL THE OTHER
BARRIERS. AND THEN. TO SAY-
WHAT ARE YOU WORKING AT AND
THEN I'M GONNA THINGS IT CAME
FROM THE OUR HOME INITIAL FROM
THEIR HOMES HAVING TO LEAVE
EITHER BEING BORN INTO PROP
POVERTY- BEING KICKED OUT OF
THE FALLS OR AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. LOSING
THEIR HOUSING BEING KICKED OUT
OF WHERE THEY ARE HAVING TO
LEAVE AN ABUSIVE SITUATION AND
THEN TO SAY HOLD ON A JOB. WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS- ON TOP OF BEING
A- FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
TWENTY YEAR OLD HUMAN BEING-
THOSE THINGS HAVE YOU HAVE TO
VOICE THAT PERSON- AND I WANT
TO. JUST DO A QUICK SHOUT OUT
OF IT AS FAR AS JOB TRAINING A
ONE I'M A HUGE ADVOCATE OF
PAYING A LIVING WAGE FOR YOUTH
TO TRADE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS WE HEAR IS THAT THEY
WANT TO GO TO TRAINING BUT- I
HAVE TO MAKE MONEY SO I HAVE TO
GET X. TO KEEP MY JOB SO I CAN.
YOU KNOW KEEP GETTING MY
SUBSIDY IN WE NEED TO JUST
REALLY. OF THIS BECAUSE EFFORT
PAY LIVING WAGES BUT
PARTICULARLY FOR JOB TRAINING.
FOR YOUTH AND- SO. EVEN WHEN.
WE TALK ABOUT THEM. WAY AMONG
THE MORE MORE MORE MORE MORE
THAN FOR. DOLLARS AN HOUR. SO
WHAT WHAT OR BE LIVING WAY
APART OUR- HIS SAN FRANCISCO AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE AN HOUR OR
FIVE TON SO OR- NO ES OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THE NUMBER
AS- DROP THE AND THE US THAT
THE SAYS ELEVEN THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE PEOPLE ARE
YOU FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE SOLD TO
ELIMINATE THE ALL THESE NUMBERS
AT THE ALMOST OF TRUMP THOUSAND
PEOPLE. IS IT THE MORE FUNDING
THE SOLUTION ON THE WALL WHAT
IS DOES THE SOLUTION TO IT AN
INMATE IS ALMOST TWO ZERO ZERO.
I HIT I THINK THAT- SHE MADE AN
EXCELLENT POINT AND THAT THE
FUNDING WHAT'S SAN FRANCISCO
HAS DONE HAS BEEN A NICE MODEL
THAT OTHER COMMUNITY SHOULD
LOOK AT YOU KNOW THEY'VE-
INVESTED THEIR FUNDING AND
SUPPORTING YOUNG PEOPLE. AND
THAT'S RESULTED IN MEASURABLE
GOALS MEASURE MEASURABLE
PROGRESS TOWARDS OVERCOMING
THAT IN SAN BERNADINO COUNTY WE
HAVE MORE HOMELESS THIS YEAR
WEEK EVERY YEAR HELP MORE
EVERY. FUND FOR YOUTH THE TO ME
AS A VERY HE WAS SPECIFICALLY.
HOW CAN WE HELP- IS A HOUSING
JOB TRAINING WILL FAMILY
COUNSELING. I THINK I THINK
HOUSING IS THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY AND THE REASON I THINK
THAT IS BECAUSE WITH OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING THEY CAN'T GET THAT
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A SECURE
PLACE TO LIVE THE THEY CAN'T
FIND A JOB THEY CAN'T GO TO
SCHOOL THEY CAN'T DO ALL THOSE
OTHER THINGS IF THEY DON'T HAVE
A PLACE TO LIVE. SO IT REALLY
IS BACK TO STARTING AT HOUSING.
CAN WE TALK TO PARENTS OF FOR
THEM TO- NOT TO COME OUT UNTIL.
THEY STAND ON THEIR OWN FEET.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT. I KNOW
WHEN I WAS A YOUNGSTER MY
PARENTS WHEN EXCITED ABOUT ME
BEING THERE BECAUSE I WAS KIND
OF DIFFICULT. HOME SO I COMPLY
I HAVE SOME COMPASSION FOR THE
PARENTS THESE KIDS ARE
DIFFICULT SOMETIMES ALSO THEN
THERE'S THE LIKE WHAT'S GOING
TO TALKING ABOUT THERE WERE NO
PARENTS THERE FOR HER AND MANY
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE
WORK WHETHER IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE HUMAN NAY BECAUSE
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDS THING IF I
CAN- BECAUSE I WAS ADOPTED AT
AGE FOUR AND- IT. I IS IDEALLY
WITH MY CASE MY PARENTS CHOSE
TO BE MY PARENT AND THEN BAILED.
AND HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
IT'S THEN KIND OF LEFT TO THE
SYSTEM TO KIND OF FIX THOSE
ISSUES VERSUS HOLDING
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE YOUTH TO
TRYING NAVIGATE AND FIX WHAT
PROBLEM HAD GONE WRONG- AND FOR
THE JOB SITUATION- FOR MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. THERE WAS
NO I MEAN THIS IS THE FIRST
YEAR I CAN REALLY HOLD A JOB
AND I'M TWENTY TWO AND THERE
ARE TIMES WHERE I STILL
STRUGGLE EMOTIONALLY MENTALLY I
MEAN IT TAKES A LOT OF EFFORT I
WENT TO THE YEARS COUNT. TO GET
RIGHT NOW. I'VE EVER FOR THE
YOUTH EVEN BE THINKING ABOUT
HAVE A JOB IN BEING SIX AT IT
AND LIKE YOU HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER WE DON'T KNOW A LOT OF
US DEPENDING ON THE TRAUMA WE
DON'T KNOW HOW TO TAKE REJECT
WE THINK IT'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH US. I'VE BEEN TRYING MY
WHOLE LIFE THAT PERRANCE. DOT
THE PARENTS DIDN'T WANT ME
FOUGHT DIDN'T WANT ME IT'S THIS
LONG LINE OF WHAT'S WRONG WITH
ME TO MAKE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
LEAVE. AND NOT HELP ME WITH THE
SERVICES THAT I. SO IT'S-
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS BECAUSE OF
THAT IS NOT STABLE. THEY CAN'T
WORK ON ANYTHING THAT IS GOING
WRONG- ONE- MY MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER AT MY CLINIC NOW HE
HAD TALKED TO ME ABOUT- WHEN I
FINALLY BECAME STABLE I STARTED
REALIZING THAT A LOT OF MY
MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES STARTED
COMING UP AND I WAS. WHY LIKE I
AM STABLE I AM DOING REAL. GOAL
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE FINE.BUT
WHEN YOU BECOME A STABLE YOU
MAY HAVE THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
SPEAKS TO DEAL WITH THESE
THINGS. AND THAT'S WHEN THEY
COMING UP AND COMING OUT. NEW
STAR. IN THERE THE- TO STOP. IF
YOU WOULD THANK YOU FOR SHARING.
THIS KADI YOU HAVE MAY. SO YOU
MY IN. THE YOU KNOW CHOI THINK
THAT YOUR CA AS OFTEN TO WE
WANT TO FIND THE SOLUTION. YOU
KNOW TELL ME THE MOST IMPORTANT
DON'T TELL ME THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE THAT CAUSES ARE YOU
HOMELESSNESS AND IT WOULD E
WONDERFUL IF WE COULD IDENTIFY
WITH. BECAUSE THEN WE COULD ALL
COME AROUND JUST THAT ONE ISSUE
TAKE CARE OF IT AND THE WE
RESOLVE THE ISSUE. AND I THINK-
YOUR YOUR RESPONSES AND I THINK
THE BACKGROUND PAPER THAT WAS
PROVIDED. MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
THIS IS NOT A ONE ISSUE.
PROBLEM WHICH MAKES IT MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT A ONE
SOLUTION SOLUTION- SO I AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
MS REAGAN ABOUT HOW IT'S THE
MONEY. I GOT TO TELL YOU THAT I
THINK IN ADDITION TO THE MONEY
IT'S ALSO HAVING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. IN THE PETITIONS THAT
URINE- TO BE DEDICATED TO THIS
I IN SAN BERNADINO I KNOW THAT
REFORM P. HAVING STEVIE THAT
THERE'S- IT. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS N OUR
COMMUNITY. TO KNOW THAT IN SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY JUST TEN YEARS
AGO WE HAD NO PLACE FOR OUR
YOUTH TO GO AND WE KNOW THAT A
FOR YOUTH ARE HOMELESS YOU ARE
TOLD WELL THE ONLY THING OF.
ALL TO YOU IS THAT BAD NEXT TO
THAT ADULT. THAT'S ONE OF THE
WORST THINGS WE CAN DO TO OUR
YOUTH AND YET THAT'S ALL WE
COULD OFFER TO OUR YOUTH FOR
YEARS. IT'S IT IS UNTIL FAMILY
SERVICES COMES ALONG AND WHAT
REGARD HERE FROM ANOTHER ONE OF
THE SUCCESS STORIES OF. THAT
MYSTERY MEN TOWARD BUT IT'S
HAPPENING THIS COMMIT. TO I'M
GOING MY LIFE BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE DONETHE
TWO OF YOU AND OTHERS THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU HAVE DEDICATED
YOUR LIFE TO STAYING THIS IS A
PROBLEM AND I'M NOT GOING TO
LET IT CONTINUE. CODY YOUR YOUR
YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR STRENGTH
YOUR COURAGE TO COME ERE JUST
AS ARE MY CO CHAIR- CHU WAS
THE- WAS SAYING. THAT IT TAKES
COURAGE FOR YOU TO COME HERE
AND WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
LOTS OF EXPERTS BUT IT IS YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT MAKES ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD BECAUSE
WE GET TO HEAR FROM SOMEONE
SUFFERED THROUGH THIS. SOMEONE
WHO IS TELLING US MY PARENTS
REJECTED ME THEM THAT MUCH MY
ADOPTIVE PARENTS REJECT
REJECTED ME THEN THE NEXT
FOSTER PEOPLE JUST REJECTED ME.
THINKING THAT THIS IS ALL YOU
WHEN IT ISN'T ALL YOU BECAUSE
THE TRUTH IS WE AS A SOCIETY
HAVE FAILED YOU. AND WE FAILED
SO MANY MORE OF OUR YOUTH. AND
THAT'S WHY HAVING THIS HEARING
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
CAN'T CONTINUE JUST SAYING OKAY
IT'S A PROBLEM BETTER RESULT IS
A PROBLEM WITH BETTER RESOLVE
IT. IT'S SAYING HOW DO WE SEE
ALL THE- STE IMPORTANT. ARE IN
IN THE DOCUMENT THAT YOU WILL
RECEIVE IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T TAKE CARE OF
OUR HOMELESS YOUTH. THEN NO WE
HAVE CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS AFTER
THAT AND THEN WE TALKED ABOUT
GENERATIONAL. LIST SO HAVE TO
THE CHAIN SOME POINT. YOUR
STRENGTH CODY IN SAYING THIS IS
FOR THE CHECK WAS BROKEN. IT'S
NOT GOING TO CONTINUE WITH THE
REST OF MY FAMILY AND HIS
EXTENDED FAMILY AS ÞL
THOSE KIDS THAT WERE FOSTER
CARE WITH. LOS IT IS THE
CHILDREN CHEST WILL HAVE TO
HAVE IT IS YOUR YOUR YOUR MY
PARENTS ARE BIOLOGICAL SAID
IT'S ALL OF US BUT IT ISN'T
JUST YOUR PROBLEM IT IS OUR
PROBLEM AND I THANK YOU FOR
BEING COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO COME
AND TO SHARE YOUR EXPERIENCE
WAS SO THAT WE ALL CAN THEN
BECOME BETTER POLICY MAKERS TO
REALLY STUDY THE ISSUE. I THE I
ALSO WANT TO SAY- GERALD THAT
THE HAVING YOU HERE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY AND THAT'S
THE COUNTY I REPRESENT BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF YOUR COMMITMENT.
HONESTLY I WOULD I WAS INVITED
TO COME AND SPEAK TO THE FOSTER
YOUTH ARE THERE IN THE
COMMUNITY. HEARING FROM THEM
ABOUT WHAT THE ISSUES WERE
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
WORLD. ALL THE DIFFERENCE AND
YOU ALLOWED SPACE FOR THEM TO
SIT. ALL MAKE. MAKES A
DIFFERENCE. IN THE- AND- ONE
PHRASE THAT YOU USED WAS
SCATTERED SITES MS REAGAN WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN. BETTER HOUSING
SITES SO ROOMS AND ROOMS IN AND
HALF THE HOUSES- APARTMENT
BUILDINGS ARE S. AROSE ANYWHERE
WE CAN GET HIM ALL RIGHT. IT
DIDN'T YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT I
THINK THIS IS A RECURRING THEME
WE NEED TO GET HOUSING AND THEN
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE CASE
MANAGEMENT- THAT AMONG SOME OF
THE OTHER- THINGS THAT YOU DO
YOU ALL HAVE TALKED ABOUT. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT I WANT TO.
TALK TO CHOI. I WONDER ONE CASE
MANAGER. VERY EFFECTIVELY HOW
MANY CHILDREN CAN THEY TAKE A
ONE ON ONE ONE IN THREE ONE IN
FIVE WELL WHAT WHAT WAS THE
IDEA I JUST LOVE DOCTOR CHOICE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT WHAT YOU
WANT IS YOU WANT. TO THE ANSWER
SO THAT YOU DON'T ITS WONDER
THREE RIGHT EVERY CASE MY GETS
ON THREE CASES. WE HAVE A- TEND.
OKAY MANAGE BUT THAT THE
WELCOME SO IF YOU A YOUTH THAT
YOU'RE DOING CASE MANAGEMENT
AND THEY'VE BEEN IN YOUR
PROGRAM FOR A MONTH YOU ARE A
FEW WEEKS THAT TAKES A LOT OF
ENERGY WORKING WITH THAT YOUNG
PERSON SOME OF HIS PROGRAM FOR
FIVE OR SIX MONTHS OR EVEN A
YEAR AT SOMEONE THEY PROBABLY
ONLY TALK ONCE OF HIS MORE
TEXTING. WITH EACH OTHER SURE
THEY'RE STILL LIVE IN OR DO YOU
THINK YOU HAVE UP TO ONE RATIO
COUNSEL MISTER THE- RIGHT.
THANK YOU OF YOUR PRESENT. ALL
RIGHT WE'D LIKE PULL UP THE
LAST PANEL. ADDRESSING THE
ONGOING NEEDS OF THIS
POPULATION LET'S LOOK TO THE
FUTURE SO AMY LAEMMLE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FAMILY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. MARK MARK COURTNEY OF
THE FROM. WELL WHAT DO YOU KNOW
I GOT THE WRONG PAPER SORRY
IT'S A GOOD THING IT'S A GOOD
THING I HAVE THE SMART PEOPLE
SITTING NEXT TO ME- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES OF YOU FOR YOU OF
MARC COURTNEY FROM THE SAMUEL
DORTCH- THE SAMUEL DEUTSCHE
PROFESSOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CHICAGO. AND FROM MY GREAT
COMMUNITY OF SAMBAR DINO LEVI
DEATH RIDGE OUTREACH
COORDINATOR THE FAMILY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND THE
YOUTH ADVISORY BOARD CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOU AND IF YOU WILL SPEAK IN
THAT ORDER ALSO ARE DEPRECIATED
THANK YOU. OF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS AMY
LAEMMLE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. AND I'M SO
EXCITED THAT THIS JOIN HERE IS
HEARING IS BEING HELD TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO
SPEAK. I'M HERE TODAY TO AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WHAT THE
STATE CAN DO YOU KNOW VERY
FOCUSED ON THOSE SOLUTIONS- TO
SUPPORT EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. ONE POPULATION
THAT HAS CERTAINLY IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND THAT IS
COME UP. IN THE PRIOR TESTIMONY
IS THE ISSUE OF YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN FOSTER CARE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS SO MAKE
KIND OF FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS
FOCUSED ON THAT GROUP OF YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND THEN TURNING MORE
BROADLY TO THE LARGER
POPULATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
MAY OR WHO MAY HAVE NOT BEEN IN
FOSTER CARE. SOME OF
RECOMMENDATION REALLY TO BUILD
ON ONE OF. MOST SIX HOUSING
PROGRAMS FOR TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE. IT'S GOT
ANOTHER TOUGH ACRONYM- BUT IT'S
CALLED THE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
PLACEMENT FOR NON MINOR
DEPENDENCE. SO THIS UP FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT PROVIDES SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. TO OVER
TWO THOUSAND YOUNG PEOPLE
ANNUALLY. THE PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
WHEN CALIFORNIA EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE AT AGE TWENTY ONE. YOUNG
ADULTS IN THIS SPECIFIC FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT TEACH PM D. AS
WE CALL IT REALLY LIKE IT THEY
LIKE THE COMBINATION OF THE
INDEPENDENCE AND SUPPORT OF
SERVICE IT PROVIDES. THE NUMBER
OF YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE SPECIFIC
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PLACEMENT
HAS INCREASED EVERY YEAR SINCE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE WAS
IMPLEMENTED- IT'S THE ONLY
PLACEMENT THAT HAS THAT HAVE
HAD THAT EXPERIENCE AND DESPITE
SLIGHT OVERALL DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF YOUNG. AN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE. I CALIFORNIA'S.
CRISIS THREATENS EACH P. N. M.
D. AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
COUNT ON IT. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE COST OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED 64%
WHILE THE RATE THAT OUR STATE
PAYS FOR THIS SPECIFIC FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENT HAS INCREASED
JUST 23% THIS HAS RESULTED IN
HUNDREDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE ON THE
WAIT LIST FOR TEACH P. AN
EMPTY. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THESE ARE USED CURRENTLY IN
FOSTER CARE WHO ARE ON A WAIT
LIST FOR HOUSING. MANY OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS WHILE
THEY WAIT. EVERY NIGHT THEY
WAIT THERE VULNERABLE
PARTICULARLY CUSTODIAL PARENTS
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO
DISPROPORTIONATELY ACCESS THIS
PROGRAM. ALSO THIS IS TRAGIC
THE AGAIN THESE ARE STATES
CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH THIS IS
THE PROGRAM TO WHICH YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE A- OF AN
ENTITLEMENT AND WHICH THERE'S
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR- SO TO
ADDRESS THIS WE NEED THE STATE
TO TAKE ACTION SPECIFICALLY TO
STRENGTHEN ITS SUSTAIN TEACH P.
AN EMPTY WE NEED TO CREATE WHEN
YOU TRICKS. HOUSING WE AT THE
AS IT IS AND THREE THE
SUPPLEMENT THE CURRENT RATE. OF
THIS SUPPLEMENT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE IN HIGH COST COUNTIES
WHERE THE COST OF HOUSING FEED
HOUSING PORTION OF EAST WHY
TEACH P. N. EMPTY RATE. BY TO
CALIFORNIA WOULD PROVE YOUTH
FROM JOINING THE RANKS OF THE
HOMELESS AND INSTEAD OFFER A
PATH HIGHER EDUCATION AND AFTER
ELITE ALL LET JEAN 83% FEDERAL.
CITY TEACH AN EMPTY TWENTY
MOMENT FURTHER UNDER OR THAT
WAY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE IN FOSTER
CARE IT IS A FEDERAL SHARE OF
COST WE WANT TO MAKE OUR
PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH EXTENDED
CARE AS STRONG- AS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE THIS EIGHT ROLL
PARTNERSHIP THEY WERE USING
ONCE THEY FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE I'M- THE.
THAT IS NO. CURE FOR OFTEN SO
THIS IS. THE RIGHT THING TO DO
FOR YOUTH BUT FROM A POLICY
POINT OF VIEW. IT'S YOU KNOW
UTILIZING SO RE WHY. ALL MY SEC
RECORD IS REFER CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS RESPONSE SYSTEM TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF HOMELESS
YOUTH. THE HOMELESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM WAS CREATED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT AND IS FUNDED
THROUGH THE MCKINNEY VENTO
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE GRANTS. SO
IN CALIFORNIA- THIS FEDERAL
GRANT PROGRAM PROVIDES FORTY
FOUR CONTINUES OF CARE WITH
OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE
SHELTER TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
RAPID RE HOUSING MINUTE SUPPORT
HOW. AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. UNFORTUNATE THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED HOMES RESPONSE
SYSTEM WAS NEVER DESIGNED WITH
HOMELESS YOUTH IN MIND. THERE
ARE NO PERMANENT SOURCES OF
FUNDING FOR HOMELESS YOUTH THAT
ARE DISTRIBUTED THROUGH IT AND
THE LOCAL PROCESS HUD REQUIRES
TO DETERMINE WHO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR HOUSING KNOWN AS
COORDINATED ENTRY PRIORITIZES
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ADULTS AND
INDIVIDUALS. SIGNIFICANT
FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENTS IN FACT
HUD DID NOT EVEN REQUIRED
CONTINUES OF CARE TO COUNT. THE
NUMBER OF UNDER THE HOME TO THE
ANY POINT IN TIME COUNT UNTIL
THE FIFTEEN. NOW I'M NOT SO
THAT TO BE YOU KNOW DOWN ARE
NOT CONTINUE OF CARE OR ON THE
HOMES RISK SYSTEM. IN FACT I'M
A BIG FAN BUT WE DO NEED TO
HAVE THE STATE REFORM THAT
SYSTEM TO ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS
OF HOMELESS YOUTH. WE HAVE AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS OUGHT TO LEVERAGE THE
EXISTING HOMELESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
HOMELESS YOUTH. HUD HAS POURED
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO CREATING THIS SYSTEM AND-
SO RATHER THAN ABANDON IT AND
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH LETS
YOU TO IT BUT LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT HOMES. ARE PART OF IT IN A
WAY THAT THEY NEVER HAPPENED-
BUT CAN BE SO ONE SUCH POLICY
THAT WOULD ACHIEVE THIS. IS A
YOUTH SET ASIDE IN STATE
FUNDING. AND AS YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT FROM OTHER PEOPLE THIS
APPROACH WAS USED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
WITH THE CREATION OF THE
HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID PROGRAM
KNOWN AS HEAT. WHICH AS YOU'VE
HEARD REQUIRED 5% OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AWARDED
TO CONTINUOUS OF CARE AND LARGE
CITIES TO BE SPENT ADDRESSING
YOUTH. BOB KEEP FUNDING HAS
BEEN AWARDED AND IN MAY IT LAST
YEAR AND THEN MORE RECENTLY
YESTERDAY. WE'VE OF- WRITTEN TO
REPORTS ON HOW HE FUNDING WAS
USED FOR- HOMELESS YOUTH. WE
HAVE A VERY GOOD IDEA OF. HOW
THAT FUNDING- HAS BEEN USED.
AND WE FOUND THAT THE HOMELESS
USE THAT ASIDE IS CHANGING
PRACTICE LOCALLY NUMBER OF
WAYS. THE FIRST WAY IS THAT THE
HOME IT USED WITH YOU THAT
ASIDE HAS DIRECTED OVER FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
ADDRESSING HOMELESS YOUTH. YOU
HEARD ABOUT ONE X. IN SAM DO
YOU KNOW COUNTY IN THE REPORT
WE HAVE OVER FIFTEEN DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES ABOUT HOW IT'S BEING
USED. AND IT'S JUST IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS IS THE
LARGEST STATE INVESTMENT IN
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IN HISTORY
CALIFORNIA. UP BACK IN MAY IT
WAS ADJUSTED 10% NOW IT'S UP
211% OF TOTAL HEAT FUNDING
WOULD DOUBLE THE LEGAL MINIMUM
REQUIRED BY LAW. WE WERE
CURIOUS ABOUT THIS FINDING AND
WE ASK THE CONTINUANCE OF CARE
AND LARGE CITIES WHY THEY
INVESTED MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
LEVEL REQUIRED BY STATE LAW ON
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. AND THEIR
RESPONSE WAS TWO FOLD. FIRST
THE LOCAL NEED IS OVERWHELMING
AS YOU'VE HEARD THERE IS NO
SECRET SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH THE TOTAL STATE
INVESTMENT PERMANENT ALLOCATION
FOR YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. IS ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THE
CONTINUES A CARE TOLD AS WE
USED IT BECAUSE THE NEED IS
DESPERATE. AND SECOND THEY USED
IT BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME
THEY ACTUALLY HAD A SOURCE OF
FUNDING. SECOND THE HOME IF YOU
SET ASIDE IMPROVE THE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CONTINUUM
OF CARE AND YOU PROVIDERS. IN
THE PAST CONTINUES OF CARE DID
NOT RECEIVE A SOURCE OF FUNDING
THAT COULD ADDRESS YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. SO ALL OF THE
FUNDING THAT COMES FROM HOT
THAT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION. NONE
OF IT IS YOUTH FUNDING- AND
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A SMALL A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT'S ONLY
AVAILABLE IN THREE
JURISDICTIONS BUT THE CORE
PROGRAM PROGRAMMING FOR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
RAPIDLY HOUSING SHELTER. NONE
OF THAT IS TARGETED TO YOUTH.
AND LIKEWISE THERE WAS REALLY
NO MOTIVATION FOR THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE PROACTIVELY COMMUNICATE
WITH BUTTE PROVIDERS- WITH THE
5% YOU SET ASIDE HOMELESS
PROVIDERS ARE NOW AT THE TABLE
AS WE'VE HEARD IN STATE BERNIE
NO COUNTY AND OTHERS. FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I AM FOR AND
RECEIVING AND INTEGRATING THEIR
SERVICES INTO THE HOME IS
RESPONSE STEM. THIRD THE HOME.
SIDE PROVIDED COMMUNITY THE OP.
TO USE THE FUNDING TO MEET
LOCAL NEEDS. IN SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED A SHELTER
AS YOU HEARD 79% OF HOMES
UNACCOMPANIED YOU THURMOND
SHELTERED MANY COMMUNITIES AND
HE'S CAN SEE FROM THE PORT
REPORT THE MOST COMMON USE WHAT
SHELTER. OTHER COMMUNITIES HAD
SHELTER THEY CHOSE TO USE RIGHT
USE IT FOR RAPID RE HOUSING OR
ANOTHER HOUSING STRATEGY. AND
AS WE KNOW A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH DOESN'T WORK FOR
HOMELESS ADULTS AND IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR HOMELESS YOUTH. BY
MAKING STATE FUNDING AVAILABLE
LOCALLY AND REQUIRED. REQUIRING
IT TO BE SPENT ON YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS COMMUNITIES WERE
ABLE TO INVEST IN THE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS THEY NEEDED AND BUILD
OUT THEIR CONTINUUM OF HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR HOMES YOU. THIS IS
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS CREATE A
PROGRAM IN YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS
WITH IT. INSTEAD THE MONEY DOWN
LOCAL THE TO AN EXISTING SYSTEM
AND THEN ALLOWED LOCALS TO.
COMPLEMENT THEIR CURRENT-
RESOURCES. SO THE SAID IT'S
READY IS ONE A COLLECT OF PAULA
THAT CAN STRENGTHEN IMPROVE OUR
LOCAL HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE
SYSTEM TO ADDRESS YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. OTHERS INCLUDING
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO YOU PROVIDERS TO ACCESS
FUNDING. PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE TO IMPROVE THEIR POINT
OF POINT IN TIME COUNTS FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH. INCORPORATING
YOUTH VOICE IN THE PLANNING AND
DECISION MAKING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND ESTABLISHING
ASSESSMENT AND PRIORITIZATION
PROCESS FEATURES WITH IN LOCAL
COORDINATED THREE SYSTEMS THAT
DO NOT UNINTENTIONALLY SCREEN
OUT YOUTH FROM HOUSING AND
SERVICES. EACH OF THESE
POLICIES TOGETHER WITH THE YOU
SET ASIDE WILL RETOOL LOCAL
HOMES RESPONSE SYSTEMS TO BE
RELEVANT AND EFFECTIVE IN
ADDRESS YOUTH HOMELESSNESS. IT
IS IMPORTANT HOWEVER THAT WE
KEEP THE PROGRESS GOING FORWARD
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND A
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BOTH OF
THE STATE'S MAJOR INVESTMENTS
IN HOMELESSNESS INCLUDED A YOU
SET ASIDE. THE YOU DON'T AND
THE CURRENT PROPOSALS THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS JUNCTURE
DOES NOT INCLUDE A STATE SET
ASIDE. SO WE YOU KNOW WE DO NOT
WANT TO MOVE BACKWARDS WE ARE
KEEPING GETTING TO SEE SOME OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT THE STATE
HAS TAKEN BEAR FRUIT- THEY'RE
NOT PERFECT BUT IT IS ABOVE AND
BEYOND ANY LEVEL. OF THE YOUTH
ALMOST HOMELESSNESS EVER
RECEIVED- SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING TODAY'S
HEARING. AND BY DOING SO YOU'RE
BRINGING YOUTH HOMELESS THAT'S
KIND OF OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND
INTO THE MAIN CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING ABOUT THE CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE ECHO
THAT I'M I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE
HERE- FOR PERSONAL REASONS AND
PROFESSIONAL REASONS- HI BLITZ
IN CHICAGO FOR A LONG TIME BUT
I GREW UP IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AND I WORKED IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM IN THE BAY AREA
BACK IN THE LATE EIGHTIES AS WE
WERE JUST TRYING TO PAY
ATTENTION TO TRANSITION TO
ADULTHOOD FOR FOSTER YOUTH
THAT- WE CELEBRATE EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAYS IT WAS A BITTERSWEET
AFFAIR REALLY I PASSAGE AND
MEETING THEIR CAUGHT AS A
COUNTY WOULD TELL WOULD STOP
FOR THIS PLACEMENT IN YOUR
GROUP. ON A- DAY SO. BUSINESS
LOT OF BACK THEN FOR LAST TO
EIGHT YEAR I BEEN ACTED GAP
AFTER GOING BACK SCHOOL AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONG PEOPLE ASIA
FOSTER'S ONE OF THINGS THAT
I'VESTUDIED- MAIN REASON I'M
HERE THOSE AND I'M ON THE
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR ON
SOMETHING CALLED CAL YOUTH THE
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITIONS TO
ADULTHOOD STUDY WHICH WAS
CALLED FOR BY LEGISLATION THAT
YOU PASSED- BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TEN I BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA FOSTERING
CONNECTIONS ACT A. B. TWELVE
SAID. HE WOULD EVALUATION OF
THIS- SO WE'RE DOING OUR
VALUATION IT'S A PARTNERSHIP
WITH CALIFORNIA CODE CHAU FOR
CONGRESSMAN PARTNERSHIP SO- I'M
GONNA SHARE JUST A FEW NUMBERS
TO START WITH AND THEN MY
IMPRESSIONS OF WHERE WE MIGHT
GO FURTHER WITH EXTENT OF
FOSTER CARE FOR FIVE SHE BUT
ALSO LESS FOR THE BROADER
POPULATION OF HOMES YOU. SO
WE'VE BEEN SEVEN HAD TWENTY
YOUNG WELL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WHEN THERE ARE
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD THEY WERE
ALL IN YOUR SYSTEM
REPRESENTATIVE SAMPLE FROM THE
WHOLE STATE RURAL URBAN CETERA.
WE'VE INTERVIEWED THEM AT
SEVENTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
JUST FINISHED AT TWENTY THREE
WE FOLLOWED OVER 85% OF THEM
FROM BASELINE. ALMOST ALL OF
THE 95% AT SEVENTEEN. SO WHAT
WE FOUND IN TERMS OF
HOMELESSNESS- WE ALSO YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
OF HOMELESSNESS AND
COUCHSURFING EVERY TIME WE TALK
TO THEM SINCE THE BASELINE. 31%
OF THEM REPORT BEING HOMELESS
SOME POINT BETWEEN SEVENTEEN
AND TWENTY ONE. ANOTHER 18% CAP
SEARCH SO THAT'S ABOUT HALF OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. HAS BEEN AT
LEAST ONE NIGHT HOMES OR COUCH
SURFING A DURING THAT FOUR YEAR
PERIOD- ON AVERAGE THEY WERE
HOMELESS FOR ABOUT FOUR MONTHS
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS. BUT
ABOUT A THIRD OF THEM HOMES FOR
LESS THAN A WEEK SO THAT
AVERAGE BE KIND OF MISLEADING
YOU GOT FOLKS ARE HOMES FOR A
LONG TIME. A LOT OF THEM IT'S
FOR SHORT PERIODS OF TIME. WHAT
ARE SOME RISK FACTOR FOR HOME.
AMONG YOU FLEE TO FOSTER. AND
THIS IS GONNA ALL START TO
SOUND VERY FAMILIAR HERE IN
TERMS OF WHAT FOLKS BEEN SAYING
THUS FAR. I GUESS I WOULD START
WITH A HISTORY OF TRAUMA THAT'S
THE BIGGEST RISK FACTOR FOR
HOMELESSNESS IN THIS POPULATION
IT'S A RISK FACTOR FOR HOMELESS
AND ANY. POPULATION OF YOUNG
ADULTS AND YOUTH- WE HAVE DATA
ON LOTS OF THINGS THAT THE
INCREASE THE RISK OF. OF YOUNG
PEOPLE BECOME HOME. PLACEMENT
INSTABILITY WHILE THEY'RE IN
CARE BEHAVE BEHAVE AN EMOTIONAL
PROBLEMS A HISTORY OF RUNNING
AWAY WHILE THEY'RE IN CARE. THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT FAMILY HISTORY OF
CRIMINAL. JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT A FAMILY HISTORY OF
HOMELESSNESS- MALES ARE ALSO
GREAT RISK AND SEXUAL MINORITY
YOUTH ARE BETTER RESPITE. I
WOULD SAY TRAUMA JUST JUMPS OFF
THE PAGE IN TERMS OF THOSE
THINGS- AND IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH BRAIN SCIENCE. DURING THIS
PERIOD OF TIME. YOU HAVE A HARD
TIME- AGING OR MOTIONS. AND
STRESSFUL SITUATION. YOU'LL
HAVE. YOU'RE GONNA GONNA MAKE
TO SAY. THAT ARE PROBLEMATIC
AND- AN INFECTION PLUMMETED
EDUCATION AND HOUSING. CHECK
FACTORS TO THINGS JOHN ABOUT
WHY. ADULT SUPPORT. MULTIPLE
ADULTS NOT. ON THE- YEAH YEAH I
WANT. TO LIVE. GOOD ACTUALLY
THAT'S NOT REALLY TRUE FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE 90% AND WILL
TELL YOU THAT. AN ADULT. I THEY
NEED MORE THAN. ALLOWING ON
PEOPLE REMAINING CARE.
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES THE RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS AND- I WAS ON
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE AND
HOMELESSNESS RESEARCH COUNCIL
FOR NUMBER YEARS EVERYBODY
AROUND WOULD TELL YOU. IF YOU
SUBSIDIZE PEOPLE'S HOUSING TO
PROVIDE THEM HOUSING THEY WILL
BE LESS LIKELY TO BE HOMELESS.
AND ESSENTIALLY THAT IF
EXTENDED CARE DOES NOTHING
ELSE. IT SAYS YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO PROVIDE THE SAN PEOPLE WITH
YOU KNOW THREE HOTS AND A COT
BASICALLY A PLACE TO LIVE IN
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. AND SO
CLEARLY DOES THAT IN MANY CASES
SO WHAT'S IN THAT AFFECTED THAT
I JUST GAVE YOU THE BAD NEWS
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF BECOME
HOMELESS. BUT OUR BEST ESTIMATE
IS THAT EVERY ADDITIONAL YEAR.
MEDICARE SPENDING TIME CARE
REDUCE THE RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
BETWEEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE BY
ABOUT ONE THIRD. THIS IS HALF
THE SHOP PEOPLE SEVENTEEN ARE
IN CARE OF THE TWENTY FIRST
BIRTHDAY. I MEANS OF FOR THOSE
OF YOUNG WILL YOU. RISK OF
ALMOST BY TWO THIRDS. BY BIKES
THAT TOOK CARE. SECOND FOUND IS
THIS RELATES THAT OVER THE
SUPPORT. WE HAVE SHOWN PEOPLE
YOU HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE YOU CAN.
ON FOR TANGIBLE SUPPORT. SOME
RELIABLE MONEY PLACE TO CRASH
GET YOU SOMEWHERE IF YOU NEED
TO GET THERE. THOSE WHO SAID
THEY HAD ENOUGH PEOPLE WERE 44%
LESS LIKELY TO BE HOMELESS IN
THE YOUNG PEOPLE SAID THEY HAD
NO ONE. WERE NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE.
SO WHAT DO I THINK ABOUT
BOLSTERING THE SIX CENTER
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OF THIS
GOING TO SOUND REALLY FAMILIAR
SO. THE FIRST THING I WOULD SAY
IS MAYBE A NEW THING AND THAT
IS YOU FOLKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE WHAT I CALL WHEN I GO OUT
AND TALK WHEN THE COUNTRY ABOUT
MY STUDY. THE MOST INCLUSIVE-
PROGRAM THAT CENTER FOSTER CARE
IN THE COUNTRY. IT'S
ESSENTIALLY A RIGHTS BENEFITS
PROGRAM- AND I THINK THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO HELP.
IN ORDER IS BECAUSE I'M A
PARENT OF TWO YOUNG ADULT THE
DAUGHTERS AND- THEY RELY ON ME
FOR SPORT ALL TIME I GET TEXT
EARLIER TODAY MY TWENTY THREE
YEAR OLD WITH A CONCRETE
QUESTION BY EITHER. GET THROUGH
A PROBLEM. BUT YOU GOT A LOT OF
VARIATION BETWEEN YOUR COUNTIES
IN TERMS OF HOW THAT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND THE RATE AT
WHICH ON PEOPLE REMAINING CARE
TO TWENTY ONE VERY IS QUITE A
BIT BETWEEN COUNTIES IN THE
STATE IN OUR DATA SUGGESTS
THAT'S NOT JUST A FUNCTION OF
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR INCLINATIONS
ARE THE HOUSE MARK EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT. SINCE SOME COUNTIES
ARE BEING MORE INCLUSIVE AND
WELCOMING WITH THEIR EXTENDED
CARE POLICY THAN OTHERS- BY
DIDN'T REALLY SAY MUCH ABOUT
WHY THAT'S THE CASE ON WHAT WAY
THAT WORKS BUT I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD PAY
ATTENTION TO. THE OTHER THING I
WOULD SAY AND THIS IS GONNA
SOUND FAMILIAR. IS WE REALLY
NEED TO RETHINK CASE MANAGEMENT
IN THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM FOR
TRANSITION AGES. THE MODEL A
CASE MANAGEMENT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYS YOU NEED TO
PUT. HAVE AN AGENT OF THE STATE
OR THE COUNTY HERE. PUT THEIR
EYES ON THE CHILDCARE ONCE A
MONTH. THAT'S BASED ON LITTLE
KIDS IN CARE. ALL THOSE LITTLE
KIDS IN HER ALL MINORS IN CARE.
BUT HE'S REVISING THE CARE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THEY CAN RELY
ON IN THE CASE WORKER GONE
VISIT LOOK. TALK TWO THIRDS OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF. CARE AND
SO SEARCHING PIECE. RIGHT A
CASE. WHO SOME WANTS SOME. IS
NOT IN A POSITION TO ENGAGE AND
TRAUMA INFORMED WAY WITH THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE. HELP THEM MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO ACCESS
ALL THESE ADULTS SERVICE
SYSTEMS. YOUNG PEOPLE GO TO-
CHANGE BE PROGRAMS. HOPEFULLY
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE DOING THAT.
BUT A LOT OF THESE FOLKS ARE
INSULTS. AND THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE LEVEL OF
INTERVENTION WE NEED TO
COMMONSENSE SUGGESTS THAT MODEL
CASE MANAGEMENT. IS NOT
ADEQUATE. EVIDENCE ALSO
SUGGESTS THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN EVALUATING TO
PROGRAMS ONCE CALLED LIVE SET.
AND OTHERS CALL THE
MASSACHUSETTS ADOLESCENT OUT
REACH PROGRAM THOSE WERE
INTENSIVE. CASE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. WHY SET THEY TRAIN OF
THOSE WORKERS AND TRAUMA
FOCUSED AB T. MOTIVATIONAL
EVERY AND A VARIETY OF EVIDENCE
BASED INTERVENTIONS THAT WORK
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE. AND THAT
PROGRAM SHOWED A REDUCTION
HOMELESSNESS BETTER MENTAL
HEALTH- MATCHES ADOLESCENCE
BROKE OUT REACH PROGRAM AGAIN
INTENSIVE LOWER CASE LETTERS
ANSWER QUESTION LOWER CASE
LOADS OF THESE AROUND EIGHT TO
TEN. SICK INCREASE COLLAGEN.
PERSISTENCE SO I THINK WE NEED
TO THINK ABOUT THAT AND THEIR
STRUCTURAL ISSUES IN YOUR
TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM I THINK
RIGHT NOW THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR COUNTIES TO DO
THAT EVEN IF THEY WANTED TO DO
IT LASTLY. AT JUST A ON THIS
POINT- IF I'M A CASE WORKER AND
I HAVE A YOUNG PERSON WHO NEEDS
MORE HELP THAT THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH THEY GET FOR SELF MIGHT
GET THEM A PLACE TO STAY AND
THEY'RE GOING TO COLLEGE. BUT I
THINK THEY NEED MORE HELP ALL I
HAVE IS T. H. P. AND MD. I
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER TOOLS
RIGHT. SO I THINK THINKING
ABOUT THAT STRUCTURAL ISSUE- IS
SOMETHING WORTH DOING FOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE I THINK IS IN A
IN A POSITION TO THAT WERE AS
THE COUNTIES ARE NOT. AND THEN
LASTLY I THINK WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF THIS DEVELOPING BETTER
COLLABORATION BETWEEN COUNTY
TROUBLE FOR AGENCIES AND ALL
THESE ADULTS SERVING SYSTEMS.
TO WORK WITH THEIR SYSTEMS AS
PART OF A SOLUTION AND IN AN
ATTEMPT TO GET DOT STRIP
DISMISS TO BE SENSITIVE TO
TRACK. MOST SYSTEM. ARE SET UP
THE TRANSITION EACH YEAR. RIGHT
FITS PARA PROGRAMS. FOR NOT SET
UP FOR. HAVING A KID AND- THEIR
AVERAGE PER IS OLDER NAPA
COUPLE KIDS. MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. IT WAS SERVICE MENTAL
ILLNESS IN THEIR FORTIES OR
FIFTIES. YOUR HER EXAMPLE THAT
I MEAN PUT IN A BAD NEXUS
ADULTHOOD GOT SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
SO WORKING USING YOUR CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY WHO HAS THE
ENTITLEMENT AS AS AMY SAYS. TO
TRY TO GET THOSE SYSTEMS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL WORK TOGETHER I
THINK WOULD BE A REAL
IMPROVEMENT IN SYSTEM. THE FAX.
SEC THANK YOU LEVI DEATH. I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM IT'S ALWAYS
WONDERFUL TO IT TOO TO HEAR YOU
SPEAK ABOUT YOUR LIFE
EXPERIENCE AND DO WHAT YOU HAVE
DONE NOW TO TRANSITION INTO
USING THOSE EXPERIENCES TO NOW
HELP YOU WELL THANK YOU YOU ARE
VERY KIND- I WANT TO START OFF
BY THANKING ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE LEFT
ALREADY FR LEAVING BEFORE I
SPEAK- THAT DEFINITELY MAKES
THIS MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE SO
YOU CAN EXTEND MY THANKS TO
THEM- I'M LEAVE I'D DEATH RATE
WITH THE FAMILY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM I'M ALSO THE YOUTH
ADVISORY. CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CODE IN FOR YOUTH-
LISTENING TO THIS HEARING TODAY
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF ABSTRACTS
AND A LOT OF REALLY FIRM SOLID
IDEAS ALSO ABOUT HOW TO HOW TO
FIGHT HOMELESSNESS AND HOW TO
COMBAT YOUTH HOMELESSNESS XP
SPECIFICALLY I'M AND I LIKE YOU
MISTER CHOI M. A VERY
INTERESTED IN CONCRETE- ANSWERS
AND HOW WE SOLVE THESE THINGS
SO I WILL GET TO SOME- IN MY
HUMBLE OPINION WHICH PROBABLY
AND WITH MUCH BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT- TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHERE I CAME FROM
INITIALLY. I AM FROM SAN MEDINA
COUNTY BORN AND RAISEDON THE
WEST SIDE OF SAME TO DO YOU
KNOW FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T
KNOW SEVENTEEN WAS RECENTLY
NAMED THE MOST DANGEROUS CITY
IN AMERICA NOT EXACTLY A PLACE
THAT- PROMOTES THE DEVELOPMENT
AND POSITIVE GROWTH OF YOUNG
PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY YOUNG MEN
OF COLOR WHICH IS A DEMOGRAPHIC
I FIT ITO- WHEN I BECAME
HOMELESSNESS YOU ASKED A BIT
BRIEFLY EARLIER ABOUT SOME OF
THE CAUSES AND SOME OF THE
REASONS- I CAME HOME IS AT THE
AGE OF FIFTEEN BECAUSE MY
FATHER. WAS A PIECE OF POLICY
TO OFF AND MOTHER WE EASY MY
NEED TO MY NAY BUT THE TIME SO
THE COULD NOT AFFORD AMONG IT'S
ALSO ADDED. NO MA'AM TOLD ME
CENTER. WITH BEFORE TAKING. I
NEED FIGURE SOME THINGS OUT. ON
SO THAT POINT I'D BE HOMELESS.
I WAS HONEST SLEEPING PARK. OR
COUCH SURF YOU KNOW YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE- OR FOR. YOU MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO GET A SYMPATHETIC
PARENT WHO'S WILLING TO LET YOU
CRASH ON THE COUCH FOR A FEW
DAYS BUT EVEN THAT. IS REALLY
ONLY TEMPORARY- AFTER THAT I
ENDED UP- BEING PUT INTO A NOT
PUT INTO PLACING MYSELF INTO
OUR YOUTH SHELTER WHICH IS
CALLED OUR HOUSE WHICH IS RUN.
BY FAMILY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IT'S A RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS
YOUTH SHELTER SPECIFICALLY FOR
AGES ELEVEN TO SEVENTEEN- THE
ONLY ONE OF ITS KIND IN SANFORD
AND YOU KNOW COUNTY. AND THE
REASON WHY SPECIFIED THAT'S THE
ONLY ONE OF ITS KIND IS BECAUSE
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO KNOW
SOMEBODY WHO WORKED AT THIS
FACILITY. HAD I NOT KNOWN THAT
PERSON THERE IS VERY LOW
LIKELIHOOD I WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND THESE RESOURCES OR
EVEN GET MYSELF. INTO THESE
SERVICES ON MY OWN I WAS PRETTY
CONFIDENT AT SIXTEEN- AS I AM
NOW I DON'T SEE MYSELF BEING
CONFIDENT ENOUGH. TO WALK INTO
MY COUNSELOR'S OFFICE AT SCHOOL
AND SAYING HEY I'M HOMELESS I
NEED YOU TO HELP ME I DON'T
IMAGINE THAT FOR MOST YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPECT ESPECIALLY NOT
MYSELF- AT THAT POINT. I WENT
THROUGH OUR HOMES YOU SHELTER
PROGRAM. AND I GOT A I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH. I'VE LOOKED LIKE
THIS SINCE I WAS FIFTEEN I GOT
A JOB IN CONSTRUCTION. AND I
ENDED UP BECOMING NOT RIGHT AT
FIRST WE KNOW CONSTRUCTION TO
BE SOMETIMES BUT I DID BECOME A
TAXPAYER- AND NOW I CONTRIBUTE
BACK TO THE SAME RESOURCES THAT
HELP ME THE REASON WHY I'M
DOING. TODAY IS BECAUSE ALL
THOSE THINGS SAID. I A I'M HERE
AND I FIGHT FOR THE HOME YOU
WERE VERY LIKE ME. BILL LEAVE
MY OF TO BE PARTICULAR I DON'T
WOULD BE PER. BY OR TAKE GIFT
ANYWAY. BUT I WE- HAVE BEEN OP.
MY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO. AND I. BELIEVE
THAT. MAIN PETER AS TO I. FOR
THEN SO MY PEERS BECAUSE DIVING
WHEN I. WHICH ALLOW YOU TO BE
SO. I'M ABOUT THIS. HOME TO
PREVENT THE CARD HOMELESSNESS I
ABSOLUTE HEARING TO BE FAT
GENERAL HOME REAL MY DIED TWO
YEARS AGO OF AS A HOMELESS
DRUNK MY FATHER AWAY ALCOHOLIC
AND BEING YET. MY FATHER FOR TO
DEATH BECAUSE DIDN'T HAVE A
BLANK HE SLIPPED OUTSIDE NOW
WAS ONLY TWO YEARS AGO AND THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT MY PATH SHOULD
HAVE BEEN I HAVE THREE OLDER
SIBLINGS TWO OF WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED MY OTHER
OLDER SIBLING IS CURRENTLY
HOMELESS HEROIN ADDICT IN THE
CITY OF SAN BERNADINO MY
MOTHER- FOR ALL OF HER ATTEMPTS
AT SOBRIETY IS SILL VERY MUCH
SO STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION SO
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT IF THESE
PROGRAMS WORK IF THESE
INTERVENTION MATT. FRUIT TO
THEM THE ANSWER IS AB. YES
BECAUSE IF IT WERE NOT FOR
THESE PROGRAMS I WOULD BE
EXPONENTIALLY MORE LIKELY TO BE
VERY SIMILAR TO THE PEOPLE WHO
I WAS GROWN UP WHO WAS RAISED
AROUND. AND IN ALL HONESTY- IN
MY OWN HUMBLE OPINION BEING
HOMELESS SAVED ME. FROM A LOT
OF THE FAMILY STUFF THAT I WAS
BEING EXPOSED TO AND ALTHOUGH
BEING HOMELESS WAS HOMELESS WAS
DIFFICULT I WAS ABLE TO FIND
SUPPORT THROUGH THAT PROCESS
AND I WAS ABLE TO FIND
RESOURCES. THROUGH AN AGENCY-
IN FAMILY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
WHO IS A RECIPIENT OF THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE HOPING TO
TALK ABOUT HERE TODAY. STE
EXCUSE ME SO AS A REAL TANGIBLE
OUTCOME IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ENDING HOMELESSNESS. AND THAT'S
REALLY OUR GOAL WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT SOME REAL SOLID OUTCOMES
AND- TO GO TO YOUR POINT- IT
SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE TO ANY OF
US THAT CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS IS
AS RAMPANT OF A PROBLEM AS IT
IS. WHEN THERE HAS BEEN FOR
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE TO
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN THERE
WAS NO NEW FUNDING INTRODUCED
TO YOU HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
THERE WAS NO NEW FUNDING GIVEN.
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS OVER THIRTY
YEAR PERIOD SO OVER THIRTY
YEARS PEOPLE WHO ARE TWENTY
THEN BECOME FIFTY. EL ALL YOUR
LOOKING AT A MESSAGE MEDICALLY
WHISPER. WHEN REALLY WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS THE STATE. AS A
WHOLE HAS DECIDED FOR THIRTY
YEARS TO INSTEAD OF PUTTING
MONEY TOWARDS OIL CHANGES AND
TUNE UPS. THE STATE IS DECIDED
TO HOLD THAT MONEY AND HOLD
ONTO IT FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
THEN TRY TO THROW LUMP SUMS OF
CASH AT BUYING A LOT OF NEW
CARS THIRTY YEARS LATER. WHEN
IF WE WOULD HAVE JUST BEEN
USING INCREMENTAL FUNDING TO
PREVENT IT FROM BECOMING SUCH A
MASSIVE ISSUE. IT COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED. NOW THAT PRESENTS
AS WITH THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO REALLY FRAME HOW WE WANT.
THIRTY YEARS LOOK AS LOOK TO
FUTURE AND AS MUCH ENEMY GROW.
WHAT YOU WANT LOOK LIKE. AT I
THINK WE ALL AS FULL OF EITHER
WHAT THE LESS HOW THIS THIRD
YEARS THE REST DAY. AND A TRUE.
THANK TRUE. WAY SEVEN ONE THAT
CAN BE. IN A TRUE WAY TO ENSURE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE AT RISK OR- HOMELESS
ARE A TO RE. SERVE THAT PREVENT
THEM FROM BECOMING BECOMING
YOUR CHRONICALLY. OF BECAUSE
WHEN YOU'RE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ADULT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THE SIDE EFFECTS AND
THEN THE SYMPTOMS OF THAT OUR
COMMUNITY. THEY ARE BAD FOR
PROPERTY VALUES CRIME RATES GO
UP- THERE'S A LOT OF THE
CLEANLINESS ISSUES THESE ARE
ALL THINGS WERE WELL AWARE OF.
SO IF WE REALLY WANT TO SOLVE
THAT INSTEAD OF PICKING AT THE
WEEDS OF CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
OR PICKING AT THE WEEDS OF
MENTAL HEALTH- PICKING AT THE
WEEDS OF VETERANS. SERVICES
THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT BUT THE
REAL ROOT CAUSE OF IT THE REAL
WAY TO GET THOSE WEEDS OUT OF
THE GARDEN. IS TO FOCUS ON
KEEPING MORE PEOPLE FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS IN THE
BEGINNING WHICH IS WHY I
BELIEVE THIS FUNDING IS SO
ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU ALL OF ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS YES MR STONE ARE YOU
SEE MISTER DEATH HER AGE. YOU
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD. BUT
HOW NAIVE BECAUSE WE SPEND
MONEY TO SOLVE A PROBLEM NOW
EVEN THOSE CREATED THIRTY YEARS
AGO AND WE'RE NOTLOOKING
THIRTY YEARS AHEAD THAT'S THE
WAY GOVERNMENT WORKS. THAT'S
YOUR FRUSTRATION AND I SHARE
THAT SO ALL OF THE TALK AND THE
MONEY IN THE PROGRAM THAT THAT
WERE. LOOKING AT NOW VERY
LITTLE OF THAT IS TO PREVENTION
AND IF WE CUT A ROLL THIS BACK
AND- LOOK AT. THE AND
PROFESSORS. TRAUMA YOUR THESE
INDICATORS WE KNOW KIDS COMING
IN THE SYSTEM HAVE TRAUMA WE
KNOW KIDS WHETHER THEY'RE
JUSTICE INVOLVED CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVES ANY OF THESE ARE THE
HOMELESS INVOLVES. COME WITH
TRAUMA AND YET WE SEEM ON
WILLING. TO DEAL WITH THAT AND
SO THESE KIDS ARE CARRYING
THESE CHALLENGES ALL THE WAY
THROUGH SO I APPRECIATE YOUR IT
ANALOGY ABOUT THE- CARD. ADDING
OIL INTO A WEEK BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T IN AND WE TYPICALLY
DON'T. WANT TO ADDRESS- WERE
HAVE BERRY SEE TO TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT YOUTH WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT HOMELESS. BUT
PREVENTING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS
NOW YOUR RATE IS SAVING FUTURE
ADMINISTRATIONS IN FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S THIS EXACT
CONVERSATION ABOUT DEALING WITH
WHATEVER CRISIS THEY HAVE. DOWN
THE LINE. AND PROFESSOR
COURTNEY AS YOU TALK ABOUT THE
A. B. TWELVE OF BERMAN TATIAN
WHICH JUST STRIKES ME IS PRETTY
CLEAR WE HAVEN'T COMPLETELY
FUNDED. ALL OF WHAT THAT
ULTIMATELY NEEDS TO BE. SO
AGAIN IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
REDUCING HOMELESSNESS IN THE
FUTURE AND SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES THAT THESE KIDS GO
THROUGH WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY FUND THAT PROGRAM. NOW
SO THAT KIDS WHO ARE AGING OUT
OR I THINK ANYONE WHO WOULD
TOUCH THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
AT SOME POINT IN THEIR YOUNG
LIFE BECAUSE THEY STILL COME
WITH THOSE SAME DRAMAS AND THEY
STILL COME WITH THE SAME
CHALLENGES NEEDS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THESE PROGRAMS WHICH SHOULD
ALSO IN MY VIEW. GO UNTIL
TWENTY FIVE NOT JUST TWENTY ONE
WHICH IS MORE MONEY BUT WHAT
HAD COULD INVESTMENT THAT WOULD
BE. IN STRENGTHENING OUR KIDS
SO WE TEND TO STEP TO THINK
ABOUT HOMELESS YOUTH OR CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVED YOU THROUGH
OUR PROBATION YOUTH AS IF THERE
AND WE TREAT THEM DIFFERENTLY
AS IF THEY'RE DIFFERENT KITS
BUT BUT THEY'RE NOT. THEY COME
FROM THE SAME PROMISE THE SAME
FAMILY ISSUES AND HOW DO WE
SOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR CHILD
WITHOUT. ADDRESSING THE FAMILY.
IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT THEM BACK
INTO THAT FAMILY IF WE'RE IF WE
HAVE ANY NOTION OF IT. SO
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN INTERESTING
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION TODAY
IS I THINK IT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AND THE
ISSUES THAT THAT WE REALLY
HAVEN'T OPENLY ADDRESS. BUT
WHAT WOULD A BETTER SYSTEM LOOK
LIKE A ME WHAT ARE THE THINGS
WE NEED TO DO AND EVEN SOME OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE KIND OF
PIECING SOME THINGS TOGETHER
SHOULD WE HAVE AN AGENCY OR-
THE ABILITY TO LOOK. AT KIDS.
WHATEVER THEIR CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND PROVIDE SIMILAR LEVELS OF
SERVICES ANY MISS DEATH OR YOU
TALK ABOUT SO HOMELESS YOUTH SO
IT IN SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
DEAL WITH. HOW MUCH USE IN AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THERE ARE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR SOME
BUT NOT FOR OTHERS. AND YET
THEY'RE ALL IN THE SAME.
SITUATION SHOULD BE IN THE SAME
PROGRAMS. WOULD WE BETTER BE
BETTER OFF HAVING A COMMON SET
OF SERVICES. FOR KIDS
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY ENTER
THAT SYSTEM. BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THEM HOW THEY COME. AND NOT
THINK OF THEM AS JUSTICE
INVOLVED NOT THINK OF THEM AS
DEPENDENCY COULD NOT THINK OF
THEM AS HOMELESS. YOUTH THESE
ARE ALL. KIDS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING. AND WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO HELP THEM IT
ISN'T THAT ULTIMATELY THE STEP
WE NEED TO BE TAKING. I THINK
SO I THINK I THINK SO ACTUALLY
I HATE TO COVER THE LOOK THE
LANGUAGE BUT WE I WAS ON
NATIONAL ACADEMIES PANEL AROUND
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
YOUNG ADULTS AND THEN I WAS
KINDA. SERGEANTS AFTER THE
SYSTEM INVOLVED. AND I GOT THE
GROUP THEIR TALK WITH THE YOUNG
PEOPLES' MARGINALIZED IT WASN'T
LIKE RISK VULNERABLE IT'S LIKE
HEY THEY'VE BEEN MARGINALIZED
LAST BRING THE MEN. AND I THINK
IF YOU DO THAT. YOU KNOW THE
DETAILS OF THAT I THINK WILL
PROBABLY BE ON THIS
CONVERSATION BUT IF YOU IF YOU.
YOU KNOW THINK IT THAT WAY
ABOUT THEN. THESE JOSH I THINK
OR ENCOURAGE IF NOT FORCED TO.
WORK TOGETHER BETTER THAN THEY
DO RIGHT BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT
OF GATE KEEPING HERE THAT GOES
ON WHEN YOU HAVE. ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA AND YOU'RE STRUGGLING
WITH NO RESOURCES IT'S JUST
RATIONAL BEHAVIOR FOR PEOPLE
SAY WELL THAT'S NOT OUR PRO
THAT'S NOT. HE'S NOT ONE OF US
IN OUR SHE'S NOT ONE OF US. SO
I THINK PHILOSOPHICALLY TO GO
IN THAT DIRECTION IS ABSOLUTELY
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO AND THEN
YOU FIGURE OUT. HOW TO USE YOUR
YOUR YOUR PROBATION SISTER
TROUBLE FOR SYSTEM THE RUNAWAY
HOMELESS YOUTH ACT MONEY YOUR
FAMILY ASSISTANCE RESOURCES. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE WAY.
IT'S SET UP RIGHT NOW SO THAT'S
NO ARE FROM IT. BUT WOULD THAT
BE MORE EFFICIENT. WELL I
TESTED TALK TO HIS POINT AS SO
WITH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUTH
VOICE IN AND PRACTICES TO
IMPROVE THIS GOING FORWARD. I
AM THE CHAIR OF OUR YOUTH
ADVISORY BOARD DOWN THEM AND
YOU KNOW COUNTY. AND THEIR
MEMBERS OF MY YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD TO EVER BE HOMELESS.
REMEMBER WE HOPE. THERE ARE
PEOPLE. GO TO CALL. IN THEIR-
WORK ON JOB SITES CONSTRUCTION
SO. I THINK WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ONE SET OF REESE. FOR ALL
YOU WHETHER THEY BE SYSTEM
INVOLVED A REGARD I UNDER. THE
BEHIND THAT BECAUSE- LOOK I'M
NOT GONNA TELL SOMEBODY THEY
CAN'T HAVE A GOOD IDEA ABOUT
YOU HOMELESSNESS JUST BECAUSE
THEY WERE HOMELESS THAT WOULD
BE NOT THAT WOULD BE. NAIVE OF
ME. BUT I THINK THAT- AS FAR AS
MOVING THIS FORWARD WAYS TO
IMPROVE IT I THINK HAVING YOUTH
VOICE IN GENERAL IS ESSENTIAL.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A PIECE
THAT IS OFTEN- WHETHER IT BE
UTILIZED I THINK IT'S UNDER
UTILIZED THERE ARE A LOT. AND I
WON'T NAME NAMES BUT THERE ARE
A LOT OF NON PROFITS AND A LOT
OF. AGENCIES IN GENERAL THAT
HAVE A YOUTH VOICE AND IT'S ONE
YOUTH PERSON. WHO NEVER REALLY
GETS ANY SUPPORT FROM THAT H.
T. BUT THEY SAY THEY HAVE A
YOUTH VOICE AND THAT IS COMMON
PRACTICE. AND I THINK INTEL WE
START- CHANGING SOME SOME
GUIDELINES AND SOME DIALOGUE
ABOUT WHAT IT YOUTH VOICE. AND
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING WE
REALLY SHOULD DISCUSS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO BECAUSE- IF
AND HOPELESSNESS IS OUR GOAL
WILL BE HERE UNTIL I DIE. AND
THE LONG TIME AWAY SO I THINK
WE NEED TO START DOING IS
ALLEGING THAT THESE. WHILE IT
IS AN OVER ARCHING ISSUE
THERE'S A LOT OF. MISSIONS
UMBRELLA OF BUSINESS. YOU WANT
TO OUR TARGET. THAT'S REALLY
AFFECT A VILLA AT THE END THE
ROAD. MORE THAN IF YOU DAM IT
UP THREE VILLAGES AHEAD OF
THAT. YOU NEVER HAVE THE FLOOD
DOWN THERE SO I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE REALLY SHOULD THAT'S
THE MAIN GOAL OF THIS IS. YOU
YOU HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL IS
AN ISSUE BUT- IF YOU REALLY IF
WE REALLY AGREE AND WE'RE
HONEST THAT WE WANNA FIGHT
AGAINST. HOMELESSNESS
CONTINUING TO GROW BECAUSE IT
IS GROWING. AND LIKE THE 3%
DECREASE. OF HOMELESS YOUTH
THIS IS A NUMBER THAT I HEAR A
LOT. AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
GUYS KNOW THIS OR NOT. BUT THE
PEOPLE PUT MINISTER THAT COUNT
IN A LOT OF AREAS HAVE HEAVY.
IT HAS EVERY INCENTIVE. KEEP
THAT NUMBER LOW. ESPECIALLY IF
YOU DON'T WANT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO THINK THAT YOU
OF ABOUT HOMELESS YOUNG PEOPLE
RUNNING AROUND YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD. SO I WOULD BE
COST ABOUT THOSE NUMBERS NO THE
BEST. WE PUT ON END THAT A LET.
BECAUSE I'M OF A MUCH LARGER
AMALGAMATION OF AN ISSUE. THAT
WE WILL NEVER GET A TRUE NUMBER
ON. IT AND I AM SORRY IF WERE.
PATTING OURSELVES ON THE BACK
FOR A 3% REDUCTION IN HOMELESS.
WHEATLEY MISSING. THE POINT
YES. AND THERE IS A PROPOSAL
FOR A YOUTH COUNCIL. WHICH I
THINK WOULD BE FABULOUS YES I-
THREE OF US IT'S A YEAH AND
THIS IS TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
GETTING KIDS VOICES WHEN WE-
LOOKED AT IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
TRYING TO DEAL WITH SOME
CHALLENGES WE ARE HAPPY. TO
OFFER. THEM WE DO THE SAME
THING WHICH- SOME FOR FOSTER.
WITH AND IT WAS. CLEAR AND-
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE SAME LEVEL THEY THEY
WERE INTIMATE IF. THEY WEREN'T
SURE HOW THEY FELT THERE IT'S
NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO GET THEIR
VOICE. WE LET THEM CREATE THE
VENUE WE LET THEM AND THEN WE
HAD TREMENDOUS ABOUT OF.
APPROPRIATE INPUT. INTO
DECISIONS THAT WE'RE MAKING AND
SO IT'S LESS ABOUT ADULTS BEING
VERY PATERNAL TELLING WE KNOW
WHAT'S GOOD FOR YOU. WHEN WE
DON'T IT'S LEADING. THE YOU
HAVE A VOICE. IN THAT AND I
THINK THE YOUTH THE YOUTH THAT
I'VE DEALT WITH WHETHER.
HOMELESS OR JUSTICE INVOLVED OR
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVES OR ANY
OF THAT. THEY DON'T LOOK AT
EACH OTHER IN THOSE CATEGORIES
WE CREATE THOSE CATEGORIES AND
I THINK WE MISSED THE POINT. BY
DOING THAT AND WE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY SERVE.
YOUTH IN A IN A COMPREHENSIVE
WAY SO I'M HOPING WE CAN. DO
SOME KIND OF A SEA CHANGE. WHAT
THE ONE PET PHRASE I'VE HEARD
HOUSTON IT RESONATES WITH ME IS
THE HIGH STAKES ELIGIBILITY. SO
LIKE IN FOSTER CARE IF YOU ARE
REUNITED YOU KNOW BEFORE AGE
SIXTEEN OR IF YOU ARE EXITS
PERMANENCE BEFORE AGE EIGHTEEN
OR IF YOU ARE UNIFIED BEFORE
EACH THIRTEEN THERE'S THESE
MOMENTS THAT PUT YOU DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES- BUT TO YOUR POINT
TO THEY HAVE. THE TUBE TO
CHANGE TO GET RID OF TYSON
SOLDIER BUT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW-
THAT ELIGIBILITY IS WHAT DRIVES
ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES
VERSUS RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE AND MINIMIZE
THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THE YOUNG
PERSON. STE VERSES AND I KNOW
FOR PRACTICE. IN THAT'S HI BUT
IT'S GOTTEN TO AN EXTENT NOW WE
WORK LAST YEAR ON A BILL FOR
YOU TO TEACH PEOPLE US A
HOUSING PROGRAM FOR FORMER
FOSTER IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE IF
YOU'RE IN CARE ON YOUR
EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY WE TRIED TO
GET DOWN BEST TO SIT TEAM TO
SAY YOU KNOW IF YOU WERE IN
CARE WHEN YOU'RE SIXTEEN YOU
HAVE A LOT OF RISK THERE'S NO
REASON WHY YOU SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THIS PROGRAM. AND IT
WAS JUST. IT WAS. IT WAS NOT
POSSIBLE LET'S JUST THAT
BECAUSE PEOPLE FEEL LIKE WERE.
CRACKING OPEN THE DOOR AND TRY
TO PUSH PEOPLE THROUGH- AND SO
I JUST WANT A WHOLE HEARTEDLY
ENDORSED THE- MOVING AWAY FROM
THIS VERY HIGH STAKES
ELIGIBILITY ORIENTATION. WE ARE
VERY FAR AWAY FROM THAT BECAUSE
ESSENTIALLY THAT IS A WAY OF
RATIONING. OF SCARCE RESOURCES
IT IT. YEAH BUT TO MISTER DEATH
RIDGES POINT EARLIER LOOK AT
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE PUT IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WHAT WE'RE
TALK ABOUT NEXT YEAR WE PUT IN
LAST YEAR BUDGET. FOR
HOMELESSNESS YEAH. WE COULD BE
INVESTING THAT NOW IN YOUTH
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS A SMALL PART OF ALL OF
THIS GRAND OTHERWISE INVESTMENT
IT'S NOT THAT EXPENSIVE SCHEME
OF THINGS BUT IT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO TALK
ABOUT ITS ONGOING MONEY. HOW
BETTER COULD WE INVEST IN OUR
FUTURE SYSTEMS IN EVEN IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS. BEEN BEEN
DEALING WITH THE SITUATIONS CAN
FIND THEMSELVES IN AND HELPING
THEM OUT THERE SO THEY DON'T
BECOME PERMANENTLY HOMELESS OF
THE DON'T BECOME. SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY BE PARTICIPATE IN
OUR SYSTEMS RATHER THAN BE
SHUNTED ASIDE AS THEY- AS THEY
OFTEN ARE SO I DON'T. BY THAT I
THINK THAT'S- FOOLISH AND WE
END UP AND THROWING A LOT OF
GOOD MONEY. CHASING SOLUTION OR
DIFFICULT JUST TO GO THROUGH
THE MOTIONS WHEN WE HAVE I
THINK HONESTLY A WAY OF DEALING
WITH. WITH YOUTH NOW IN A MUCH
MORE PRODUCTIVE WAY AND THAT'S
AND INVESTMENT WE COULD BE
MAKING A LONG TERM IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND REDUCE ME THINK
ABOUT REDUCING THE JUSTICE
COSTS AND REDUCING THE TAP
WATER GLASS AND PUTTING THOSE
SYSTEMS OUT OF BUSINESS WHICH
WE WON'T FOR LOTS OF REASONS
BUT SEVERELY MINIMIZING WE
MINIMIZE THE LONG TERM
OBLIGATIONS OF THE SYSTEMS BY
THOSE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS BUT
WE GET THERE WILL BY UPS
BIGELOW THESE WERE THAT. WE
DON'T THAT WAY YOU THROW A LOT
OF MONEY PROBLEM THAT'S FOR US
BECAUSE IT'S POLITICALLY X. BUT
UNWILLING TO LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES WERE LOOK TEN
YEARS DOWN THE LINE TO SAY
WHERE ARE WE GOING TO BE. YEAH
WE GOT IT IS A MUCH MORE
RATIONAL IF YOU GIVE US IF YOU
GET YOUNG PEOPLE AND I SAYS I'M
ON ONE OF THEM TWENTY TWO SO I
STILL COUNT FOR COUPLE YEARS
AND HOLD ON TO THAT- BUT- IF
YOU GET. SOME PEOPLE IN.
DOLLARS YEAR FOR NEXT TEN YEARS
I GUARANTEE YOU THE OUTCOMES
WILL BE FAR GREATER THAN IF YOU
TRY TO THROW TEN MILLION
DOLLARS A CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
IN TEN YEARS. I CAN GUARANTEE
THAT. WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO ME AND WE'RE
TALKING BILLIONS ABSTAINED OUT
TOWARDS HOMELESSNESS ABSCESS SO
TAKE A PIECE OF THAT YEAH. NO I
AGREE BUT- GETTING THERE.
THAT'S WHAT THE THAT'S WHAT WE
LOOK PEOPLE LIKE YOU FOR ISN'T
IT I HAVE. I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE. QUESTIONS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS THIRTY CHOI I JUST ON
OF YOU THINK WE SAVE IN A TEST
SO TO THE LAST SO WORRIED THAT
THOSE MEN HAVE TO LEAVE A AS OF
SO. AND THEN MAY I TAKE IT THAT
AND THEN I A TO REALIZE THAT
THIS OF POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS SET ASIDE FOR HOMELESS
PEOPLE HOW MUCH PORTION IS A
SET FOR YOU IF THE WHAT I HEARD
WAS KNOWN A DEFINITE MONEY.
SPEND SET UP AND THEN ALSO.
DEPUTIESFOR HOMELESS WILSON-
MIST ELLIE- SUTTON TALKED ABOUT
A SO WE DO WE DEPARTMENT
SECRETARY AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY. COOL SO WHO ARE
DEALING WITH THIS- HOMELESS-
NECESSARY- ISSUE AND- IF THE SO
YOUTH THE ISSUE IS SO A VERY
IMPORTANT AND THE WE NEED TO
STOP FROM THAT PORTION CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF MONEY SHOULD BE YET
DECIMATED THE AND THE FOCUSED
UPON AND THUS MY SUGGESTION TO
A- SECRETARY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WITH THAT CONCLUDES WITH THE
LAST OF THE PANEL I THANK YOU
SO MUCH THE I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SET AT
ALL BUT I DO WANT TO THANK YOU-
I THINK THAT THAT THE INSIGHT
PROVIDED. FROM FROM WORKING
WITH THE YOUTH FROM STUDYING
AND GIVING REPORTS OR FROM
BEING THAT USE THAT THAT SHARES
EXPERIENCE JUSTICE CODY DID
EARLIER. THE ONE THING THAT
YOU'RE DOING. IN ADDITION TO
THAT IS IT THAT YOU'RE USING
THAT EXPERIENCE TO HELP THE
YOUTH THAT ARE EXPERIENCING THE
VERY SAME THING. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU YOU. IT NOW WHAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THREE MINUTES TO. I
WILL ELSE THE TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES SO THAT
WE KNOW IF IT TURNS OUT THAT WE
HAVE A HUNDRED PEOPLE WAITING
THAT I'M LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE
BUT LET'S TO- I. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WERE REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS JOINT HEARING WE WOULD
REALLY URGE OTHER COMMITTEES TO
ALSO COURTED ME IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE LOOKED INTERNALLY AT S.
YEAH YOU AND ARE DOING AS WELL
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE HOMELESSNESS
IS AN ISSUE THAT CROSSES OVER
SO MANY DIFFERENT COMMITTEES SO
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUE AREAS-
WITHIN EDUCATION B. L. HEALTH.
MENTAL HEALTH REGULAR
DISTRIBUTIONAL HELP OUR
COUNTY'S WERE SEEING A NEED TO
ADDRESS AS AS WELL AS HOUSING
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING THIS
TODAY A WE JUST WANT TO
REITERATE ONE OF OUR PLATFORMS
ARE WE TO LOOK AT THIS AS A
HOLISTIC AND PERSON APPROACH WE
WILL THAT UP THIS CASE IS. I IN
NIGHT SOLUTION. THANK LEAVING
LUCIEN IN AND IT'S IN A TIME
HERE BUT IT'S INVEST IT ACCESS
IT'S- WHEN WE LOOK AT ISSUES
WERE WE WE'VE SEEN SIX WAY IS
TO FAMILIES IN YOUTH WE LOOK AT
CRISIS SINCE NOW MY ONE IS THE
FIVE IS WITH AT NORTH FOR AND
THERE WAS THE EARTH AND WHAT WE
DID WAS WE OUT AND WORK. WE PUT
LEGIBLE IS COUNTY SERVICE OUT
THERE PEOPLE AT TIM SURE THEY
WERE GETTING THIS AS AND SO
WE'RE ASK TO DO SOME TO IN IN
YOUR COUNTIES THAT CAN PUT
PEOPLE AT COURTS THE COMPLETE
AT LIBRARIES AND PUT THEM IN-
THROUGH COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
WHATEVER PROPOSALS ARE OUT WE
THINK BY OUT USUALLY WORKERS BY
INVESTING IN. SERVICE SAYS YOUR
GOING TO THE ON YOUR LOCAL FOR
THE WORK LIES NOT JUST THE IS
THE TRANSIT YOUTH BUT MANLEY'S
WERE THEY GET MY CAL GET
CALTRANS OF THE ENROLLED IN SD
WE LOOK AT A LOT OF. THE PEOPLE
JOHN IT'S AN AND I SHELTERS
WERE SEEN THEM OF THEM NOT A IN
THE SERVICE EVEN THOUGH QUALIFY
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW CAN
WE AND AT ACT ONLY AND WE
LEAGUE NEEDS WERE ON YOU TO
HELL US WITH THE BY INVESTING
SO WE URGE CONSIDER OF A
HOLISTIC WHOLE PERSON APPROACH
WE WERE PRETTY WELL BE LETTER
ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS WE CAN
INVEST OUR RESOURCE TO REALLY
EXT. WE DO WANT BY LATE THAT
THERE IS A NATION WE GOT TO ST
IN SERVICE SAYS SO THAT WE CAN
ENROLL PEOPLE AND GIVE THEM A
MEDIA ACCESS IN A MULTITUDE OF
DIFFERENT SERVICES WE'RE
LOOKING AT A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
APPROACH BUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
THAT PASSED AS AN INVESTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE SCA USE COMMITMENT-
AND JUST AS YOUR NAME SAYS IT'S
THE SERVICE A PART OF SOMETHING
YOU TAKE CARE OF VERY WELL
THANK YOU. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MATT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING THIS.
HEARING LAURIE CHAMAR ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATED STUDENTS UCLA-
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT ONE
IN TEN. YOU SEE STUDENTS GO TO
BED. WITHOUT HAVING A HOME AND
ARE HUNGRY- AND SO THIS IS A
BIG ISSUE FOR THEM AND WE WILL
BE FOLLOWING EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS ASIAN NEED DUNLAP IA
CURRENTLY A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. I'M A JUNIOR.
WE ONE YEARS OLD. I ALSO
EXPERIENCE. WAS MIX WHEN I
TURNED EIGHTEEN AFTER LEAVING
MY FOSTER HOME. AND I WAS PUT
ON THE WAIT LIST FOR ABOUT TWO
MONTHS AND- I JUST RENTED A
ROOM FROM A PREVIOUS GUARDIAN
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT BECAUSE
SHE NEEDED ME TO PAY MORE. FOR
THE ROUND. SO THAT SUMMER. WELL
WHEN I WAS HOMELESS I HAD
STRUGGLE THROUGH A LOT AND LIKE
DURING THE TIME I WAS ATTENDING
STOCKS THEY I HAVE FAILED ALL
MY CLASSES THAT SUMMER BECAUSE
OF IT AND MY MENTAL HEALTH WAS
UNSTABLE AND- THE HOUSING COSTS
WERE REALLY HIGH SO IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO. AFFORD ANYTHING I
DON'T HAVE A JOB AT THE TIME
BECAUSE TRYING TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL AND I THOUGHT I HAD
ENOUGH MONEY FOR- THEY CALL IT
TOO. AND IT'S ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED OR A HUNDRED DOLLARS AT
THE TIME WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN I
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO LIVE
SOMEWHERE AND BE ABLE TO. FEED
MYSELF I WASN'T ON FOOD STAMPS
SO AFTER FOSTER CARE I WASN'T
PREPARED TO BE AN ADULT ON BE
ON MY OWN OBVIOUSLY SO. I'M I
REALLY WANT YOU GUYS TO SUPPORT
THE A. B. TWO EIGHT ZERO OF
BILL BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME BECAUSE LIKE AFTER
EXPERIENCING ALL THAT. I FEEL
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE AS
LUCKY AS ME AND A LOT OF PEOPLE.
MAY JUST YOU KNOW GO DOWN THE
CRACKS. AND NOT GO BACK THIS
NOT DO ANYTHING AT ALL MIGHT BE
EXPOSED TO CRIME AND SEX
TRAFFICKING DRUGS AND I ALMOST
FELL THROUGH THOSE CRACKS SO IF
YOU GUYS CAN HELP. AND THEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY SHARING THE IT'LL A
LIFE LIVED EXPERIENCE IT MAKES
A DIFFERENCE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JORDAN SOSA AND I SERVE AS THE
LEGISLATIVE COORDINATOR FOR
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION AND
SEE WHY SEE AND HAVING THE
HONOR TO REPRESENT KERN UPON
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ACROSS THE
STATE OR PASSIONATE TO
TRANSFORM THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
AND PRACTICE CHANGE. AND I
REALLY JUST WANTED TO EMPHASIZE
AND HIGHLIGHT THE MEMBERS WORK
ON TWO YEARS AGO THE STAFF-
DEVELOP THE FOSTER STABILITY
CAMPAIGN AND REALLY HOW DO WE
FOCUS AND MAKING SURE THAT THE
SIXTY THOUSAND YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HAVE
STABILITY IT WAS INITIALLY
FOCUS ON PLACEMENT STABILITY
BUT WE KNOW THE FOUNDATION AND
MAKING SURE THAT TO. A USE
MEANS THEY'VE SO FOLK AND ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE AND HOW AND
WELLNESS AND EDUCATION HAVING A
PLACE TO CALL HOME AND FOCUSING
ON A LIFELONG CONNECTIONS RIGHT
YOU WANT TO SHARE THE
INTERSECTION OF. OF YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
A FOSTER CARE OF A QUOTE OF OUR
CHAPTER MEMBERS HOT FROM LONG
BEACH A REALLY WANT TO SHIP
THIS MESSAGE OF THE IMPORTANCE
ON WHY THE WAY K. ABOUT DO YOU
THINK. HOME LAST CHANGES. TO
THE CARE. THE FOSTER USES WAS
PUT IN PLACE TO THE YOUTH AND
SO THEM AND TIME OF NEED
HOWEVER FOSTER YOUTH QUICKLY
FIVE OUT THAT THE BERRIES PUT
IN PLACE TO HELP IS WHAT SUB
ADDING THESE THE COLTS TO THEIR
LIFE. ARE NOT REAL. CLEAN AIR
LIVE AS THE RESULT. HAVE THIS.
TO HOME THIS PIPELINE. THERE IS
THE CHAIR TO GROW IN SIX AND
THRIVING AND FOR THIS FOR RES
WE SEE WHY SEE IMPLORE YOU TO
OUR FOR STABILITY FOR ALL. AND
AS SERVING A LEGISLATOR CORNY
FOR THE ORGANIZATION WE ARE
RUNNING- A. B. TWO FOUR SIX
NINE TWO HAVING A PLACE TO CALL
HOME FOR EMERGING ADULTS AB
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR TO SUPPORT-
CARE GIVERS ARE GOING TO THE
RESOURCE FAMILY. PROCESS TO
SCHOOL OF WORK FOR A TO HAVE
BURST IN FUNDING FOR YOUTH
TRAVELING TO THEIR SCHOOL TO
HAVE EDUCATIONAL STABILITY- WE
ALL ALSO RUNNING ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE UP LET YOU LIVE
EXPERIENCE IS IN THIS. CAPITAL
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY THE VOICE ON THESE AS WELL
AS S. NINE FIFTY. THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT COULD EXPECT AND
NECK ELIGIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUTH WHO HAVE- WITH- WHO ARE
THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
TO SERVICE IT'S AN ENTITY
COLLEGES. OF WE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR DURING THIS
CONVERSATION WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR SUPPORT ON ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANKS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. AT
JUSTIN GARRETT. STATUS OF
COUNTIES ONE I THINK THE CHAIR-
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT AND
DEDICATION TO THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF YOUTH HOMELESSNESS-
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SEVERAL
OF THE PANELISTS WERE ABLE TO.
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE LOCAL
INVESTMENTS AND- UTILIZATION OF
STATE FUNDING- AS COUNTIES WORK
TO. PARTNER WITH  BROAD
COALITION- TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
REDUCE YOUTH HOMELESSNESS- AND
THEN DEFINITELY ONE TO SEX
COMMENTS HAD BEEN MADE ABOUT
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE- IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT
IS REALLY HELP TO SEE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES FOR OLDER FOSTER YOU.
AND APPRECIATE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND OF THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO HELP SUSTAIN
ENHANCES OUT COULD NOT
CERTAINLY AND WE WITH PORT. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE. THIS
ISSUE THAT. THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ON. INDIA ON BEHALF OF FACT OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CHECK ASSERTS
I'M WANTED THANK YOU HAVE FIRST
AND ALL. FOR THIS HEARING FOCUS
ON THE IMPORTANT ISSUE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BUT WOULD LIKE TO.
ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS. MADE
TODAY AROUND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR- INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- WE
AS WE NOW I SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT. THE LONGER AN INDIVIDUAL-
EXPERIENCES HOMELESSNESS THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO
DEVELOP. I'M AN EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA AND I'M DEVELOP A BEHALF
HEALTH CONDITION AND DIED MORE
DIFFICULT AS TO. ENGAGE WITH
THE INDIVIDUAL- AND PROVIDE
HOUSING- SO. YOU KNOW THE REAL
IMPORTANT THE PREVENTION AND
ARMY PENSION THE CIRCUMSTANCE.
I'M AND THEN THE. DUBBED ARI.
ACOSTA COPY. IMPORTANCE OF IT.
ALL UNITS. AND BASS ON. YOU
KNOW THIS IS LITTLE BIT RE FROM
THIS COUNTRY. BY WE DID SEE
OVER THE LAST DECADE WITH A- BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
REDUCTIONS- VETERANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS BY
ABOUT A HALF IN THE LAST
DECADE. ND MAKING ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND YOU
KNOW HOW THE IN IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- DOES
MAKE. MEASURABLE DIFFERENCE ON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MADAM CHIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HOSTING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING ON YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS MY NAME IS GORDON
BALL TO SKI WITH THE YMCA OF
SAN DIEGO COUNTY YOUTH AND
FAMILY SERVICES WERE ENGAGE
MEMBERS IN. THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND THIS
YEAR WE ARE CELEBRATING OUR
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY. AND THEN
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY THANK YOU- IN
IN FIFTY YEARS WE HAVE- BEEN IN
IN FINANCIAL CRISES AND HAVE
SEEN UNSUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
OUR CORE ISSUE WHICH IS.
WORKING WITH- ON SHELTERED USE
IN DIFFERENT PHASES OF THEIR
CONTINUE AMEND STRUGGLE. I LOVE
THE ALLITERATION OF OUR PEAS
EARLIER TODAY PREVENTION
PROTECTION PARTNERSHIPS
PATHWAYS AND POSSIBILITIES- SAY
IT FAST THREE TIMES RATE. I
SERVICE ORDER WE GET ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA RIGHT.
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN SAN DIEGO-
WE'RE READY FOR THIS
INVESTMENTS BOTH WITH HEAP
FUNDING AND Y. H. T. P. FUNDING
WHICH SAN DIEGO COUNTY HAS
RECEIVED- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
COLLECTIVELY IN THE SAND YOU
USE HOMELESS CONSORTIUM- TO
HAVE A UNITED FRONT TO BE WISE
IN PLAN FULL. ABOUT THIS
SPENDING AND YOU HAVE SEEN-
PHENOMENAL INCREASES WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY OF THE YMCA YOUTH
AND FAMILY SERVICES ALONE HAS
ADDED THIRTEEN STAFF- TO OUR
BODY OF WORK IMPROVING-
SUPPORTS IN THE FIELD AND
STRENGTHENING THE FIELD
OVERALL- ONE OF OUR NEWEST
HIRES WITH HEAT YCP FUNDING-
HIS NAME JOSH'S TOGA AND I WANT
TO. HONOR HIS STORY BY SAYING
HE STARTED IN A T. H. P.
PROGRAM TWO YEARS AGO AND
THROUGH- MINDFULNESS ADDED
WELLNESS. OPPORTUNE THESE- IN
WORKING WITH COACHES IN CASE
MANAGERS LEARNING ABOUT FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY HE'S NOW ONE OF
OUR SUPPORT SPECIALISTS NOW
WORKING WITH OTHER YOUTH. I'M
AND SERVING AS A LEADER AS CODY
AND WE BY OUR- ALSO STE IN ME
AS YOU KNOW FOR NEW YOU COMING
IN OUR PRO WITH A- FUNDING JUST
IN THE FIRST. OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR- THESE ARE EXCITING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT- WE'RE NOT
GONNA SOLVE THIS IN ONE OR
THREE OR FIVE YEARS SO
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING- AND
CONTINUING TO HAVE THAT CARVE
OUT FOR YOU THIS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL FOR WHAT WE DO IN OUR
NEXT FIFTY YEARS OF OPERATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JACK YOU ON THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY FOR THE
AND HELP PARTY IN CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN- TO SOMEONE WERE
STONE'S POINT WE ACTUALLY DO
HAVE A PLAN- THAT ACTUALLY
ADDRESSES POVERTY. IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY OUR
PRIORITY IS TO AND- TELL
POVERTY FOR FOUR TO FIFTY
THOUSAND- CHILDREN IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE IN AND
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS. AND SO I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE MEMBERS I'M
ON THE COMMITTEE WHO ARE
COUNTING THIS ISSUE- BUT JUST
WANTED TO THANK YOU AND
REITERATE SUPPORT FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME- MENTIONED
SO HOLISTIC CARE AND IT'S NOT
JUST ONE THING- THAT WILL HELP.
LIFT FAMILY THE CHILDREN OUT OF
POVERTY IT'S ALL THINGS
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. AND ALL
PEOPLE TOGETHER THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THE
GREAT WORK ON ENDING CHILD
POVERTY ITS- THE- WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS AN ORGANIZATION YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THAT- AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING TO GET. THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE IN DEEP POVERTY. IN TO
POVERTY. AND THAT'S THE GOAL
RIGHT NOW FOR THAT. AS YET IT'S
SUCH A HARD THING FOR MANY
OTHERS TO. TO GRASP THAT BUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT HARD WORK
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND
AGAIN WE DO HAVE A PANT PLAN
OVER. TEN TO TWENTY YEARS- AS
SOMEONE MISSED ON HAPPY TO DROP
AT HIGHER OFFICE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR CAN BE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- STEPHANIE I'VE
LEARNED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE REPRESENT ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY AND
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED NON
PROFIT ORGANIZATION STATE WIDE.
DOZENS OF WHOM PROVIDE THE T.
H. P. AND M. D. PROGRAMS. IF
THERE'S ANYTHING I THINK THAT
WE CONSISTENTLY HEARD THIS
AFTERNOON THE COMMON THEME IS
THE CRITICAL NATURE OF THE
SUPPORT OF SERVICES. THE T. H.
P. AND MD PROGRAMS KNOW HOW TO
DO THIS. THE CHALLENGE IS THAT
WHEN WE SURVEYED ABOUT A
HUNDRED PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS
TOGETHER WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. WE FOUND
THAT A GOOD 46% OF THEM WERE
EITHER REDUCING THE LEVEL OF
THEIR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. OR
THEY WERE NEEDING TO LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF HIGH NEED TO USE THAT
THEY COULD TAKE INTO THE
PROGRAMS. AND SO FOR THAT
REASON WE'RE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WE ARE CO SPONSORING AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY. IN HOPES
THAT WITH TARGETED SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR THE HOUSING
COMPONENT OF THE T. H. P. AND
M. D. RATE. WE CAN ENABLE THESE
PROVIDERS BOTH TO. ENRICH YOUR
MAINTAIN THEIR IN WHICH QUALITY
OF SERVICES SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR THE YEAR. BUT. PERHAPS
CASSIDY WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
A HUNDRED OF YOUTH ON THE
WAITING FOR THESE SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRPERSON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
MAC DONALD'S I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE CHILDREN SAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER REPRESENTS AND SERVES
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND YOUTH IN LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO PASSER COUNTIES
INVOLVED IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. I SPECIFICALLY IN THE
NON MINOR DEPENDENT ATTORNEY
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY I HAVE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CLIENTS ON MY CASELOAD
AND AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN TIME.
ABOUT 10220% OF MY CLIENTS ARE
HOMELESS THESE ARE YOUTH IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WHO WHEN
THEY WERE SEVENTEEN WERE MEANT
TO BE PROTECTED NOW THAT THERE
EIGHTEEN ARE MEANT TO FIGURE IT
OUT THEMSELVES- MY CLIENTS WHO
ARE ON THE STREETS ARE MORE
LIKELY. TO HAVE CONTACT WITH
POLICE MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE IN
SURVIVAL TACTICS TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS HAVE A PLACE TO
SLEEP. I'VE HAD YOUTH WHO WERE
CLEANING HOMES JUST TO BE ABLE
TO SLEEP IN SOMEONE'S CAR IN
THE FRONT YARD- THE NORM IS
WAITING LESSEN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR YOU TO ENTER THESE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS.
CREATES A HUGE DETRIMENT TO OUR
YOUTH THEY ARE ON THE STREETS
DURING THIS TIME- AND IT ALSO
HAS CREATED AN ISSUE IN THE
SENSE THAT MANY OF THE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. HAVE TO CHOOSE VERY
CAREFULLY- WHAT USE ARE ALLOWED
INTO THE PROGRAMS BECAUSE THERE
ARE ONLY SO MANY SPOTS FELT
THIS LEAVES THE MOST HONOR YOU
USE WITH. OP THEY'D TO BE ON
MAY PRETTY. MAN OF. WHO REALLY
JUST DON'T HAVE OPTIONS FOR THE
HOUSE ISN'T THERE. ON ANY. THE
CAN BE PROVIDE TO PROVIDE. MORE
HOUSING BADS THESE YOU WHILE
CAN. THIS OF SIR. SAN MANY OF
THESE YOUTH AND THE TRANSITION
HOUSING PROGRAMS TO DEVELOP
THESE CONNECTIONS WITH ADULTS.
WHICHWE HAVE SEEN AS AN
INDICATOR SIX FOR SUCCESS LATER
IN THEIR LIFE ON AND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM WOULD
INCREASE THEIR SUCCESS AND-
ULTIMATELY- REDUCE A LOT OF
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES FOR YOUTH
EXITING THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR HI. WE MADE IT
IS A LOVELY SEE THAT YOU HAVE
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON YOU
HEARD SOME FROM SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY BUT I
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED-
HOMELESSNESS AS A YOUTH AND
THEN I WAS A SCHOOL TEACHER IN
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE MIGHT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES ALSO EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS- RIGHT NOW I'M
HOUSING SOMEONE WHO IS
DISPLACED FROM THEIR HOUSE IN
OAKLAND BECAUSE THE RENT
SKYROCKETED UNDER HOME HOUSING
SITUATION SO THIS ISSUE AFFECTS
US AND AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM JOHN BYRNE
ADVOCATES FOR USE THERE ISN'T
FEDERAL FUNDING. TO SERVE USE
THAT FROM THE TIME I WAS A
CHILD THROUGH ALL THE WAY
THROUGH MY TIME AS A TEACHER TO
TODAY AS AN ADVOCATE THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING HASN'T CHANGED
AND IT DOES TAKE STATE
LEADERSHIP SOMETIMES TO CHANGE
THOSE PATTERNS AND SOME VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE THING THE
LEGISLATURE'S LOOK TO DO OR ASK
FOR SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FELTING AS OTHERS HAVE
MENTIONED YOU SET ASIDE IN THE
BUDGET- THAT HAPPENS THIS YEAR
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THE LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET
HOWEVER IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN WE
DO NEED THESE RESOURCES. AND
YOU KNOW OVER FOR ALL WAY
BROWSE PAYING ON HOW CAN AND
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE LEADER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I'M NEED
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY I'M A PROVIDE WORLD
AND FOR SEVEN MY NAME IS SUE
EVAN WE PROVIDE TRANSITIONAL
HOW TO FUSS TO YOUTH IN
COUNTIES DIEGO SOMEBODY KNOWS
WITH A SIGH AND LA WE PROVIDE
TO OVER TO AND THIRTY HOUSING
ON ONE DAY I'M HERE TO SHARE
WITH CRITICALLY WIDE ABOUT THE
SITUATION LA WITH THE RISING
RENTS WE IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS CAN NO LONGER FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS SAFE
NEIGHBORHOODS BEEN NOT PREPARED
TO PLACE A YOUTH IN A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND WE ARE
HOPING TO LIMIT HOW MANY YOUTH
WE CAN ACCEPT WHICH IS
HEARTBREAKING ON ANYONE THEY WE
CAN RECEIVE TEN APPLICANTS-
WITH SEEING AN INCREASE
INSPECTION LA OF THE APPLICANTS
WERE COMING FROM HOMELESSNESS
AND WE'RE EXTREMELY WIDE ABOUT
THE CRITICAL SITUATION- WE ARE
WORKING A LOT WITH THE VET VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS ABOUT A
PREGNANT TO. PAYMENT AND THE
DESPERATELY NEED HOUSE. SAY
WITH HEY TO SEE. TO AND AB TWO
A EIGHTY. AND ALSO CARVE OUTS
AND ALL THE OTHER AND FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT HOMELESS
YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED. I WANTED
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
MEMBERS AND THANKS FOR STICKING
OUT TO THE AND I KNOW I'M SURE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TIRED ON I'M FROM
TWO IMPORTANT TOPIC. I AGREE-
I'M SIMONE DIRECTLY I'M WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
AS WELL- SUPPORT ALL OF THE
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MADE AND I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WE BOTH NEED A
PREVENTATIVE TACTICS TO PREVENT
YOU FROM BECOMING HOMELESS
OBVIOUSLY. AS WELL AS
ADDRESSING ISSUES FACED BY
CURRENT HOMELESS YOUTH AND I
THINK PART OF THE PREVENTATIVE-
SIDE OF IT IS CONTINUING TO
IMPROVE OUR FOSTER SYSTEM FOR
OLDER YOUTH- PART OF THAT IS
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT THE
SUPPORT OF PLACEMENT TIAS PAN
DE. IS ACCEPTABLE AND IS NOT
COMPROMISED STILL PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES TO AVOID KIND OF
RESTATING WHAT OTHERS HAVE
STATED I WANT TO SHARE
SOMETHING NEW ABOUT THE TING
BILL. AT SUMMER FILLED HANGS ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO THE APPROACH THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL WITH WELL
VETTED- A PREVIOUS BILL. WERE
TEST THE TO AN EMPTY RATE I'M
FOR THIS REASON AND THERE IS A
WORK GROUP CAN BY MET FOR TIME
AND LOOK AT A NUMBER OF
APPROACHES THIS APPROACH THAT
INCLUDED IN THAT BILL WAS
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED SO I JUST
WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE AS
WELL THAT IT'S TAKES THE RIGHT
APPROACH- AND AS WE'VE LANDED
ON THANK YOU. WHAT AND I DO
WANT TO COMMENT THAT. MY
COLLEAGUES WERE NOT HERE WITH
SO MANY HEARINGS GOING ON IN.
ANY SINGLE DAY AND THE FACT
THAT WE HAD SO MANY OF THEM
HERE FOR THIS HEARING I THINK
IS A TESTAMENT TO HOW IMPORTANT
THIS THIS TOPIC IS. TO THEM AND
TO THEIR TO THEIR DISTRICTS-
BUT THEY ALL HAD MORE THAN ONE
HEARING AT THE SAME TIME AND
THEY DON'T ALL GET TO SAY THAT
THEY HAVE TO LEAVE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ANOTHER HEARING. BUT
PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT THE FACT
THAT WE HAD SO MANY OF THEM
HERE REALLY SAID A LOT ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT THIS TOPIC IS.
POINT WELL TAKEN AND I THINK I
THINK EVERYONE HERE APPRECIATES
THAT CERTAINLY- AND WE CAN SEE
HOW COMMITTED ALL I'M EVERYONE
IS YES TO THE- THANK YOU. HELLO
MY NAME IS ALEXIS PETERS I'M
WITH THE SPIRIT THAT WE ARE
PROVIDER THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I WE RUN A T. H.
P. PROGRAM FROM TO AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE. I
WANTED TO SHARE A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING THE YOUTH THAT ARE
COMING INTO OUR PROGRAMS ARE
COMING USUAL THERE EITHER CLOSE
TO HOME ONCE OR THEY ARE HOME
WAS. A SLEEPING IN THEIR CARS
VERY VERY COMMON IF THEY HAVE A
CAR AND A LOT OF COUCH SURFING.
OF AND ALSO WE'RE SEEING-
THEY'RE COMING OUT OF GROUP
HOMES AND I'M GETTING THE PHONE
CALL SAY THEY NEED PLACEMENT
NOW THEY'RE LEAVE RIGHT NOW.
WEEK WE'RE NON EMERGENCY
PLACEMENT AND THAT'S HOW
THEY'RE TRYING TO TREAT OUR
PROGRAMS AT THIS POINT. SO
DEFINITELY WE NEED HELP WE SHE
WE NEED MORE FUNDING TO OPEN
MORE BEDS AND ALSO TO HELP WITH
THE RENTS BECAUSE THE RENTS
KEEP GOING HI HI I'M HERE AT MY
PROGRAMS HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND WE'RE CLOSE TO EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH JUST
FOR A TWO BEDROOM TWO BATH
APARTMENT. AND WE DO TWO
PEOPLE. PER APARTMENT AND IT'S
HARD TO SUSTAIN UP WITH WHAT IS
COMING AND SO. MY BUDGET TAKES
THE HIT EVERY YEAR AND WE NOTE
THAT SO BUT WE'RE HERE FOR THE
YOUTH. SO ANYWAY HER SUPPORT
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND IN TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING FOR YOUTH IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU. HI THIS IS
AN INDEFINITE WHICH ARE NOW
JUST JUST. POURED OF UP AND
BOTH HE I. THAT WE PROVIE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE EXTENT FOSTER PROGRAM.
IT'S A REGION WE ALLOW ANY
PEOPLE TO GO HOME. BUT NOT A
TWO MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL. EXTRA CARE AND I LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF STATE WE
CAN'T LET IN GO I AM A ABOUT A
THIRD OF GOING ALMOST. POINT
THAT HAVE TO BE AND THAT'S
COULD ALSO I JUST WANT TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF ANY HOMELESS PRO
PACKET IS FOR ME SURE THERE'S A
DEAD A. THANK YOU IT WILL BE
THERE WITH THAT ONE OF THE IS
THAT I CARRYING WILL RICK. THE
ANY. MONEY THAT IS PROVIDED BY
THE- WILL INCLUDE A PERCENT
SAID A- FOR OUR OUR YOUTH. THAT
IS ONE OF THE BILLS. THANK YOU.
KEN LEWIS REPRESENTING THE HELP
COALITION FOR YOUTH I WANT TO
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER ASSN AND
STAFF IT WITH A WONDERFUL
HEARING TODAY AND THE
BACKGROUND- WORK THAT WENT
BEHIND THE SCENES TO GET THAT
BACKGROUND PAPER IS VERY WELL
WRITTEN I'M AND I WAS REALLY
EXCITED BY THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AND I THINK IT REALLY
ELEVATES THE NEED FOR THE ON
GOING FUNDING AND ADDRESSING
THE ISSUES THAT I MISTER DEATH
RIDGE RAISED AROUND YOU KNOW IT
IF WE HAVE HISTORICALLY ARE
INVESTED IN THE SYSTEM DOES NOT
A SURPRISE FOR THE GROWING
CHRONIC COMMONSENSE POPULATION
OF TODAY. AND TO AS SOMEONE OR
STONE'S POINT OF HOW DO WE GET
AHEAD OF THE US AND I THINK IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE ANY ON
GOING FUNDING IN ANY POP BUT
THIS LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS IT
REALLY HAS TO FOCUS ON THE
YOUTH BECAUSE THEY ARE OUR
FUTURE AND THEY DO GREW UP TO
BECOMING ADULTS AND SO I THINK
IT IS IMPERATIVE HONEST YOU
ENSURE THAT THEIR ON GOING FUND
THERE IS SET ASIDE FOR IF.
BECAUSE WE WENT MOST CAN THAT
PEOPLE. THIS PICTURE AND- IS A
YOUNG PEOPLE. TO STAY A SPECIAL
WHERE YOU WERE UNDER EIGHT.
THERE AT NOT TRYING TO RETURN
TO. HOME THAT THEY- THEY LAY.
THAT WERE IN SAFE. THEM AND SO
WE REALLY NEED TO CREATE. SAYS
AN HAVING IN OUR- OPPORTUNE.
FOR THEM TO COME IN TO FIND
SAFE. TO GET THEIR IMMEDIATE
NEEDS MET. AND BE ABLE TO
TRANSITION THEM TO WHAT WHAT
IS. WORKING FOR THEM AND WHAT
IS GOING TO WORK WHETHER THAT
IS. EMPLOYMENT WHETHER THAT IS
EDUCATION OR COMBINATION AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
STABILIZE AND SUPPORT THEM TO
BECOMING SUCCESSFUL STABLE
ADULTS. AND I ARE YOU HERE ON
THE PANEL TODAY WERE. WERE
TESTIMONIES AND WITNESSES TO
WHAT CAN HAPPEN ONE OF THE
POSSIBILITIES WHEN WE CAN
INTERVENE AND WE CAN PROVIDE
SERVICES. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
ONES WHO WEREN'T INTERVENED
WITH HIM ONE OF THE ONES WHO
WEREN'T LUCKY ENOUGH TO. TO GET
THAT ONE BUT THAT WAS OPEN.
BECAUSE TEN YEARS AGO WHEN
CHAIR I IT ACTUALLY DID A
REPORT AROUND. THIS IS THERE.
FOR YOU THEN THE STATE IN
TWENTY TEN A WE ONLY HAD TWENTY
COUNTY SO. DEDICATED PACIFIC
FOR YOU. AND SO YOU KNOW IT
TOOK IN A DARYL'S PROGRAM. ONE
PROGRAM AND THE LAST COUNTY IN
THE STATE. WE NEED THOSE IN THE
PROGRAMS AT THE ENTIRE STATE BY
A PROJECT. WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH YOU TWENTY NINETY FIVE.
AND SUPPORTING THE EFFORT.
FORTH. THESE PLACE A T. H. P.
AND MD PROVIDER. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
NON MINOR DEPENDENCE AND YOUTH
BUT WE ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN OUR FACILITIES AND
SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT A RATE INCREASE FOR
TEACH P. AND MD. AND THANK YOU
FOR THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING. THANK YOU ALL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG AND FIND
OUT ALL ABOUT HIS BILL BECAUSE
I'M GONNA HAVE TO JOIN THAT TO
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT WE
THAT I PROVIDE WHAT WHATEVER
WHATEVER HELP I CAN GIVE- I
WANT TO THANK I WANT TO THANK
THE PUBLIC WHO GAVE THEIR
COMMENT I APPRECIATE YOUR
STAYING TILL THE END SO THAT
YOUR VOICE CAN ALSO BE HEARD- I
WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS
ALSO FOR TAKING THE TIME TO BE
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
TO HEAR FROM THE PROGRAMS FROM
THOSE WERE STUDYING THE ISSUES
FROM THOSE WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH. HOMELESSNESS AS YOUTH
AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING SO- SINCE
THEN AND HOW YOU OVERCAME IT
THERE'S A LOT TO BE LEARNED
FROM ALL OF THIS THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM-
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER STONE HE
HAS BEEN AT THE ALTAR IN THE
ARCHITECT OF LOTS LEGISLATION
THAT HAS TO DO WITH OUR LIST
YOU THEIR FOSTER YOUTH. AND A
BUTTON TREMENDOUS. ANYTHING
WITH MISTER GIBSON SOME MEN OF
THE OTHER. WHO CAME TODAY
BECAUSE WANTED TO BE INVOLVED
IN THIS. THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE
AND YOU ALL HAVE SET IT. TO NOT
INITIAL WE'RE GOING TO RESOLVE
IN A YEAR AND TWO YEARS AND
FIVE YEARS. BUT WE ASOLUTELY
BETTER GET STARTED WITH THIS
AND WE BETTER BE SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS AND WE BETTER EXCEPT THAT
THIS IS A SEGMENT OF SOCIETY OF
HOMELESS SOCIETY ON HOW SOCIETY
THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN
SOMEBODY ONE OF THE COMMENTS
WAS THAT THIS IS THE THIS IS.
OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR YOUTH I ABSOLUTELY. AGREE
THIS IS OUR RE. AND AS MOST
STONE SAID IT SHOULDN'T BE JUST
UP TO TWENTY ONE JUST UP TO
TWENTY FOUR EAT IT THERE HAVE
BEEN EFFORTS TO TRY TO INCREASE
THAT IN THE COMMENT WAS MADE.
WE HAVE TO WORK ORDER AT THE- A
LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE BUT I
KNOW THAT JUST BY LISTENING TO
THE COMMENTS FROM ALL OF YOU
FROM OUR PANELISTS FROM. FROM
THOSE WHO CAME ALL THE WAY FROM
SANDRA YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THAT
I'M GOING TO JUST THANK YOU SO
MUCH- BUT I THANK YOU ALL FOR
PROVIDING THE INPUT WILL. IF
CAN WRITE NOTES WE WERE GOING
TO LOOK TO SEE WHAT THE PACKAGE
IS GOING TO INCLUDE AND FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ALREADY HAVE
BILLS IN THESE AREAS I WILL BE
REACHING OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE INCLUDE. IN ALL OF THOSE
BILLS ID THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR HELP
US FOR TO A LOOSE. THANK YOU
HAVE WONDERFUL EVENING. THANK.
ANYONE IS.